[Music]
n
he
[Music]
n
yo yo my check real what's going on on
this glorious Sunday we doing out here
let's do a roll call right quick see
what's going on in the
realm my man hey
fan what's going on let me know how my
levels are sounding how we doing out
here hey fan what's going
on no doubt no doubt lyan Master what's
going on I see you oh man ACG up okay up
early for
you salute keep up the good work enjoy
your Sunday thank you brother you are
missed man I feel like I haven't talked
to you in a while ACG we got to get you
back in the realm man I need those takes
I need those opinion those game reviews
love what you do brother always great
seeing you and you are definitely miss
we got to get you back in the r bro let
me know and we got Louis Luis jenez
salute yeah I forgot about the T it was
good getting that extra hour to sleep
though I like that extra hour woo
refreshed King liked it too I call it
was funny no more Oscar what's going on
the brightest Sun salute went the BL con
okay okay live Supremacy what's going on
L and mass I see you Zach Riley uh oh
Gerald Mack the OG what's going on Chris
salute once we got popn what's going on
this pain salute but was in the building
God Soul Kristen r i see you project
Aries okay theend y Taco yo I did not
get to w taels y I've been playing so
much Tekken right now I've become a
fiend like I'm back in my old days and
just I just want play eight so bad I
just been playing Tekken 7 on on the raw
I'm playing Tekken 7 on on um XBox
whoever I can play play teken I just
been playing Tekken all the new
character reveals got me super hyped you
already know geek the sneak I like that
man no doubt so we going to get y'all up
in here adct is here you know what I'm
saying he in the background chilling and
black conflict X my man powers to the
people salute you know what I'm
saying love that name oh yeah we going
to get King up in here everybody and you
know have a good show we got topic to
talk about things to get into the whole
Round Table and all that so we looking
forward to a fun one but anyway let me
get rocking I will get the rest of the
Lords and see what's going on talk to Y
soon here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y to messed up and turn me to an
animal and heades be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's but I addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's aring up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the range you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still coal I got let's Swit
that Stop N that was dope keep that keep
that keep that going keep that going n
Go ahead look I guess you could say that
I'm very spoiled feel them to be your
dog they very loyal but I ain't going to
hold you I ain't heard the boy you you
ain't got to say it I'm embarrassed for
you always been a nerd never been a
loser making Vault Tron with a gang of
cougers and I'm going places better tell
a uber cuz it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that are pulling up
to the iron Lords podcast right now as
we speak and uh I guess I'm here to keep
you entertained until it's time to get
this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being aable and they say I'm better than
money because you can Bank on me being
accountable I know a million rappers
that don't want to be on the song with
me that's understandable I kill a beat
and they want to compare me to Freddy
and Jason I rather be Hannibal they be
like I use a video game just be original
y'all to Dramatical I know it's random
but I am addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable this is that
this is that Yoga Fire Flame they think
it's Saron up in the apartment they call
it department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the range you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless back
we was messaging people on a check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm antisocial
love my city but I'm still by coal I got
let's switch that what did you do don't
stop that was dope keep that keep that
keep that going keep come go ahead look
I guess you could say that I'm very
spoal feel to be your dog thing very
loyal but I ain't going to hold you I
ain't heard the boy you ain't got to say
it I'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making Vault
Tron with a gang of cougars and I'm
going places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am and
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all messed up and turn me to
an animal and heades be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
be and they want to compare me to Freddy
and Jason I rather be Hannibal they be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all to Dramatical I know it's
random but I'm addicted to flipping the
sample and making INF flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's sing up in the apartment they
call a department and I get the blame
still I'll be running collecting the
range you just a Target when I'm in the
range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still by coal I got let's switch
that
up don't stop that was dope keep that
keep that keep that going keep that
going n Go ahead look I guess you could
say that I'm very spoil to be your dog
thing very loal but I ain't going to
hold you I ain't heard the boy you you
ain't got to say it I'm embarrassed for
you always been a nerd never been a
loser making Vault Tron with a gang of
cougar and I'm going places better tell
a uber because it's pretty hard to sleep
on Fredy KRW
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lord's podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a canable and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know what million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's sarson up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting and range you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
of started regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM got check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm antisocial
love my city but I'm still by Coastal I
got Letch that what did you do don't
stop that was dope keep that keep that
keep that going keep that going n Go
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoil feel them to be your dog they very
loyal but I ain't going to hold you I
ain't heard the boy you you ain't got to
say it I'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
Vault Tron with a gang of cougar and I'm
going places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and head be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Aron up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the r you just a Target when I'm in the
range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my VOC on Twitter
but I'm anal love my city but I'm still
Co I
[Music]
got's keep keep that keep that going
keep that going n Go ahead look I guess
you could say that I'm very spoil to be
your dog thing very loyal but I ain't
going to hold you I ain't heard the boy
you ain't got to say it I'm embarrassed
for you always been a nerd never been a
loser making Vault Tron with a gang of
cougars and I'm going places better tell
a uber cuz it's pretty hard to sleep I'm
Fredy crew good
that's let's do that
again here you hear you man and welcome
to the show if you would not mind go
ahead and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they they can saring up in
the apartment they call department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the range you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
of start regardless back we with
messaging people on a check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm antisocial love
my city but I'm still by coal I got
let's Swit that what did you do don't
stop that was dope keep that keep that
keep that going keep that going n Go
ahead look I guess you can say that I'm
very spoil feel to be your dog they very
loyal but I ain't going to hold you I
ain't he the boy you you ain't got to
say it I'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
vultron with a gang cougar and I'm going
places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y to messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be handable
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Aron up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
and r you just a Target when I'm in the
range I was the hardest start regard
back when you was messaging people on a
check my vocs all on Twitter but I'm
anti love my city but I'm still by coal
I got let's
[Music]
Swit keep that going go ahead look I
guess you could say that I'm very spoil
to be your dog they ain't very loyal but
I ain't going to hold you I ain't heard
the boy you ain't got to say it I'm a
barass for you always been a nerd never
been a loser making Vault Tron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell a uber cuz it's pretty hard
to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um
look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being aable and they say I'm better than
money because you can Bank on me being
accountable I know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable I kill a beat and
they want to compare me to Freddy and
Jason I rather be Hannibal they be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all to Dramatical I know it's random
but I addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable this is that
this is that Yoga Fire Flame that they
can saring up in your they call a
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the r you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless back
when you was messaging people on a check
my vocals all on Twitter but I'm ano
love my city but I'm still coal I
got don't stop that was dope keep that
keep that keep that going keep that
going n Go ahead look I guess you could
say that I'm very spoil feeling to be
your dog they very loyal but I ain't
going to hold you I ain't heard the boy
you you ain't got to say it I'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making vult TR with a
gang of cougar and I'm going places
better tell a uber cuz it's pretty hard
to sleep on Freddy Krueger
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and head be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a canable and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
[Music]
call Proclaim all cloud and clear a
proclamation of invitation turn not on
me I C the of
theal the River St Lawrence with the
water St through
one and more
I'mma just chill and watch them and
snacks in the attic I wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young whoop
but then they would mistake me for atct
if I can imagine it's cool to give you
some advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cuz if you don't give her that
option you going to be single player
like Sovereign you going to get tossed
in the bushes by King DAV royalty and
not a pretender detrimental to a
Elemental what's a avatar to a knee
Bender I got to be Meo I know it's my
destiny work kind who cares if you fly
if you still a mosquito you swear you
ain't something but really be steo you
like to collect stuff in that's Co but I
got bad news even if you really was that
dude King still be the king of the
statue since a juven I've been cursed
with a curse to be Musical and if you
hate it we'll meet in The Crucible other
than that it's cool and it's beautiful
we let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on the
Sunday is suitable cuz you can listen to
this in your cubicle on the Lord's
day if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cuz you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord's
[Music]
Day
oh I got to send you stuff H mics on
sending stuff with
hot yeah yeah yeah yeah you saw you saw
that joint I putting inside of the chat
though these out here is roasted me baby
they roasted me baby we weren't talking
about confidential things this is this
is what what happens when you comment on
things you haven't played yet see but
the thing is this though these dudes is
they they disingenuous man you know and
yo we gonna get into that had a talk
okay I I I should have wifey bring me uh
my baby my new baby hold on let me let
me call wife what you suming wifey for
what's going you know got
wifey you should say when I was doing um
the whatever the show's called yet last
night uh they they they demanded to see
grace they dued you into show me your
show me this woman just see Grace Grace
coming on the show giving you kisses mid
show you yeah I'll be peeping that
what's doing that [__] on
purpose hey language language language
she's like I'mma let the the realm know
this is
CLA don't get any the ideas
realm she's Canon
exactly here and we are live welcome to
the high Lord podcast LLC and also live
on La gaming.net episode number
329 it's another o glorious Sunday we're
back at the round table on the Lord's
day and
today we've got Bungie
Lambs you there some women do
myt Destiny to Future so gays as a
service pivot BlizzCon 2023 and Call of
Duty Modern Warfare 3 to discuss so we
going to get right into it so let's
introduce the Four Horsemen of gaming
those original gaming nights of the
realm here at the round table my co-host
the Coos my brother from another mother
the difficult game conqueror Lord of his
own world and the how of the young wolf
my man Lord adct back to back of the ad
show how we doing sir doing pretty good
man I'm still coming off the high of
watching uh you know the last episode of
Attack on
Titans I I've been watching that show
since
204 and now it's over wow done and
what's funny is is K don't even know
what the hell that
show he just no no I'm not ha I love no
no he he he's watched two seasons but
the problem is is the attack is one of
the shows where they flip you on your
back in front back like multiple times
like they make you think you know what's
going on and like no you don't know
nothing like he used the wrong
metaphor that was that was definitely
time worthy but we Let It
Rock flip you on your back and I felt
like door open energy
that sto your stomach so uh you I I did
I did react to the final episode is it
on our patreon oh was on patreon yeah
it's on our patreon it's just you know
very good conclusion uh good after all
this I would not I will be not watching
that final episode on the patreon I do
apologize until I watch the show people
don't like the ending but it's just like
you know with everything else like
really popular shows you're never going
to hit everything and it's just like I'd
like for them to hit everything but you
know there's only like one part of man
you are lot today man there's only one
part of of like the last episode that I
was like H they could have did without
but it's it's good man Tacko tit I was
being to tell you whatever y'all I'm
sorry to interrupt whatever you're oh
please finish please finish I was going
to say Tacko Titan will probably go on
to be one of if not my alltime favorite
anime oh wow what I was going to tell
you in reference to it cuz um you're
getting a lot of good positive response
with the patreon and spoilercast and
things you guys are doing they they keep
talking about adct gotta watch the end
credit credit SC they saying that you
miss oh you did okay I just want to make
sure that you saw it cu the the patreons
and the chat they kept mentioning that I
was want to say okay yeah it's it's
uh I get it people like you got people
be acting like they they like
foreshadowing a new show no they're not
so they do it too much yeah all they
were doing is showing the significance
of the whole thing with that the whole
point of the show like f it's good and I
finally beat Persona 5 Royale 100% it my
guy that's up right before it left Game
Pass I grabbed the reaper and Dr
I grabbed the reaper and drowned him in
the uh you drowned him you took him in
the deep water Dred drowned in I drowned
him in in the momentums what's funny
is after I figured out how to beat him I
beat I killed him like eight times Terr
and then I was told after I beat the
game because I was like well I needed to
level up they're like dude why did you
just do the reaper cheese I'm like what
do you mean the reaper cheese apparently
you could go in Persona 5 you could
switch to easy mode cuz how it goes is
the mo when you go to easy mode the
moment you go to a a rest stop or
anything like that or or a rest area it
saves that easy mode so you could go
switch to easy mode or no it's called
safe mode switch to safe mode sa mode
when you kill the reaper he'll kill you
with one hit but the problem with safe
mode is you automatically get revived so
you can kill the Reaper don't matter
what level you want you could kill the
reaper get like 400,000 XP cuz you're
not supposed to kill the reaper right
and then what you do is you just you
fight them again and die and when you go
back to the rest area it's all normal
again you're not supposed to be able to
switch it from from safe to normal but
if you die when you come back you keep
your XP because that's how Persona so D
just chees in the level that's crazy I
was I was a little upset I was like that
could have been very
useful could have been very useful adct
is all about the exploits exactly he on
his exploit joke no D I see you I see
you tried to get your cat in the frame
but yeah yeah cat jumped on I cuz he
heard cuz he heard Bella was here he was
like
yeah cats versus dogs anyway no doubt
salute to uh the show and everything
that you've been doing and stuff like
that and the Persona finally done I know
you've been doing that for a long time
I'm four right now Beast loving the
Mario Kart Shirt By the way and and of
course we have our most technical gaming
Lord the solo gamer list for the single
player selfish experience and also the
srus the Lord of clarity and Lord patent
of the iron bank PC Master Race's
own hopefully getting some rest Lord
offing he's muted you're you're muted
he's
muted my apologies the cops are Wilding
it's always Sunday man Sunday everybody
wants to go wild I'm stay stay in your
house relax it's when I do Define Duke
on Wednesday it's always they just feel
like it's it's going down don't don't do
the crimes on Sunday you know the Lord's
Day speaking of which someone was
recently murdered where I live which
doesn't ever happened here but chill
that's crazy yeah yeah yeah so the
murder went down oh my God like that you
got to say you can't say that on YouTube
you have to say unal living the unal
Living went down you can say that you
can't say
like you can't say that you know if they
canel their self yeah you can't say that
so yeah so uh yeah this was actually
sibling on sibling crime apparently oh
damn yeah not good not good not good not
good but but uh apart from me not being
un alive yes uh I did I I just I shut
myself off in the world yesterday and I
gamed King called me at 8:30 in the
morning and I looked at it I was like
I'll call you later I'll text you
you tell the truth Shane the devil he he
sort of look he like oh hell no I turned
around and went to we thought we were
all concerned for you yeah but when he
calls me I wake up in a panic like oh my
God same sof I'll be nervous but we call
him he's like yeah uhhuh yeah y call me
I'm like all right it's it's some money
thing it's like okay I got it's some
money thing car accident I was in a car
accident sir I could have been dead and
d and I only heard this again I never
get this when it happens I'm taking upd
with this add we only call for a money
thing I put it in the was crashed no
that's not true y call Y do call me when
y'all see I'm not around you're like
wait a minute because even yo AJ called
me AJ's like yo you good man I'm like
yeah I'm all right man what good no I
was worried because we on chat when we
don't see your little icon look at the
message we go yo what's going it's mad
days I thought I thought I didn't even
realize that I was just you know you get
the message and you just kind of flip
down on the phone but you're not
actually going into the chat so it's not
coming up that you're in the chat so
it's yo I didn't realize I was doing
that and then for that reason I look
like I'm not looking at the chat but I
what what you guys are talking about I
let just he was doing it he was doing it
the sneaky way yeah yeah yeah yeah you
know what when you slideing there they
they try to leave you all
already yeah but now now I know the
sneak way it was totally untouchable no
no uhhuh so what you been playing so
yeah yesterday I after I woke up like at
noon I said you know what I'm playing
and I just sat down and play Spider-Man
all day play Spider-Man all day wow
thoughts thoughts thoughts so oh so y y
planned on coordinating these short
shirts today this is I just want no this
was not coordinated no happen I I
literally just threw this song speaking
of Spider-Man uh me and King did a a
spoiler cast on Spider-Man that's right
yes yeah that's up go do that yeah go go
read the in depth uh check out the
in-depth reviews on that um so I finally
started seeing bugs right I finally
started seeing bugs um they were a
little bit annoying I'm really surprised
you didn't see them soon long that's
what I feel no I honestly I saw them
almost immediately yeah I looked out I
guess and but what I did start seeing uh
so one funny one right it was a funny
one where you know when you uh let's say
you you intercept a crime that's
happening on the street and they're
beating up on on a civilian and then
once you once you beat up the bad guys
you take the civilian to the ambulance
yeah you gotta right so I grab picked up
the civilian I made like a very quick
movement and for whatever reason that
detach the civilian from my my character
so the civilian is floating in midair
and then but the but the but the the
moment is continuing so I'm like okay
that civilian thing's mad glitch cuz it
got to the point where I wasn't even
picking him up I you just sit there like
it was the SSD it's the SSD though
you there was two times it glitched out
where I had a recheck point but then I
realized maybe it was just I don't know
why but if I didn't pick him up and I
waited a couple seconds he went away and
it's still completed so I like okay you
can walk your yourself to the that's
exactly what happened like for mind the
dude stayed frozen in midair he was like
laying down like this mid
mid so I you know once I saw I saw that
the icon was still live right the icon
was still live so I swung over there by
myself and and I acted out the whole
thing you're GNA be okay whatever and
then and it gave me like the mission was
was complete so I was like all beautiful
that's hilarious now another one that
was a little bit annoying but again I
have to I have to at least thank them
for I mean their checkpointing
checkpoint system oh thank God it's a
savior because this was a moment where I
fought um you know this is not a spoiler
but Craven's Army whatever um and it was
a multiple waves of these dudes coming
at me it was it was a long combat
scenario okay and at the end you know
you're supposed to tell you once you
beat them it'll tell you the next thing
to do yeah and I'm like n I'm looking
around I don't see anybody it says
defeat them defe defeat uh Cravens
whatever minions whatever I'm looking
around I'm scanning the environment like
where are these dudes at I'm looking at
the mini map one dude stuck in the
environment underneath the staircase
right
I go to the staircase his head is
sticking up so I like maybe I can just
beat up on his head and pause
pause so I kicked him once and that
kicked him completely into the staircase
so he was done I could get I can't get
to him now so I was like all right I
said let me restart so I'm I was hoping
I was like you know there multiple
phases to this so I'm like maybe it'll
keep me no I had to go do the whole phas
again again and the combat is great but
I'm like I don't want to do this again
cuz that's the first combat scenario
where I noticed I was like damn this is
drawn out like why I drawing this
scenario out so much so that was a
little bit annoying but apart from that
um I got a I got a good amount of time
in real quick so there is a glitch
there's these things later on in the
game that you have to clear you have to
put like a bomb on them it's like one of
those little events I'm sure King can
speak to for that so the whole point is
you put these things up and you it it
will you have to wait out a few seconds
and then they explode King tell me how
people found out you skip all that you
don't got to wait that time when you
start the event if you switch your
outfit when you go back it's done wow oh
that's wild wow yeah shout out to that
buggy gang that wasn't like that in the
other
two but room isn't burning though it's
we're fine I have to say after seeing
that I was just like it it is just so
unlike Insomniac yeah it's just that's
just what it is like I'm like okay maybe
they was disgruntled cuz they wanted
them to do games and service yo
you you are ridiculous continue
Wolverine is going to be a game as a
maybe maybe Bungie came in and was
ah
ridiculous Overlord
Bungie maybe they had a Gams of service
in development and bunge candy like we
we ain't about this life yo the games
and servers was into the Spidey
verse like nah that's not going to work
they had a Spider-Man pizza delivery
game yo you know what funny yo maybe
Bungie is actually sabotaging them
because they don't want no game better
than
Destiny you crazy like n you're getting
whack that's a high game that's
idea time continue so storywise
storywise I'm enjoying it I I'm I'm
particularly enjoying the the level of
kind of depth that they're giving Craven
I like that I like what they're doing
with Craven um Craven's A Beast right
yeah I'm still not a fan I'm not a fan
of miles's voice whatsoever wait wait
hold on the Puerto Rican delegation we
do not
approve his voice is is but since he
became the teenager his voice is no good
a heard King miles is CID he ain't Pro
real
I I wanted to know how they going do
theb suit later his mom his his mom's
Puerto Rican vernacular perfect
beautiful but she's full Puerto Rican
though but she's full Puerto Rican right
so it's not about him when he speaks
Spanish that's fine I I completely
understand that I know plenty of of of
of kids that are fully of Puerto Rican
descent or Latin descent and speak that
way because they they just don't speak
you know Spanish that's fine it's just
his his the way he speaks English is not
it is he wants he wants a New York voice
and it's not even it's not even more
Thug doubt it's not even he just seems
like he is not from here hey y hey y
hey he sounds more California to me yeah
I can't I can't so and it's not even
it's not a bad performance overall right
I think the way he the emotions and all
that stuff is there it's the voice that
is killing me I can't do
it let me see what else so as a result
of playing Spider-Man what I have done
is I have put Allan Wick to the side for
now because what I realized is I tried I
I I looked into putting it on the Rog
and this game is super demanding it
ain't doing
that it would diminish it it people got
running it could be done it would
diminish it to the point where I don't I
need Ser s is rocking that though no
it's
not being
messy you being messy all that hot stuff
on so being that
I I want to play it with the path
tracing and all the hot stuff and with
the lights out and the headphones on
I'mma finish Spider-Man and then I'mma
focus on that afterwards um so then a
little bit more Mario Wonder right still
just couple levels here couple levels
there beautiful wonderful enjoying it
I'm playing playing yeah yeah and then
and then I I I spoke briefly to Cog
about this and I hadn't I hadn't
listened to Duke yet so I didn't know
you you were playing it because I was
surprised that you knew about this game
so it's a game and game pass called so
very
French like ch
just like rock like CH
Rock You better watch out for blue
face you stupid continue so I gotta say
man I'm I'm a climbing fool when it
comes to climbing in video games I mean
all the climbing and double jumping I
always feel like I'm breaking something
when I'm able to do that right I
remember back in the day on the Master
System and Ron that us jump from wall to
wall like oh man was the that had the
sword down too with a triple jump you
about to have a heart attack yeah we
lose our mind no man don't know how
obviously Mario going back and forth
don't be a hunter on
Destiny yeah yeah we lose it but like I
mean literally going all the way
obviously breath of the Wild games like
um what the hell is that game obviously
uh Shadow of the Colossus things like
that I love climbing right um and in VR
The Climb one and two ns are crazy so
good kaisa put me on your brother put me
on that yeah so but I it's always been a
thing where the mechanics of it right
get try to try to um emulate the real
mechanics of climbing right obviously
it's a game but emulate as best as
possible you know who did it real good
call it a mountain in the
VR cuz that that's very much like that's
that's that's the aloy Nathan Drake Type
where it's like oh you just you never
get tired you just climb you jump from
ledge toed yeah so this game is all
about it it it Maps your hands to the
trigger
so it's all about you finding the
handholds to go up and then it does
something very cool which is if in
climbing in real life um you can it's
it's probably not advisable to start
crossing over hands like that if you can
help it right because of balance issues
so what it allows you to do is reach up
to a handhold reach up with your other
hand to that same handhold and switch
off rest your hand yes and then continue
on right uh you could game on fire too
and just cross over like this and climb
like you're like you know like Nathan
Drake you could do that if you want but
you're going to start seeing your
stamina go down yes and I don't really
know what the game is about I know it
has to do with this kid climbing this
mountain and there's a civilization
that's lived on this mountain he learns
about the civilization that he's going
up but I don't know the overall the
overall premise of it and your little
man's in the back yeah well I he's I
heard him going but he hasn't come out
he he come out soon yeah he come out the
P you going to see what that's when the
whole situation going to change that's
when it changes I Haven even got to that
so but the climbing mechanic has me so
enamored because I have not seen it that
way before like literally you rest your
hands and you put your hands behind you
and shake them out the only thing he
doesn't have is the is the the the chalk
pouch right modern climbers have but
other than that just that well his skin
is naturally rough though they tell you
in the beginning the reason why he
orange like that cuz his skin is
naturally he got he's a born gripper
P continue um and as you start going up
and you start seeing the scale of the
mountain and you look down at what's
beneath you it's a real beautiful moment
again it evokes those moments of like
climbing the colossi and stuff like that
or breath of the wild when you're
climbing did y'all see that guys he cuz
some fools out there would have say
climbing the
kassas right he gave you this is why we
got him here that's why we got him here
that's why we got him because he he's
the best in the business and what
guy we got to get like voice over
something like we we developers we got
to holl my man it's true like he's dead
nice with it I'm ready I'm ready he
ready yeah coloss get back to the col I
love I love that feeling of just sort of
like being out there I told you guys a
couple years ago when I watched that um
documentary free solo about Alex honold
and free soling you talk about that guy
that died right no he a die he he oh he
didn't die I thought you talk about the
other guy the super strong dude plenty
of other dudes have died this dude this
dude is is special like he really is
like he's not phased by it he he
respects it up to the utmost he trains
like nobody's business but he he has a
thing where he's able just to put the
fear there's no fear like he he prepares
and he's ready for everything that he
does and he's able just to push the fear
back and not freak out and the one time
I saw him freak out he literally he
turned around he's he's standing on a
mountain he's leaning back on the
mountain like this he's looking out out
forward he's like I don't know if I
could do this and like 10 minutes later
he composed himself turned right around
finish the climb that's cuz really when
you when you get to a certain point
climbing you're not going down yeah it's
all the only way out is up so um yeah I
love I love that that when they try to
do climbing in games and this is a very
special little game like it's it's it's
it's you could easily look look over
well it's not what I thought though y
there is a Super Chat that is so so wild
will we get to it for
S it is wild anyway continue so that's
it that that was it so I did like I said
I turned myself off in the world lady sa
was working so I was able to do just
chill and play without any you had your
Blaze okay I got you I got my little I
got my little blaz schedule blazing and
not calling people back yeah that's what
up I like like I let you know I was
alive I love you and I appreciate the
concern yeah we scared we a see that
icon we just like what yeah I like
where's this little white blank face cuz
he don't got a face in there he just got
some blank dots we had to do the
wellness check when last time he spoke
to like I don't know how you speak to me
all right cool and of course we have the
Incredible Hulk of this aka the EXs
gamer oh the prophet of Xbox swamy King
of the statues who demands nothing less
than that premium experience and is the
unequivocal leader of the advanced alive
no man oh beloved Lord King how we doing
I'm doing fantastic today everybody say
hi to Bella Rose Johnson oh it was a
eight hour trip to go get her yesterday
to Washington DC and it was nuts she is
a Boston ter sleepy sleepy no she wants
to get upstairs and go play with cooko
Chanel Johnson they were having a good
time yesterday so she's like this is
Daddy he is the alpha
I love him uh cuz when we picked him up
you know they they she came out of a
little car they was driving little car
you know why you got to shave their car
no no it is what it is you know what I'm
saying so we pulled up so you know we
hopped out what's crazy is yo so I was
all right so for Halloween um I was
riding around with the Michael Myers
suit on and playing the Michael Myers
music all right so the people pull up
they text me and they like um yeah we
here we in the BMW I'm like all right
cool hop out as we hop out I have my
music on wait and you had the Michael
mes with the dicky suit check it I had
no Dicky
suit dick the dick suit on there St play
so I hop out but as I hop out my my
music was on random on my phone yeah we
open the doors tell me why the Michael
Myers music come on now it's at night
it's at
night
this is not a this is not a pet exchange
this is a setup yeah this is a set up
son we just sitting the get you so I was
like oh
[__] turn turned it off right we got out
and you know we we we got her and you
know she got in the car she was like oh
this is big big oh oh we moving up this
our Uncle Phil he Uncle Phil oh so she
she's in the fresh place of B like she
her life she she moved from Philly she
different she a b there yeah yeah so she
in Washington DC pop but um not no more
you in Westchester
baby you're Westchester baby now so so
she was born July 12th okay and um she's
about to go get all her shots and
everything go get chipped up yeah cuz
you got to get chipped up we gota be
able to find you when we get crazy but
she a chill pup she get a little
rambunctious when you know she with Coco
she now cuz Coco Coco came in she was
like y what's up what's this yeah what's
going on what's up with you you know I'm
saying I I run the
show show yeah you know what I'm saying
I was like y calm down calm down but she
did poo poo outside today took her to
the backyard she did poo poo she did pee
PE and she's a good girl so um what I've
haven't been playing was uh Modern
Warfare 3 and I seen a lot of you guys
coming at me so you know I'll be playing
that this week uh what I have been
playing is um Allan Wake 2 so I finished
the Spider-Man I Platinum Spider-Man oh
oh so for all you dudes that be capping
for Sony that don't even own Spider-Man
probably don't even got PlayStation but
Playstation number one in your heart in
your heart I I was with your girl so wow
I Platinum I Platinum J
booo all the bugs and stuff she a little
weird this time but um yo the game is
dope uh but the bugs man it's still a CH
eight uh so Allan Wake though all right
so I get to you I heard you and David
jaffy South talking about this so I'm
like let me get into this wifey sitting
there looking at it she said that's not
the game like the faces that's that's
not the game I said also oh boo boo that
is the game that is the game that's the
game so when it started the naked dude
is doing his thing she like oh my God
what what are you playing and then you
going up to joint and you know stuff
start happening she like oh hell no
what are you playing like and then it
scenes I'm a huge fan of control did
this too like when you go into a new
area they Splash what area it is on the
screen and that's something from Cape fa
if anybody watched the movie with Robert
daerio cap fair and a lot of movies like
that do this thing um I love uh spy
killer Thrillers I love stuff like that
I love um uh detectives types things mhm
this game is all of that and it reminds
me of a film it reminds me of a movie
like of a live playing movie and the
fact that they have remedy has mastered
The Art of Storytelling and
conversations natural conversations
between human beings with facial and
they can take the mundane and make it
spectacular so they are really about the
tech whatever the tech is whatever the
hottest Tech is we're going to get a
grasp of that Tech better than anybody
that's out there and we're going to do
it at a lower cost than anybody that's
out there because arguably this game
looks better than anybody's first party
AAA games this game has so much Tech
layed in the games that y'all like if
you'reall playing it on Xbox or
Playstation y'all not seeing half the
stuff that you're supposed to see when
you get to a high-end
PC would be a PC oh man on yo I mean on
a highend go to digital found
okay okay sounds yeah do your home do
your homework on going to digital
Foundry it hit different um yeah on King
David y'all know what I'm talking about
if yall know yall know
anyway yo I'm telling you this game is
the best looking game this generation so
far oh so far okay okay and I know it
makes Microsoft sick to their stomach
that they had them there
after they did Quantum break and they
did not scoop him yeah I know it wasn't
Phil's uh position at that time
right if they double back now to try to
scoop him the level of how much you got
to pay for these dudes yeah it's
different now um but they're worth it
whatever they're asking
for that three billion whatever Bungie
got give it to him because this is this
is where you're deficient at
yeah yeah yeah you good at multiplayer
games you you're good at that fantastic
these guys got what you are deficient at
and then you can have Jason Ronald and
his
Squad sit down and craft the next
machine around their
ideas and their Tech how they are
working their Tech and I'm guaranteeing
you at the way that they're moving you
will have triaa lowc cost games at a
highest fidelity
way above everybody else and and this
will give you that little genre that
you're missing and they're they're
necessary but also play Mario wonder and
and in your defense um digital Foundry
did the uh the breakdown with the
versions and they saying that the Xbox
version is utilizing mes shaders and
digital finders also saying that that
could be the the real definition
generation definer as it goes on like
the whole R and A2 it seemed like the
the tools remember everything like when
is it going to happen so like
this is the game that you know that're
showcasing a difference in the I
PlayStation 5 struggling I mean I mean
see see that's see Cog is different C
Cog is gonna say nice stuff like you
know this is the differ and he's being
nice he he's learned this from you know
hanging out with other people oh my God
are you are youly LSN F yeah yeah yeah
yeah so how I do it how I do it how you
do yeah PlayStation struggling and this
is the the reason why is cuz they don't
got mes shaders right so all right guys
so this is how it goes digital Foundry
outed you guys and I saw the faces yo
shout out to my boy John lman yeah but
when they were saying so so so this is
why you trying act they sad for the for
the comparison loss the face was kind of
crazy whoever did the edit I don't know
if it was for Tango whoever whoever did
the edit it was the best edit that I've
seen and this they found out that that
PlayStation 5 just was a underpowered
type of [__] but the pro is coming and
y'all can get some m in the ridiculous
it don't look good for you guys and if
all the games going forward use M
shaders you are ridiculous yo do your
homework or you not having mes
shaders the r and a toot fight begins
has been
it that's it so I was having fun with my
mesh
shaders and
of course we have the G dig himself the
shinovi L Cognito friend that Rel to the
Roman IOP not tell you what you want
what you need to hear shout out to
defiling Duke and shout out to Maddie we
talking about we had this fun thing call
it booty
calls like now he's he's in Pocket there
you know what I'm saying you know he's
going to be able to take more control of
certain studios in the whole structure
and San and that whole bit shout out to
the last word we had a mock funeral
service for events that we may be
talking about later or that was cool
shout out to Scarrow shout out to J jar
man Destra a lot of the destiny
Community came through they wanted to
hear what we had to say so it was really
cool and then for me surprisingly I've
regressed I haven't been playing a lot
of the new stuff and I just got to be
real s bro when when Tekken shows
something new the kid in me just CES out
and I don't know if you saw the latest
character reveal yes I did oh you not
feeling my man Victor
so he's voiced he's voiced by Vincent
Cassell right so that's cool they got
they got a power actor to voice him but
I just don't like I I've never been the
biggest fan of guys with weapons weapons
okay no fair fair fair fair I got you
and I did see some feedback from the
Tekken hardcore like yeah I don't know
how I feel about him with the Glock and
the and the thing the sword and fair
enough I just thought the character was
was cool and first of all like Paris
really needed something like Paris was
like FR was like yo when we getting one
for us like cuz now Tekken is so big
it's so International that if you don't
see your country like you feel away now
like away now true it's true so to see
him and and the re and I didn't know
dude from um you know I forgot his real
name what the actor's real name Vincent
Cassel Vincent Cass I didn't know he was
a gamer and a hardcore Tekken fan so
when I see King the reason
it was a goal for me remember when I did
my 40th and I had you all come through
when I came through with the Silver
Surfer I came with the Silver Surfer
threepiece sh this man he he stole my
drip my whole I'm I'mma do who who
rocked it better I'mma put my joint do
that do that do that I'm put it up on
cuz I was like and then with the Unreal
Engine five and you seeing all the
detail and the detail and it and it
glimmers and it sh I didn't I didn't
know how felt about The Sword and the
gun thing and but you know me right now
I'm trying to like stay away because I I
want the game so bad yeah I'm so so
that's what it is it's like I'm fiend so
I'm forced to play seven and and tighten
up and and see what's going so I've been
really doing that and obviously I
touched ju I've been touching that I I
definitely feel that and like I said s
when you go farther you'll see s read
the chat cuz you ain't read the chat he
go we going to get to I I'll get to I've
seen yeah and I like I don't like you
being able to see stuff not seeing
stuff well everything all in due
time but yeah little buddy in the back
he definitely it opens everything up and
what happens is the you're able to
manipulate the world differently and
you'll see where the climb what I like s
is how he puts that little what is it
the pike to stabilize yourself with the
Rope oh yeah EXA that's another thing
yeah you have to you go from place to
place and you and basically you know
uh there's free soing right is using and
then when you're using ropes you're
you're sort of uh you know every couple
whatever feet or whatever you're kind of
stabilizing yourself and something
hammered into the into but what I like
is when you're do you're doing that and
you side run the wall that is a it is
it's just a feeling it's a simple game
but it's just I felt the control
actually felt intuitive like climbing
and then unlike breath of the wild where
let's be honest people get mad when
Zelda's and then he stops and then the
stamina met you like damn I don't got to
go I got to go cook some food and I got
to do something but what I like with
this is It's a overall stamina meter it
does decrease over time but if you hold
still you can get some back you'll get
some back exactly rest if you rest yeah
so that part is fair so anyway that's
pretty much it on and and adct knows
there's a VR game we we can't talk about
just yet that uh we were rocking but uh
yeah that's been pretty much it um Sor
with the super chats me do uh long now
what we doing
okay let me do let me do super chats I'm
start with one last week that we I read
on the initial run before we had to cut
out and start over so I want to uh read
this one it was from Sith Lord so I'm
reread this um it says it's Times Like
These that I appreciate you guys and
Lord beefy I recently
had boy I recently had a friend pass
away so I'm hoping King can help turn
this frown upside down so we did we did
read it but we read it on the first part
of the podcast that is in The Ether now
so yeah rest in peace rest in peace sure
some laughs today that's a that's a lot
of pressure you just put on me though
but I I got you though what's up tic all
right I I've been trying to like use
this like fault thing look uh I if if I
do it right our our Teespring should pop
up in the chat if you do it
right if I do it wrong yeah I just saw I
swag swag I don't know what's going to
happen yeah yeah I saw that I saw the
Twitter though I saw the Twitter go up
before I was like all right okay pick up
some swag so the the swag's not working
I don't know fure it out professional
podcast all do time
exactly shout out to professionalism
professionalism and then before Mo on
also all we have to do is read the super
chats for 15 seconds okay like you can't
expect professionalism for me when you
guys ain't Prof no not you I it's a joke
inally I do it m when we all do off the
rail L attack on you you good you good
you good believe me you good yeah trust
me I'm just joking at all of us all
right there it goes oh there
go
yeah hit the
link I like I like see if the link work
yeah yeah I like I like how adct
figuring everything out for something
for later hey yo stick around stick
around in the show we got something
incredible at the end yeah yeah continue
K King is started a special project yeah
oo no snitching no snitching no
snitching I was going to go somewhere
else with it as the jokes but I'm not
going to go there is nasty is nasty
moving on only fans link later on in the
chat oh yeah he said it not me he said
attic is nasty trying promote you can
promote your side hustle on your own
time yeah you know how he like to do it
the door open
whoa oh
only way whoa it's the only way to fly
pause move it
on don't open it face down chill too
much all right uh also I want to shout
out uh Lord uh dadra AKA Lords nail
killer uh uh hooking up uh one of the
Lords with with a real cool uh little uh
Tekken collector edition as as a sign a
sign of love as a sign of sort of a kind
of like a well mostly love from the
community because of the type of uh it's
for Cog and and and the type of year
that coog is had uh he just wanted to
show a little love especially for you
know how passionate Cog is about Tekken
so uh yeah he ordered something for him
man really beautiful beautiful gesture
and it's a cool thing and I guess it
will arrive uh when the game launches
next month no in two months yeah much
love that is super appreciated again
thank you so much it means it means a
lot okay let me get into these super
attached that
I
messy there for
you first off we got the homie ACG with
the $20 Super Chat keep up the good work
enjoy your Sunday you as well brother
keep up the work you're killing it shout
out shout out to um ACG giving everybody
else a out trying to get out with with
with n y' y only he got
out not y'all Spiderman yeah yeah you he
he who said it first it wins and the
rest of y'all know there's no wins for
y'all then we have Doctor Strange Love
five Super Chat okay it hasn't started
yet he shuts down my presses The Last of
Us factions because of player retention
and stickiness yet they can't even
maintain that with their own game ironic
yes wow irony is is evident yeah no you
can't do you can't work on everybody
else's homework and expect to finish
your own I don't care
it's like you said it's like it's
sabotaging on other games yeah like oh
that's a hot idea you know that ain't
going to work yo that
[__] how you think fortnite got to where
it is they they looked at pubg was like
oh yo give them give them the old engine
you know what's funny you know what's
funny it fortnite is literally getting
back on top from just showing old
content yep oh that's right they going
back OG right now they are
doing what I think Bungie should take
like a huge lesson here like old content
not being Stripped Away is actually
helpful isn't it like yeah people want
to play the original stuff no well the
way epic does it like and I'm not going
to lie in fortnite because I don't like
how the storefront looks right now right
because the storefront is very basic now
and my son is like I said where the rest
of the storefront he said oh no that's
how it was in the beginning I said oh
this is
disgusting I'm used to going to the
store and having a variety of things
that I can pick now in the OG storefront
it's just one little page this is what
it is for the day get down or get or lay
down and I'm like no I don't like this
right here so that's one part y'all
could have just left in the bushes be
I'mma keep that a buck with you but
other than that they they understand the
pulse of the culture I don't know who
they got over there what type of of kids
that they got in there but you can tell
it's fresh new ideas and they aren't
afraid to mess up they just aren shout
out to Bill still in the team over there
at Epic abely yeah true yeah for sure yo
I saw him playing hardcore too oh he
goes in like Bill be playing for sure
get to there Contin then we have a
nintend theotaku $5 Super Chat anyone
concerned about the power of the switch
2 should watch digital foundaries
analysis of what the successors Tegra
t239 could do in terms of performance I
put that in the chat yall saw that yeah
you did put I get a chance to no it's a
video it is Yo that switch too yeah
coming in hot I hope so they they know
full well that they there's no reason
for them not to care about third party
at this point like it's just you're
going to get Call of Duty might as well
make it as good as possible because you
will be the only game in town that apart
from like the Rog or something they can
play that portably why not make it the
best experience it can be so hey that
that's fantastic do can you do do you
think that the fact that they were able
to secure certain deals with
Microsoft lend to them upping the power
in the Box because let's say right you
going in and you're not knowing if you
having third party support then you just
you know craft it to whatever you're
doing but now that you know for a fact
that you're going to have third party
support you just up the specs this is
the first machine without a right so
this this is new Nintendo this is new
Nintendo and even though up until now
they haven't really showed that they're
doing anything necessarily different
except for letting the kids come out and
play and and and and really have put
their imprint on these new games so
maybe the same holds true for you know
console their console and what they
think about in the console space so I
guess we we'll find out but it does not
make any sense to have Call of Duty on
there to be able to have it natively not
a cloud thing only right you're going to
have Call of Duty and not have the best
possible machine to run that portably
when you know that the hardcore if that
game runs a 60 on that you're going to
have plenty of people playing buying two
copies of that game it just happen it's
Cod you know what I mean so uh yeah to
me hopefully the powers at be finally
moved into the 21st century like look
there's no there's no reason to to to to
leave these third party games out of our
thinking there's no reason for it so I
hope that is the case I really do um
then we have we have Nintendo taku $5
again it's crazy y'all have exo mea in
the intro and we don't even know if that
game will ever come out yeah yeah I've
been waiting for that game I'm mad I was
for that game you you know I thought it
it was probably a pretty demo and they
still haven't crafted the game around
yeah probably just conceptual something
yeah take their time with it I don't
care exactly then we have Cedric H let's
put the Crush in the chat for Cedric H
gifting 10 ILP membership thank you
appreciate that yeah blessings then we
got sin Vendetta $10 Super Chat love
Attack on Titan and can't wait to watch
the final episode it was also it also
was released yesterday on my birthday
which was awesome great birthday gift
yeah happy birday what's up yo how many
people watch kenjin aora the third
episode is out and the kid binge watched
it and I'm about to do a reaction to
that on RNR go watch your attack on
Titan don't watch that oh damn yo yo you
know you know yo I sat there and said
you know I biged up your crap I your
whack anime now he trash I biged up your
fluff machine my joint get eight
episodes in this hardcore hard hitting
and they drop them all in y' they spread
y'all out over 30 20 30
years get they let you they LED you down
a dark road cuz cuz they know all good
they know all good things you have to
wait for yeah but sometimes you like to
get it bang bang anyway so they flipped
you on your stomach and on your back you
heard the Stu
doing over here we don't do that that
pan flipping on you yo we get down
flipping we get down to the nitty-gritty
of it you understand quick fast it easy
you got when your stuff crashes Netflix
then we can talk oh he ain't even on a
level he broke the internet yo you broke
it because you had people starve with
the popey
bis they finally said yo we got juice
they thank God it's
over t on iron Lords anime tune in to
RNR with the Lords where you too can
find out about all your anime needs
anime all things anime
there another another death battle this
week
hot then we have little conquer $2 super
the little one a the big Ain the big con
little
conquer no coner came
through now Xbox needs to jump jump on
that Crystal D quick
oh I love I love how they take like
stuff that we're actually making a
conversation just make it mad pervert
Yeah just mad it just pause worthy for
no reason and what's funny is people
would know how relevant that
conversation is that they weren't long
time listening facts facts salute
continue There we got Hollywood rules
remember for 21 months Lord silver the
murder went down are we referring to
Sony sir happy
it was an actual actual
murder happy Sunday my NYC West Virginia
cousins happy to hear King as well and
you guys are all feeling better salute
salute much
love then we got platano J member for 31
months Lord Bron Deo Lords happy Sunday
salute yeah salute to
you and we got Craig holigan gifted one
I membership Craig holigan doing the
Lord's work as always appreciate you
brother's
outside and we have Shadow Blade with
the $10 Super Chat blessed to the iron
Lords a much love for you guys also I
told King David he reminded me of the
great General gou G Yu yes from my
favorite game Dynasty Warriors man of
honor and wisdom and
courage thank you brother yes that used
to be one of our favorite games yeah the
real Dynasty War CLS come down clouds
come down we we fight it was a fighting
game figh game we played it yeah yeah
love that it was really good graphically
then we have Robert kellet $2 superchat
can't believe Bungie is seeing the black
d we'll see we'll see buddy Robert Kelly
what's get to Super Chat what's your
game of the year so far Lords anything
extra meaty or
beefy some beefy situations adct what's
yours um my game of the year yeah even
though I had Haven beat it it's balers
gate B yeah like you just like it
because of the perverted stuff bro no I
like it because of the freedom you have
I'll find out November 2 I mean December
know what day comes
out whenever it comes out I'll play it
because I'm not playing it on that
unstable box but if why if it's not on
Game Pass who said no I'm buying that
what's up with you you buy you you yo
you yo you got me messed up bro like at
the end of the show y'all figure it out
what's going to happen but Boulders gate
will be in that conversation too at the
end of the show y got stick around okay
what is your G of the Year oh is um
Starfield okay uh but in my heart is
Spiderman like I'm a I'm I'm a
Spider-Man dude like Spider-Man 2 I'm
I'm a Spiderman guy and I'm always going
to battle for our stories that sustain
me as a kid and they did craving so well
I mean the bugs kind of hurt it but my
single player story driven narrative
game of the year the best story for me
is Spider-Man because they crafted a
story that we knew yeah and they flipped
it on its head and and gave us something
different and when you can do that when
you can impress comic book fans then you
got something special so my story of the
year is Spider-Man but my game of the
year is Starfield because there's no
game like
Starfield right now no doubt s yours
he's right there there's definitely
Starfield is one of a TI kind time of a
game yeah it's mine it's just literally
I gotta go by the game I play the most
that's giving me the most enjoyment and
it's it's hard to like truly judge or
review Starfield because there's not a
game like it on the market either yeah
so what's yours just early um up until
this point I Haven really finished a
whole lot but I would have to say it's
Street Fighter 6 for me wow he standing
on it I'm a stre like they really they
brought Street Fighter back back man
five remember five was you can't you
cannot force Esports onto a game ever
it's the community that defines it right
and they they came out Street Fighter 5
it was super Bare Bones no story mode
they were just counting on it being this
phenomenon uh in terms of the you know
Esports and the competitive scene and it
wasn't and it what it did was exclude
people out of Street Fighter in a way
not to mention the fact that it was a
PlayStation exclusive and you couldn't
get it any place else
shout out to Market deals it it excluded
people out of out of Street Fighter in a
way that Ford didn't when Ford brought
it all back and then they went back and
they made it even simpler for the new
guy to jump in um and they you know they
finally did some story stuff that it's
not Mortal Kombat levels but it's it's
it's it's corny and stupid for Street
Fighter but I think mechanically that
game is amazing the only thing to me
that I think May usurp it is if that
Allen wake really hits when I down and
really and really give it as just D so
that's really the only thing because I'm
not going to be able to
finish tears of the kingdom and you know
and then I love star I really really
really love Starfield but I have not
completed the story because I just I
have a 100 hours in Starfield running
around and you just been running around
damn just beat the story it's not even
that long foolishness is what I've been
doing man he ain't the only one I ain't
finished the story either oh y got
that's the best part of where I'm going
around getting I'm going around getting
powers and but the problem is is I'm I'm
like the dog that be like oh squirrel
squirrel yeah I know I know it's it's
that type of game yeah I get messed up
really quickly I just like I just want
y'all to finish it so you can see what
they've done storywise which is
generally historically not the strongest
Point yeah but we got to move we got to
move the story is kind of good we got
flame in here waiting for some
reason some some must be some reason
must be some important were going to ask
me what my game of the year was but okay
I I guess just for these
guys let's go let's go let's go let's go
Lord Warframe I know I know his game of
the year is Halo is Halo okay yeah he
saw posting about Halo Lord Warframe
what is your game my knee all right I
Lord gaming.net what is your game of the
year so far for you oath Trav 2 anyways
oh octo 2 there we go spread the word I
knew
that so far at least I haven't I haven't
finished on week two yet I really
enjoyed alop Trav one I still haven't
played the second one you I'm not going
to lie dude just buy it on steam or
something it is worth it I think I'll
wait for it on next at this
point fair enough fair enough fair
enough so we got get these super CHS we
running behind Okay then we have hold on
I roll back a little bit hold on a
second OH ZIP Davis $5 Super Chat Zip
Zip with the drip from K&N Lars from
Tekken will be the new head of
PlayStation the fan base likes to be
choked and dominated it's a natural
fit what is going on zip stop it zip the
whip zip the
drip then we have Doctor Strange left
here we
go oh you like climbing s well I got a
long meaty Tower that'll test your
skills try not to climb it too fast but
it'll erupt
wow
yo Str L is outside thank you for your
Patron
hey back to you s we cannot have that
conversation doing like how it just did
I was doing something right now and I'm
just sitting there like I can't believe
that man super chated he paid good money
to talk to his he wanted Sol to know he
got something to clim you like climing
gam I got one for you listen we have we
have we have discourse around this
subject
now following up
let's play with each other's
joysticks oh the battle for S
heart it ain't for my heart they
B go go ahead and finish the super chats
the only thing I was goingon to say is I
am testing like the streamlabs thing so
if you see a spamming a little bit it's
it's not me it's stream no you're good
you good the only thing strange is that
you think Sab will be climbing any meat
Tower other than m yo stick with addict
I'm the only joystick
faad
yo did
it there's a real life battle for s in
here n ain't B for me a lot it's very
it's a beefy competition for song place
your Super Chat bets is it Dr straight
love or is it or is it I can't have my
family listen to this [__] I'm just be
I'm just going to be honest with you man
your best bet is King cuz my girl kill
us
both it's a beefy competition solv the
incumbent the champ returning Champion
hey hey hey hey ain't nobody put me into
that don't do
that lot of meat on the table in attic
like he adct got a only fan is soft like
the clown meat
po continue what a beef competition blow
for
blow hey
yo Contin there we got Robert Kell went
again $2 super CH bless you for getting
the pup King yes she's adorable thank
you yeah why why if you sending me PCT
so she got Coco face oh my
God adorable here we got the homie harie
Chie $5 Super Chat did someone say Alan
Wake 2 deluxe edition Global
code always looking out for the
community if you got this code from
Harge shout it out in the chat let us
know let us know yo yo from now on don't
throw the chat like like don't do it
like that make these guys earn it
because you got one guy that is scoop it
real quickly and I'm out
and let them stick around the whole show
drop like a couple of letters here a
couple letters there let them do the
homework for it
man then we have uh Doctor Strange Love
yet again $5 Super Chat why must we
fight over sav's love joystick instead I
propose an
alliance make this Co-op experience
switch to dual analog joysticks for they
trying to
[Music]
tag yo they trying to tag team this
situation they trying to make in a mob
situation yo it got way too beefy in
here Dad they turn that into some type
of bus we know bu that is two analogs
that's wild there we have uh the
response somebody put dual anals oh who
who whoa time time that's super pause
worthy y'all out of pocket y'all got to
stop I don't know who y'all
are continue I don't even read the chats
y'all crazy yo somebody said they try to
spit I'm done spit rolls I'm done that's
good play with each other's
Joy it's crazy it shows how much you
know about sa he's all about the single
player selfish experience and I and I'm
the Red Dead Redemption of playing with
J yo he I'm done I'm done bro they going
hard in the P this is a fight this is a
fight I've never SE the Doctor Strange
Love put his flag down like he's not
trying to hear it he's
doing thank thank you all for your
patience my man my man been violated dip
down says so is that local Coach
K we good only online only oh we good
with the super no we are not we oh wow
okay good we have Tyson Lewis M for 23
months Lord bronze blue samurai on
Netflix is dope it seems like a cog
official also Alan Wake is fire yeah I
got to check that out got to check that
out then we have Jonas the dad $2 Super
Chat this is for addict he needs a
hug I guess addict needs a hug adct
needs a hug I guess then we have Doctor
Strange Love yet again5 Super Chat I see
how it is a joystick I offered you f I
see how it is joystic I offered you
friendship and you spat in my face we
could have had shared to now I got to
make him all mine You Will Rule the Day
yo yo this is turned into the Monica and
the Brandy J this is the boy is mine
this you need to give it
up the soft
is
Yo the solve
battles tell
the then we have g$ Super Chat epic
needs to fix controller support for
Allan W 2 I I was bugging out on I so I
got to see so far what I played i't had
no issues but I a had no controller
issues no but you playing on Console
yeah you see how he tried to shave you
though like you see how he try to you're
playing on
Console yeah but you're playing with
messed up controller so you can't really
play I I I I love how the the version
that's not messed up he tried to shame
us for
playing but it's not messed up because
it can't do all the hot stuff that the
other
vers but the thing is it can run though
it don't matter it don't matter it don't
mattero you just do you know what path
tracing is Sir no but I I know where a
controller up and down left right
me I I know I could get to my
objectives let's go continue Z mind you
they all have the same PC that I have
now they just yeah this is true this is
true they just too scar power yeah this
is true we we like good
controls continue let me
see that lazy otaku5 Super Chat this is
how you know sad s was a Chad in school
men and wom women fighting for him facts
listen I know that boy since the third
grade he's been a
problem I became know honestly I be
problem later you grew into you you had
what what is it where you grow I forgot
the story but there's a there was some
Growing Pains
there he he was aisher though once he
blew up it was over there we go Hardy
chani $5 chat Sol give up set up your
only sticks page for the
community only sticks that's
wild there we have Robert called only
stones come on we doing it doing it
today you acting like that's the most
sus you've read today
that was late that was late that was
late continue There we have Robert Kell
$2 Super Chat people looking too much
into holes godamn wow wow yeah
definitely iron Lord paast today paast
today that's what that's because of s
w't be what I do I just arrived and do
my job we GNA start calling you juicy
pause yeah we got to get a t-shirt
because he do got a shirt with him
playing with a joystick though oh like
remember yo we don't got the shirt with
you playing yo you know what what are
you talking about I no not do got I got
you I got you I got
you that's how that's how beefy was
created cuz K ideas I got you yo he yo
t-shirt inbound we got a t-shirt coming
the T-shirt coming since y'all want
y'all want y'all want who is wearing
that who going wear that I got three
people right now yeah that's how they
got me now y good good with t-shirt
coming just like how they got me they
like yeah beefy needs to happen and
joystick shirt coming dog I defended you
you I feel I didn't feel defended I'm
all when when I was being attacked and
accosted by beef emojis and all this
craziness Ain nobody stop defend
me I was bullied into a Persona I'm
calling graphic guard right
now I need some Lord beefies in the chat
right now yo somebody said beefy and
Juice I'm done
continue
let's go juicy beef yeah oh man crazy
and we got uh SB $10 Super Chat how
y'all don't have a pause emote already
emote is beyond me that's true we don't
have a pause emote to be fair we we we
kind of go into all the the pause jokes
yeah salute to Sir then we have gab
Forte $10 Savages all this be hey King
Boo Boo why did hary she put beef and
and Bear
hey King Boo sorry hey King Boo Boo and
Clan IOP hey Forte salute so father
Gucci you better relax Cog the leader of
the hold the beef movement you need to
relax you need to relax yourself you
need that was too much that was too much
the question is the question is it hold
the beef OT or does it hold your
beef this is what I'm talking about add
you always say he always got to take it
to the next level he got you do that
then he got to Spirit Bomb the
situation but he want to sleep with the
door open man always he always got to
add extra layer of detail
to extra sauce anyway continue Forte
says my run in D2 has ended we done many
raids together and I always cherish that
their path forward message rubbed me the
wrong way this isn't cap just
disappointment I feel you for yo come
over to fortnite we got a chain for you
I I got a game for you my friend I got
Lord Warframe got something for yeah
it's called fortnite it's called
fortnite the damn sure a't W wireframe
or whatever that thing over there messy
that game has been struggling for years
it's actually it's actually doing really
good though yeah I know it took 40 years
to
get contines so we never going to get
through the damn first topic we up man
okay all right reason that certain
people are here that I have to is set up
cuz you can't just invite me like
normally no we just can't invite you we
got to let you out no
J that was that was wrong that was wrong
that was wrong I apologize I apologize
that was messy anyway uh it's that time
of the mon with Lords and gaming.net
y'all you know what I'm saying we out
here killing it blessed to have some of
the greatest writers going on and the
talent is the talent pool has been
really cool this year to see a lot of
the content coming up and uh we in the
middle of a say like a recycling of
things so stay on the lookout for some
stuff that's coming there but um you
know we got to celebrate we got to
celebrate one particular Lord who went
Above and Beyond in the month of October
killing it with the news articles
killing it with just Anime he's just I
mean it's so many things you do to try
to it's hard to quantify what you don't
do but um yeah man we we we salute your
your your content and obviously the
consistency with editing of course you
know what I mean one of the best editors
in the business Lord flame what is going
on congratulation on editor of the month
thank you and obviously I want to shout
out the team because obviously without
them I can't do literally anything on
the site because you know what's there
to edit if they're not submitting it but
um but I mean what what I've seen this
month has actually been pretty awesome
like Jean's playing a lot of games in
preparation for our Game of the Year
Awards next month as
well as Chris he's basically been doing
a like a lot of articles
in between so
he's yeah he kind of breaking up no no
you breaking up a little bit yeah now it
came back but it was breaking up a
little bit but you're good now I think
you're good now hey we're good was I
breaking up you were breaking them but
now you're good okay sorry about that uh
we're I'll just start over uh Chris been
bringing his laptop to work to actually
make a lot of Articles and it's actually
pretty it's been that's that's some
dedication right there that's why he's
our scram mon obviously seen some we've
seen some returning writers Lord Edge as
well as Jason Rose who made that
uh made a couple of spicy articles for
us earlier in the year and he's coming
back and bring it back I love that and
Lady April came back talking about moral
komat great Mortal Kombat Liu Kang for
people who beat Mortal Kombat she had a
great uh Liu Kang kind of like post you
know morm piece that's it's it's
amazing yeah so just just shout out to
the team in general man and Tai as well
like they're doing a great job as the
community manager as well as covering
everything they can from bz con and not
Destiny
too sorry
sorry messy messy so I want to say thank
you to them because they're an awesome
team to work with and we have some
interesting stuff coming up so no I
appreciate you brother it's you've been
really again a blessing the consistency
is what I like the energy that you bring
obviously helping out on the editorial
staff and again the commitment to
Warframe wayfinder you have a great
review of cocon up right now that people
are sleeping on that game I believe it's
from one of the guys the hat that made
inside and um people i s Game Pass right
now that's a great one but continue the
great work and I do want to stick around
we do have one more award that we you
alluded to that we got to give out which
is obviously you know describing a month
and again with October this kid's been
killing it absolutely tear with the
again article
board games and of course his beloved
iudin Chronicle you know what I'm saying
so we have to present the latest winner
of describ of the month to cunit Chris
Jones in the building he couldn't be
here but he left us a message you know
you know how the MJ log
that so we GNA play that right
quick what's going on everybody it's
your boy Lloyd Chris aka the Michael
Jordan Al loget just want to give a big
shout out to the team Lords gaming.net
iron Lords podcast we're all here doing
the Lord's work bringing you the best
possible media tech gaming all that
great content for you guys viewing
pleasure it's been a rough couple months
for me for the real work life but I want
to give a big shout out to all the
editors that have worked with me quite a
bit uh putting out articles will be
edited 3:00 in the morning 6:00 in the
morning 2: p.m. um whenever I was able
to get that stuff out the editors were
always on it and uh giving obviously the
great advice they do big shout out to
our writing team putting out the great
content we have we we got lots of new
writers coming in doing their thing
obviously iron Lord's podcast Lord
Cognito Mr 247 traveling the traveling
the globe all around the globe Cognito
goes especially with the recent
happenings big shout out to Cognito
showing his uh passion his dedication
everything else obviously s King addict
always putting in hard work stuff behind
the scenes a lot of people don't get to
see obviously everybody loves uh General
King David so I just want to say how
much I appreciate them appreciate the
writing team and uh some special stuff
coming in up couple months hopefully it
comes through and uh I'll definitely be
at PAX East so be there with the Lords
if you see us come up and say hi don't
be afraid and uh you'll be seeing me
again of course
salute again salute Lord see unit
scriber the month salute Lord flame
editor of the month absolutely killing
again appreciate you guys really got
things cooking over there at Lords
gaming.net more plans and also I just
want to put this out there we're doing a
call to Arms it's going to be coming up
real soon obviously me and Flame talked
about it recently at the edior meeting M
the team so again we're going to be
looking for news article people who want
to just put out news articles as well as
uh potential vi video video editing for
reasons that we will get into later so
yeah um look out for that on the Lords
of gaming.net Twitter atls gaming net
look out for that and also IP will
signal boost that but again if you're
looking to get into the game as far as
just getting your child with writing and
you're looking to do if you're good with
news pieces or interested in that please
reach out and go to the Lords gaming.net
go to the uh contact us section and
interested in writing for us and we will
takeing applications there so salute and
again F thank you for pulling up much
appreciate for having me but I do want
to add one thing to the call arms pleas
just thing everybody knows if you're
applying and you just want to write
about anything that you see like
newswise doesn't have to be the most
important stuff that's happening right
now if you just see a game that you're
personally interested in like I've
covered a lot of smaller games in my
time as an editor and even before that a
writer so you don't have to cover like
oh you don't have to like look for the
most you know popping off news you can
just cover whatever you want we don't
have any restrictions yeah absolutely
what you're passionate about is what we
care about so that's that's the deal any
oh akw like the video editing all right
you know what to do Lords of gaming.net
contact us i s it hold on let me get you
that link get you that link bro y have a
great day
andam you know I wasn't hold get you
that link have a great day no doubt have
a good one brother I'm going put this
out there just to signal boost for those
who are interested this is the official
link you already know all right any
other super chats we can move on I think
we're good for now all right cool so
then it's on me we
have uh we got the patreon question
actually we do the uh the poll first uh
last week's poll results are in the
people have spoken to the question with
the recent reports regarding internal
shuffling Within PlayStation which
direction do you think Sony should
ultimately take for their long-term
success the winner of the three-way poll
at 47% of the vote fairly close was Sony
needs to evolve and have games as a
service in their portfolio to survive
group coming in at second at very close
41% of the vote was Sony should drop the
aggressive games as a service push and
stick to the experiences they they do
best and in last place it only 10% of
the vote was I don't care Sony and bungy
still owes me my damn factions games
group shout out to all those who
participated uh Lord addict man the
people want Sony to stick with games as
a
service they must be trolling it was
close you clearly yeah King King did you
did you tweet this
any no
are you
sure what why you trying to give me into
trou are you implying that someone had
influence on
voting I'm not implying I'm just saying
you know sounds like inside a tweet from
the right person you know definitely
because because I'm pretty sure K you K
King the G for a reason you know he he
don't want to play station six it's the
quickest way to do
that I know I it's not that I don't want
to play PlayStation 6 I like Sony would
love a PlayStation 6 but at the end of
the
day sometimes you just can't make it
past the Finish Line it's just not going
to happen sometimes the punches get too
strong anyway I think this was a patreon
question we missed last week correct me
if I'm wrong adct um Benjamin amaru hey
Lords another blessed Sunday is a
pronoun how important is it to have
played through control and Quantum break
to fully grasp the connections to the
Allen wake Universe cheers and have a
fantastic podcast he said be there Bri
early this is when he thought um Jaffrey
was going to be there and he said um he
wanted to ask jaffy talk about the devs
the most amazing miniseries made or the
why files living in a simulation episode
that would be awesome apologies that we
missed this but again how important is
it to you guys as far as you know the
connections with a universe with Allan
Wake Quantum break control how important
is I don't care you don't care about
yeah you as the wrong person there yeah
so um yeah I mean they're all
interconnected now right even what I'm
hearing even Max Payne um and the
possibility maybe of quantum break so uh
so I would say directly to play alen
Wake play uh an wake 2 play an wake
um there is you if you play control
there's it it alludes to it there's
things that you find in the world that
allude to it and obviously there's DLC
that has to do with Alan Wake that isn't
necessarily uh imperative that you play
before playing Allan Wake 2 but if you
haven't played Alan Wake 1 I would say
yes or at the very least an in-depth
sort of uh you know playthrough of it
that kind of explains the story beat and
all that stuff if you don't want to go
back and play alen Wake um there is the
remastered so you can play in a a little
bit higher Fidelity higher frame rate
stuff like that if you don't want to go
play the old 360 version but I would say
story-wise yeah you want to be you want
to know what happened Allan Wake going
into this one no doubt King who started
Allan Wake uh too how do you feel about
the importance of a connected Universe
between games I think it's necessary I
think um stuff like that allows you more
flexibility in your worlds because once
you have this cohesive thread and we
seen Marvel do it and we see other
companies try to do it uh once you can
get that connectivity in those people
that like
control probably don't know about Allan
Wake and they might bed over and those
people that know about Alan Wake
probably don't know about control and me
personally and my hope my heart of
hearts My Hope of hopes is you know
Microsoft can get a hold of these dudes
and they can put uh Quantum break into
that uh yeah break is they're saying
there's a reference right it's a
reference but I want it to be connected
you understand because that then that
gives me absolute hope that Microsoft um
Can can not I don't really I don't want
control over remedy what I want is a a
actual home and finances given towards
remedy right so they don't look like
they're hurting when it comes to
production when it comes to putting the
games out when they want them I think a
broader eye on their games I think this
game itself Allen wake 2 itself is their
one is the one that they needed because
Allan W one was a little niche control
was out there but it didn't hit the
critical success I thought it needed I
know Alan Wake 2 will okay no fair
enough fair enough um you know I like
them I think it's dope what they're
doing you know for the people who are
really playing I know shout out to Rand
ebontis Travis those three you know
especially Travis because I know he's
pretty hard on certain games and I think
prior he had Boulders gate as his game
and he put a tweet out recently that
it's not even close that Al to is his he
said it this morning on bit Cass he said
it he was like is my game of the year
facts ran said it early now ran I was
like I know he's such an allen weight
guy so at first I was I wasn't sure if
it's just you know when you're a fan of
but no those are these are people I
respect and you know I will get around
to it but I like that they do in the
connected Universe to King's Point I
think that the relationship is getting
better I heard the relationship wasn't
that great during the quantum break days
that was four Phill or whatever but I
did hear it's they're trying to improve
it obviously the uh showcase we were all
wondering why was Alan Wake to there so
to speak so maybe that's the Olive
Branch as far as getting relationships
better it is what it is that's all I got
so we going to get into these topics we
good on the uh Super Chat that so we no
new patreon question right oh no new no
new ones I didn't see the stuff that I
saw add it correct me if I'm wrong was a
lot of RNR questions so I didn't want to
read that and I felt that was for y'all
yeah about RNR it's going through a
change just just uh bear with us yeah so
let me know got in future if you guys
want me to read the RNR Jo they were
anime specific but I didn't know if that
was oh yeah yeah yeah we like that we
like but I thought that' be on RNR or
but see the thing is okay so RNR we
can't read it cuz it's a tape show oh I
got you so yeah yeah the conversations
could be had here you know I know you
don't want to Accent look like he got
stuff that he want to do today I'm just
saying you know it is football and we
it's 2 2:30 and we didn't get the first
topic but I mean we could I I do
understand that but I do understand Fair
they pay their
money the paying customer deserves to
get go Ahad and ask them real quick and
we we we'll just do it real fast yes no
yes no answers that's it that's all we
do here
yes I'll ask yes please please help uh
we we have one from have you guys ever U
have you guys read my hero and do you
guys like avatar The Last Airbender if
so what do you think of these two shows
and manga um I love my hero and I love
avatar The Last Airbender you King back
to you
King what was the
question hey you read my hero or we'll
just say have you watched my hero and
yes I watched my hero yes you like
Avatar of the last airer of course I I
think um them doing it live I'm waiting
for the new ones to come out but I love
avatar the Last
an this one's this one's a pretty Blinky
one hope all is well I'm not sure if
this has been asked before I was just
curious to the Lord's and debl B forste
talking about how I don't have I'm not
onam I have the top five anime series
for example
Naruto that's for both Naruto and shap
and want I'll give M quickly five JoJo's
bizaar Adventures land line Saga I
actually need to watch that one of the
best stories with some of the most
symbolic in media Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood Hunter x Hunter that's a
great show the power system in anime uh
three of my top five episodes are Hunter
Hunter episodes and one One Piece manga
included if you can't think of any uh
we're not really going to go into that
but I can do M real quick okay okay so
my top five is uh noru um uh one punch
man uh um Kenshin Aur uh baky and um the
over F all right King yo hey we outside
we outside we can't forget that we got
to go back to what we love legend of the
over yes legend of the over do your
homework on that do your homework on
Legend of the over
yeah yeah just do just do don't do it on
a work computer right not suitable for
work it different it different very
technical heavy scrub scrub scrub your
history after that mine's Attack on
Titan yeah probably uh Demon Slayer I
like Demon Slayer more than my hero and
I actually have to say in Yasha that's
like one of the original uh animes that
got me into it and like you just throw
random to popular animes in there right
now probably probably bleach all right I
got got you man I got gerver I Got U
ninj scroll whatever that and what
fighter to the the animated movie was
hot uh one other the old on s i old
Vampire Hunter D Vamp Hunter there it is
there it is that's mine that's what's
your Aira Kira Kira my My Generation
exactly Aira is dope though my my list
is pretty much C's list that's we know
we know we FR out of control dude we mad
FR F of the North
yeah but see you ain't asking about
vintage though cuz I would have said
berserk and some other stuff too yeah
sort of the berserk yeah all right no
doubt are we caught up uh adct yeah
that's all all right cool we got the
Legend ham Solo in the building oh
that's my Gody can we get a mic check
for the for the for the guy we're just
now getting to the topic too I know
right I can hear you brother keep
talking just say words yeah yo what's up
what's up what's up just go to get that
to
round this the CIO this the CIO we we
going to do an official still don't yo
ham yo ham I feel crazy good right now
he got he got the call up yo he got the
call up my man
got I hit his L we been we've been
working in the background you know what
I'm saying I told her I was like yo
please bear with me we a forget you you
know what saying and he got little man
in the back know what it is bro you know
what it is how you feeling I swear I
love this guy I'm feeling fantastic I'm
feeling fantastic I am very appreciative
to you guys reaching out and having me
on the show and you said this isn't even
going to be the only time I I mean you
said what you said I was like I'm cool
to hop on but but but then I kept read
reading I was like oh oh there's a
tradition in the realm when it's I
really appreciate it you're welcome
you're welcome there's a tradition in
the realm when it's the first time you
still you got to get the Royal Treatment
we just doing this early just to get get
you know get the anticipation up then we
going to do it a IAL you know what I'm
saying we get the said knock the dust
the sword the problem is is we the
problem is is I complained to Cog I'm
tired of a bunch of guests so I was like
because here's the thing like I can't
sit here six seven hours every week and
every time we have a guest be here six
seven hours I'm like do we got to cut
down the show the show has getting
lengthy pause anyway oh shout out to
trouble Sho G real quick cuz I do see
him in there I heard you recovering
brother it's so good to see you help
everything as well so I wanted to shout
out my man meds up in there salute so we
finally to meds yeah troubleshoot gaming
we finally going to get to these topics
y'all so look this is the big one this
is the one everyone is talking about
it's been dominating the headways I got
a lot of setting up to do so um yeah
Sony's uh shout out to Bloomberg Jason
shrier uh Sony's bungee game unit cut 8%
of the staff after Destiny play has
wilted sales at the studios running 45%
below projections for the year they also
part of a bigger revamp at Sony
PlayStation unit so yeah they the
decision to remove over a 100 jobs from
his staff and about um from management
from the flagship video game uh Destiny
uh two about two weeks ago they uh Sony
uh Bungie developer told employees that
Revenue was running
45% below projections uh Pete Parson
chief executive chief executive officer
he um he pended on weak player retention
for Destiny 2 which has faced poor
reception since light
and then um regarding the next expansion
final shape uh they've been getting good
but not great feedback and they uh
planned internally to push the release
of final shape from June
2024 um I mean from February to June
2024 according to those people inside
officially budgie has not made that
statement public yet but this is what
obviously JC sh you know world class
reporting um basically it started to get
worse during the week uh people were
getting a 15minute meeting meeting
requests last minute or uh stuff to
their calendars to come into the office
access revoked um so you know around
this 8% of the the employee force that
was laid off um employees will let go
will receive at least three months of
severance and three months of uh Bungie
pay Cobra health insurance and uh that
ended uh Monday so as soon as the you
know kind of the new year because that
was that last week of October people
were rushing to try to uh get those
receipts in um yeah and uh Jason
continues to go on laid off staff ERS
will also receive uh pro-rated bonuses
and uh those who were on a vested
schedule following uh Sony's acquisition
of Bungie will lose those shares that
weren't vested as of next month so that
was a big one uh he continues on he says
uh this these layoffs were part of a
larger moneys saving initiative at
Sony's Playstation unit which also cut
employees at Naughty Dog media molecule
and it's San Mato office then this
continued on obviously we shout out to
Paul tassy who I've been talking to he's
been talking about the reports of how
people were receiving this news it was
not well internally even for people who
were retained um the legendary uh
Michael
salvatori uh one of the composers iconic
composers from from the uh Bungie days
the Halo days you know from uh Destiny
soundtracks he was let go he made a
statement pretty much taking it in in
Grace as far as that was concerned uh
Pete Parsons put a tweet out um in
reference to the whole situation today
is a sad day of Bungie as we said say
goodbye to colleagues who have all made
significant impact on our studio what
these exceptional individuals have
contributed to our games and Bungie
culture has been enormous and will
continue to be a part of Bungie launch
into the future he goes on to say these
are truly talented people if you have
openings I would highly recommend each
and every one of them this was not
really received well in addition to an
internal meeting that came out that said
um to the people who are retained we
held on to the right people so that wow
wow that was kind of some some backlash
there um following that uh in typical
bunge history every week There's a this
week at Bungie and uh this one it did
not come out this week and then they we
waited for the statement on the the
second and um yeah that was Thursday in
reference to it's a statement called The
Path forward they talked about um this
is one of the most difficult weeks in
the studios's history they want to
acknowledge the feedback and concern
that everyone has that they haven't uh
Desy needs to surprise in Delight they
did not mention the delay of still yet
they have not mentioned the delay that
uh J sh has reported they went on to
which is interesting which is
interesting we are intensely focused on
exceeding your expectations for the
final shape Destiny 2 has more than 650
dedicated teammates pouring all their
energy and expertise and delivering this
epic moment and its uh subsequent
episodes in the weeks ahead you'll hear
more about from us on the what's on the
short-term Horizon beginning on what's
next season in November and then they'll
talk about their ability bigger Vision
with the final shape now surprisingly
this was the key point I'll end with is
that normally this is run by a community
manager usually it's a cosmo or it's um
you know one of the general you know run
of the mon CMS and this time it was
signed the destiny to Dev team so no one
put their name to it from a community
manager which people felt was very
interesting based on what's going on so
yeah I mean there's a lot to unpack here
um you know obviously the future of it
and uh Destiny's future obviously
marathon and I guess the last thing that
I'll say is um again I don't know how
much truth this is to it so take it with
a grain of salt it's not you know there
a couple of big- time YouTubers and even
tassy pulled back his uh statement on it
that there may have been some pre-alpha
internal testing of the game marathon
which is what they're working on next
and that they were asked at this stage
with the play testing would you
recommend playing this game this is a
game that you would want to play and no
one raised their hand that was going
around
but however pre-alpha Focus testing In
fairness and that's that's what was said
in this they got their own medicine back
at
them talked about that on Destin show
they did it on they did it to naughty
dog it's like anybody want to play this
nobody raised their hand they say we got
you
they
apparently Staffing it it was like do
anybody want this like that was not noty
dog these
allegedly escaped
from dman put out the internal email
like y make sure oh he said escape from
tar streamers yeah yeah they review bomb
your
game anyway yo and dude stand up and
like
Boo it boo this man you and your
scenarios yo one dude got up and threw
his hat was like that's
garbage not the CH oh man he like y go
back to matter cuz this is trash you are
ridiculous anyway how it feel Budgy how
it feel nobody raised their hand for you
you are messy sir but anyway that we've
got a lot of the information still more
but I I'll be here for real long this
this story is continuing to develop so
um start with you have solo man let's go
over you're
ridiculous
man cuz I got them but actually he
there's one more thing before I give it
to you there was um there was one later
development shout out to Paul tassy um
all right so the update to the story is
management also said they were other
levs looking to avoid layoffs they said
one level was um executive compensation
they told that they were told no that it
would H happen at the company um now
that Pete Parsons and other other
Executives previously forfeited annual
bonuses before the layoffs but staff was
not informed so they're saying that they
were trying to do as much as they can to
avoid the layoffs they said internally
no one is blaming Sony for this even
management some employees were told that
if the so here's the key K some
employees were told if the Sony buyout
did not happen that with the current
Destiny 2 performance the studio would
have been in Jeopardy if they were still
independent that's a key line from his
article what they going to say Sony
Force this to lay off people n no I'mma
get to that basically say if they if
they didn't take the contract whatever
you really say if Sony PID all the money
instead of paying that the cheapest
amount on the layway now there was
also there was also moment about a I
know right here we out of pocket about a
retention um Pro uh process that was
supposed to happen so there's new
updates on that
similarly the 1.2 billion in employee
retention from Sony was spent by Bungie
long time ago often on b
d your retirement fun yo get these dudes
out of here son you are messy St SP La
time go often on buying out employees
bungee shares which then went to Sony
there's nothing left in the there's
nothing left in the pot to avoid layoffs
which wasn't what
is attic is out of control yo who's in
charge over
there so the trending of what the
spending said the means that the 45%
Miss in projection is important and not
necessarily wildly inflated projection
however nearsighted it ended up being so
there was just real damage Post
lightfall in terms of player engaging
and spending even though light fall so
well they projected almost half more 45%
more you know and in currently people
are mad um you know leadership with mad
and stuff like that and uh yeah that's
pretty much the latest update there's
more this this just too much I I'm just
trying to get to pick and choose some of
the more important ones but yeah those
are the major ones that were kind of
updated but anyway okayo good day your
thoughts on this whole situation I'm not
going to lie some of this stuff that
you're involving within the problems of
Bungie seems
like this was not avoidable and they
were pretending like they were kind of
trying to avoid it the whole time yeah
it it just reads like that a little bit
like oh that money's been spent a long
time ago so yeah so you didn't know
you're G to go this direction it sounds
like you knew exactly what you were
gonna do and you just kind of I don't
know
used I don't know some of the wording
within the acquisition itself to make
yourselves look good so then because at
the same time you got to remember this
acquisition is happening at the same
time as the
DLC like like right around that same
time so they don't want to have all this
bad press right and then be like well
here's the game right they want to have
good positive press and then say yo we
got the backing of Sony behind us too
now right well things are starting to
kind of fall apart a little bit for Sony
and and it's falling apart in more
multiple different ways right but this
bungee one's a really big eye opener
particularly because a lot of us that
follow this stuff remember that
retention thing yes that retention thing
was a big deal and P was on top of the
hill saying we saved your butts and we
got your
back and then this happens and then we
hear that some of the people are only
getting one day left of their insurance
and then you hearing talks about Cobra I
tell you what you don't want to hear
about cob you want hear about Cobra the
the insurance is different that it was
other things that they didn't have
access to they only had insurance they
had their whole uh you know the whole
time they get uh their months or
something like that their separation
bonus it's like insance the only the
holiday season yeah oh yeah especially
being in the holiday season that's
devastating yeah that's tough that's
really but when I look at Bungie like
big
picture it's just like starting to get
to the point where it's like all right
man ien heard you cry wolf I don't know
how many times now right you cried wolf
to get away from Microsoft and and and
the thing is is a lot of people like to
use Microsoft as point at them they're
the bad person they're at fault they're
the big bad company they push themselves
away Microsoft was like fine fine y'all
cost you dang much anyways yeah got they
got free they went to activ
y'all go ahead and go independent and
they're like yeah fine then they went
over to
Activision gave them a you know ruffled
up their feathers really good Activision
was like all right fine go ahead and get
out of
back and and and then Sony picks him up
and it's like more issues so it's just
like I mean I heard something fantastic
the other day and I thought it really
made sense I heard it from K Mega shout
out to my brother podcast with a couple
times a week dope dude but um but he's
like man they they're like the James
Harden or they're like the James Harden
of gaming yeah that's no lie that's true
and I'm just like yeah absolutely
because as soon as they seem to be fine
the business that they that that the
person that Bungie's going to seems to
be pretty fine and then they walk in
give their two cents and then have a
problem you know what I'm saying
like it's just kind of frustrating
it's kind of frustrating to watch and
and at and at this point it's just like
you know 911 seeing that they call and
they're just like yo not the
911 nothing so so so how s looked at my
phone call the other
morning I'll text him later it's nothing
he he he need he he just needs something
I mean what what do you process with the
updated information ham in reference to
like them saying that if they didn't get
a acquired that essentially the lights
could have been off at that
point cap um yeah yeah I don't know how
much I'm buying that because it's just
like so you wanted to get released from
Activision so bad so you can go broke
and die I want independence yeah I
wanted Independence like like like like
like some of like like I said some of
the stuff isn't adding up so it's like
wait a second if you didn't get acquired
you would have been in the trash but but
you did get AC choir but you said you
used all the money for the retention a
long time
ago but you needed the retention to keep
the employ like like like like what I'm
saying is this just doesn't it's just
not cohesive it it sound like she wanted
to get out the relationship cuz she was
tired with the one dude she wanted to be
for the streets right maybe she just
spends too much oh hers do Gana yeah
valencias Valen here moving in in new
condos in
downtown yes I mean it's possible that
basically living outside of your means
and the way you running stuff it's
possible I'm sorry I'm I'm I'm
interjecting on thoughts that no no no
no that's that's partially what I'm
saying is it's like it's it's not only
like are you kind of a problem but you
come you come in here you wreck my
Maserati you put you put your heels
through my 65 in
man you did all this wild
stuff and then you you got the nerve to
put your hand back out like and just
like the the chin is down but the hand
is out so so so it's just like no man I
I I just don't understand and and then
on top of that you got hired to help out
it seems like you haven't really helped
as much as you kind of held back
disrupted yeah yeah yeah yeah in the way
they and and here's the thing I
understand they're they're coming from
Activision which is really good at
marketing oh yeah you know getting their
abely you know and getting their uh
microtransaction out for sale and stuff
like that and Bungie you know although
Destiny's had its ups and downs they've
made a lot of money off of that thing
right and it's been ongoing for quite
some time
but some of their formula is kind of
coming back to bite them a little bit um
with you know you can't completely do
like if a new person is to hop into
Destiny 2 now it's like great Point how
do you describe that story me an addict
told all time on boarding is horrible
then they vaulted stuff that you can't
play from the beginning new person you
know addict told me you know you're
trying to get lady addict involved one
time and it was just like where to start
right
yeah right yeah so yeah it's just like
log in and start shooting stuff and
what's funny is like the money thing is
the easiest thing and that's the sad
part it's like they have this new thing
with the cosmo drone now that makes no
sense half the time and it's just it's
completely it's not a fun experience
it's not and like it got to the point
where she was like I ain't doing it no
more like because they they because I
want to do it with her yeah so so I got
to the point where I had to do the
beginning part for her because she was
just getting so frustrated of what was
going on and and it's like I said and
that isn't the fact that we gave them
$200 and some dollars to do all that
yeah we might as well kiss that money
away technically sorry please the
tutorial
sucks the the way they give the
infrastructure to the game sucks the the
intro to this game for a new player that
sucks and then they wonder why they 45%
missing quotes like you're literally
only milking the current player base and
you're losing them too like especially
if to is and you're also and and to add
this little tip bit to it adct you're
losing it not only because of the luster
kind of wearing off but all these games
that were in Co having issues are coming
out taking away that that steam that
love that fire that was burning so so so
if this would a if lightfall would have
dropped in a year like where like like
like no disrespect to it lightfall would
have dropped in a year like the end of
2021 going into 2022 to where we had
kind of a space of just like not a whole
lot going on everywhere I mean sure
there's some stuff happening for
PlayStation with like Grant Turismo uh
Horizon forbidden West and you know they
like death uh what was it death Loop and
um ghost wi Tokyo and stuff like that
came out but like as for like
multiplayer like there was no Diablo
facts out there there was no man we
should have got forte in here we could
get him tell tell Forte if you want to
an event let him come through it's just
like finish finish so I'll talk one of
the last people because I'll rant I'll
talk over people I've learned you
passionate bro about the about Destiny
I've learned my evil ways of interrup
people I just can't talk until lasts
you're good bro you're good no finish
but you made a good point H in terms of
like the timing of this could this is
potentially one of the worst years you
can launch mediocre content and arguably
one of the greatest years in gaming
right some people are making that
argument like 2023 the lineup is just so
crazy so this is definitely one of the
greatest years in gaming yeah so if
you're like a destiny fan and you're
like okay I'm taking a break cuz I don't
like it you know you might not come back
between
you know tear of the Kingdom balers gate
Starfield Spider-Man Allan Wake 2 talk
about it yeah right it might be all for
you Diablo like it's crazy out here in
these
streets yeah exactly so I mean that's
that's for the most part all I got to
say I ain't keep beating a dead horse on
this no I feel bro I F I'm I'm beating
the dead horse he said beating the dead
horse they all owned by
Sony you going last or you going now
yeah I I I'll go I'll go all right go
you go we go together we got history
with this so let's let's get our
resident Destiny expert Lord Sovereign
you know person who lives for the
multiplayer experience live service
trained you know that's what you do the
hamster wheel the destiny artists yes
that's what you do so's up like what how
are you processing this information
Hunter how are you processing this just
like you know the news that's come out
the
layoffs you know each day there's more
information and um just in general you
know however wherever you want to go
with
it I was going to make a joke about it's
the day I've been praying for it for you
get your revenge on me you get to kill
my you get to kill my
baby but I mean no you didn't kill
Destin Bungie killed dtin that is true
that is true NOP Sony did it oh here we
go we wait for you we know where you
going we we going to get to that let's
get we know where you
going
buddy when I look at when I look at the
most successful game in this space
fortnite when you look at what that
requires for it to stay where it
is and to constantly be evolving
constantly adding new stuff to the point
now they're going back to the beginning
to sort of maybe give themselves a
little bit of a buffer while they come
up with more new stuff the fact that
epic was not absolved from having to
sort of clean house a little bit because
of the fact that Tim Sweeney said
himself it's like we're making we are
spending more money than we're bringing
in this is the biggest type of this game
on the planet really in a lot of ways
apart from mobile games and things of
that nature and even they a company that
has basically dedicated themselves to
that one game and Unreal Engine five is
saying that they can't sustain it this
moment was always going to come for
Bungie in some way shape or
form they were never going to be able to
sustain this level of production on this
game for a consistent amount of time
they built it to the point and I joke
I've joked about this in the past where
they built they've built the ups and
downs into the development of this game
you know that this game's gonna suck for
a while and come back up real real quick
s like I kind of want to push back
against that cuz you know even uh King
going to say it's Sony's fault and to a
degree I think some of these layoff is
is responsible with Sony because
obviously if they front the bill now
like yo you ain't you ain't putting out
you putting down now so it's just like
but when it comes to Destiny and Bungie
I'm sorry I'm putting all this blame on
Marathon because I personally felt like
this game was fine until they started
trying to multi-d develop games but this
is the thing and that's when it just
started slowly going downhill but think
about the sacrifice you're making though
right you're talking about a company
that in the past has been used to making
multiple products right multiple
products in the same genre in the same
uh in the same franchise right when you
talk about Halo but then this it turned
into a company that made one thing one
thing they they iterated on it they
evolved upon it but it's one thing
they're making right when you're a
creative after a while there it's going
to be burned out right there's going to
be the people that made it what it is
may may not want to continue being there
if they see that the product that's
coming out is is is is plateaued at a at
a certain the the thing they'll solve is
every time there's solid content for
Destiny it's kicking when from forsaken
to the witch Queen it doesn't matter how
much time is between these every time
they make good content it's kicking you
know why they can't make good content
consistently right now because they have
half the damn team working on another
game well yeah in conjunction I'm for
soft no no but but that is that that is
fair but it should be fair that they're
allowed to work on another game you know
what I mean like on that but that's like
you're you're only what's that that
saying it's like you you're only looking
at the trees not the forest it's like
how do you expect to build another game
especially when you maybe they thought
was Sony would front the bill for for
Marathon so they could easily do both
but to me it's like okay you know we
want to build another game because we
feel like this game does have a ceiling
and when we hit it we want to have a
fall back it's like but instead to me
like slowly building on they're like
okay all the PVP you are on Marathon
what about Destiny what about Destiny
that part is the fact the community has
been extremely upset that when Marathon
was announced all the features that
they've been clamoring for which is
dedicated uh servers you know the stuff
it's all been moving on marathon in s's
defense both of y'all right in s's
defense they've actually had it's more
thanes man like they they they was
matter which was another project can
basic yeah hero shooter there was a bag
I don't know how much substantial was
from um n e I believe they they received
at some point so yeah I mean there's a
lot of factors and then the thing I just
wanted I'm give it right back to because
we we always interrupt you we got to
stop but oh
adct no it's me too no no it's me too I
muted my mic CU you know what
is on Twitter s says you can get all of
his Tak
off all of it all of s has a lot thought
provoking things and then we get going
and we forget that he started it and
then we whatever but the thing I did
want to say is the also the added
responsibility of now you are The
Shepherd of Sony's game studios all of
their game studios live service continue
back to you back to your off so I think
I think that my overall take on it is
just like and this is just my sort of
thoughts on on the games as a service
right we talked about like last week or
week before like was the Sony pivot the
games of a service something should they
have done that right and my answer was
yeah my answer was yeah but if it
happened to the extent that we were
hearing where he's like he's telling
naughty do y'all need to do this and no
bring in your teams which you did do you
brought in teams that specialize in that
and have them work on those aspects of
those games of of new games right and if
you also want to incorporate your old IP
into that well then no don't have those
those base teams that are making those
single player games work on that have
them work together with these other
teams to come up with a product or
something or an extension of the basee
product that is multiplayer Centric that
has all of these micro whatever you want
to do to to monetize it don't make that
core team work on that stuff because
that is not what their strength is right
so we heard a whole bunch of different
stuff and as to as to what was happening
there and and and if the truth of the
matter is that you ask these teams you
have you ask duckman's team to be like
now I got to do this and you gotta pivot
to here that's not a smart thing to do
and you're not going to you're not when
it comes to to creatives they're going
to turn mom be like no and eventually
going to walk out and and you're going
to get a situation where now you just
have you're trying to figure out how to
move this product forward so my you said
they got stuck with a lot of product
yeah a lot of product and nobody to work
on it right and which is why it is on it
is what King on ice
right so so my thinking is just this
it's like look looking at this whole
thing with Bungie they've had a great
run with this game right he used P tens
on me oh no they they've had great sit
down sir you had a good run like this
give me some hope there was a 10 the
plan was 10 years right they just about
there my to be honest with you s I agree
with you like to me when you're telling
me you're laying off one of the lead
people that did all the music for
Destiny to me you don't see a future of
Destiny more and you're getting rid of
him now and there's nothing more telling
that's than when the when the community
walks away right when you have a forte
saying I'm done with y'all no matter
what y'all do that is that is crazy cuz
now now they've made the hard pivot it's
not like all Destiny like I said these
undulations that you know are coming if
you're a destiny fan it's like all right
there's going to be Hills they goingon
to be valleys we know it's coming right
no it's like I'm done with y'all this is
the last straw I'm moving on to
something else and they they're gonna
they're gonna give that bandwidth to
another game and I think all of all of
the the conversation around what has
happened recently
is an indicator to the community that
Bungie is I mean um destiny 2 at some is
is more and more becoming less and less
of the priority moving
forward so to the destiny fan that is
okay you're not going to be you're not
going to be caring about what I want for
the game you're not going to be making
the improvements I'm looking to see in
the game you're going to be moving
forward from that so I just think it's
happened in a way that again it painted
completely a negative light when you
when you have you let go of all these
people you let go of people that are and
we talked about last week how it's like
doesn't matter how much of a legend you
are within the industry within you know
to the fan base you're an employee to
them and it it sucks but at the end of
the day at the end of the day they're
gonna let you go you just become a
number and it's it's crazy to me as a
fan that you let go the guy that came
one half of the the team that came up
with the Halo the Halo they let go who I
believe also was part of the iconography
the the uh the Halo logo the logo like
iconic stuff people and it's stuff that
that the people that made this product
what it is that is egregious to me as a
fan but they made it back in the day
right and that's the thing what have you
done for me lately and them salaries
let's be honest of people who are let go
tend to be of the higher right if You'
been there from the beginning y your
your check might have more zeros than
the others exactly
it's probably not reflective of the
actual boots on the ground work you're
doing anymore just because you earn that
right I got a question for you guys real
quick though I'm wondering like so
you've seen their success obviously with
Halo you see the success with bung well
I mean not not with Bungie but with
Destiny over the years up and down but
pretty solid for like the majority of
the time would you say that it is okay
to listen to somebody that's kind
of damn King's going to roast this but
kind of a one-trick
pony then look at your game from Naughty
Dog oh you talking about the Sony
component okay I get what you got hold
that door hand the only reason why Ian
soft answer but I don't want it to get
into a full pad on this cuz this is
literally the next ST which we jump into
but you cooking you cooking we go
and S when you talking about like the
salaries yeah I actually think there's
more to it than the salaries you know I
hope this isn't the case but the way
like you know the these journalists are
you know talking about maybe they was
targeted because of how much shares they
hold in
Bungie and that's you know the whole
retention bonus and if it is that if it
is they targeted the people that would
realistically have the most shares and
would gain the
that's why that's why they kept the
right
people hit that man with on something it
always comes down to
money and if if thought you was getting
that yacht see but but my my mindset is
is okay they gave they gave Bungie this
this giant back and they're like low
this is for you to distribute to your
peoples to keep your peoples here and
then Bungie's like okay we're taking
that bag and then they gave it to
someone else okay where's my bag you
ain't going to be here long enough to
collect that bag that's why you don't
need
it
money yo bunie Bungie sounds like the
dude that go to his girlfriend when he
gets a stimulus check and said I can
flip that
flip let me let me invest that for you
let me they on that DJ NV Stu a not the
houses oh come on Flipping in j you know
I I actually I hope it's just the layoff
thing you know we just you guys have the
most salary we could get the most out of
laying you guys off I hope to God they'
like yo you know let's let's let's sell
for this extravagant number but we gonna
lay these people off before they even
get that that bad I got I'mma tell you
what's happening you know what's funny
like tell you what's if that is truly
the case I hope these people come
together and Sue the hell out of Sony
and suing nothing in their contract they
got they got Bamboozled bro you got you
got done son Let's off get his finish
boss let's off finish the boss to finish
out is this and to me for me it's more
of an indictment of games as a service
in general when you look at the biggest
game and what that the fact that it had
to make all alterations to how it
operated to continue to be in the
black what you look at with Bungie is a
situation that long-term
longer term feels like it's
unsustainable they were never going to
be making the money that a fortnite is
making they were never going to have the
bag going in that a fortnite has going
in and I thought it was always stupid to
look people looked at what what mobile
games were making and what these first
games like the fortnite the pubgs were
making and they they swore that they
were going to be able to do the same
thing what nobody felt it felt like no
one looked at as what it takes to run
that that machine and keep that machine
going day in and day out and that's why
so many of these games that come out
that are good gameplay-wise they die
quickly because they don't have that
stickiness A and B they don't have the
they don't have the bag to be able to
sustain that type of production on a
single product when you know that over
the course of time regardless of of how
popular something is the numbers are
going to dip you look at World of
Warcraft that's been here forever they
just announced a whole bunch of new
stuff at bitcon will talk about that at
the end of the day though that another
game that just undulations up and down
like it it the fact of the matter is the
fact of the matter is but they ain't
doing nothing nasty though the curve is
true you're not you're not you're not
boning no uh
yeah talk so anyway the curve's always
going down so at the end of the day it's
like it bothers me that so many
companies are are making this the
biggest bet that they're taking hey hey
take a take 50 to100 million and try to
and try to make one of these and see
what happens don't bet the farm on it
and then turn around be like oh it's not
working well what did you think was
going to happen the bar is here like
PlayStation's like take half our company
go make 10 of these yeah like I don't
understand that at all so to me is an
IND is an indictment on what games of
the service is and it's an indictment to
me on how it change the thinking of the
people in positions of power where it's
like they see this bag and they're like
yeah yeah we got to get it we got to get
it and I don't I don't begrudge them
trying but this is one of the times I
would say dip your toe in don't jump in
head first don't do yeah I like how Jim
do yeah I know you like how Jim do
that's why he he a All or Nothing
do and it's just like to me this long
term is not it's not going to be be a
good look it's not going to be a good
look I'm sad for the game I do hope they
just don't care about the game shut up I
don't care about the game but I'm sad
for the people that were there I got to
give them their props I give them their
props for making it this far because
they were there were times that you guys
as the bung as the destiny Community
y'all were in the drags I was like oh
this is the worst I said why definitely
right and and and they and they lifted
themselves up out of there so uh I give
it to y'all did they make it this far
because of them what s like a
bu I'm G try to be measured on this they
make it this far because of did they
make it this far sound talking through a
PlayStation no CU of y'all cuz you y'all
are crazy people that's why they made it
this far facts 100% he in the slop sink
I remember I know he he's in an
undisclosed location he's talking to the
little the wire in the cup let that man
cook let that man
cook off he got a couple seconds before
they find him in the
slopd on the job don't do that to the
man continue
for out there he's he's he's in the back
behind the the PlayStation fives that he
just Le y let me finish with
this it's a funny story because I
remember a long time ago going on BR
show and it was just after one of these
these undulations that I talked about
where Destiny was not the good place I
like your joy on this and then and then
and it's cuz I I went in there I was
joking right I was like I was like haha
that's what yall get that's y deserve
whatever and Luca got so mad at me Luca
was like oh I don't appreciate it you
come on here and you tell and you making
fun of people's uh you know misfortunes
and this that she got M like Luka chill
that's right she was she was in she was
indoctrinated with us right there at
that moment I was like I was like
obviously you not listening to ir's
podcast cuz you know this is my stick
this is what oh she didn't know that she
was playing I was like so she chilled
out but she got so mad at
me I was ripping y new one but this
again this is something that again you
guys I I God bless y'all y'all are crazy
but you guys stuck with this game in
spite of itself in spite of itself
sometimes because to Forte's point A lot
of times y' y y y every time somebody
pointed out something that that sucked
or whatever you guys are like yeah but
the Sky Box yeah but the shooting is the
greatest I'm like I'm like I'm like
really the shooting okay the shooting is
the greatest but you also have like doom
and other games have great shooting Call
of Duty but it's just like I was like y
really sticking with this game for this
W for this moment for me I'm not
gloating I'm not gloating at all but I
just listen man that man can glow let
that man glow I I could just see s like
I've been waiting for this
moment hell yeah s woke up this morning
saw the top and smile he literally doing
the mega I would have waited in Eternity
for this yo he sat back he said he knew
it was going to crumble and he would
still be here when it's
about this is his moment solves this is
equivalent to if King wakes up and
there's no
PlayStation this is equivalent to the
day that y'all find
out cuz I know already but when y'all
find
out
yeah continue so are you finished Ser
yeah beyond beyond that like again all
the stuff that came out about you know
yeah like the like you know uh boss is
not you know taking bonuses and
compensation and stuff like that all of
that stuff always always looks really
ugly right and and uh when it comes to
doing you know really really crappy
things like you know letting somebody go
with one day left of of coverage and
stuff like that and shares that have
invested so that they lose after they
were part of you know the company way
before the buyout happened and it's like
that that's just that again that's when
you know that's when you know that
you're a number and it sucks it really
does suck but business is business is is
a is bad like business
sucks always tell I always tell people
you're not working for a company you're
working with the people and in the
moment you in the moment you forget that
that's the that's the moment that you
you already losing so don't ever never
put yourself in a situation where the
company is the thing that you're
cheering cheer for the people that you
work with because those are the people
that make you want to work and stay at
that job even if you hate that job are
we are we are we uh referring to the
internal capitalized bungy tweets with
the with the explanation point well
listen listen I need to hear
it for for a week since it's happening
and I'm a little cooler now about the
situation but it's just more of and
you'll be the first one to no this
because I always complain to you about
it I understood this years ago about
this game there was things that I
refused to do in this game because I
just I was like I'm not doing this this
is stupid there's stuff that they make
you do that you're like why am I doing
this this is some tedious stuff and
you're basically just dragging on this
year to basically say you got content in
it a lot that is something that is I
I've never ever ever ever if I don't
want do it I'm not doing it and a lot of
people continue to do that so to Cog to
your point un Sol the the player Bas I
blame the player base I don't blame them
as much as I blame Bungie and I blame
Sony but I play play I blame the player
base because they allow this to happen
by continually playing the game when
there's nothing to do in the game if
there's nothing to do why are you
playing it there you go play something
else show them with your with your time
because guess what the yes the money
does matter to them but the engagement
is what matters the most to them when
they went and when they went to Sony and
they were getting bought out by Sony and
they evaluated themselves by saying hey
we're gonna hit these metrics now think
about it they when they got purchased
they were talking about final Shake
being on the horizon they were're
talking about um the uh lightfall being
on the horizon you just came off one of
the biggest pre-order games in the witch
Queen so they were looking at it like yo
we're coming up to the crescendo and
everybody's going to be playing this
game so PlayStation is like well listen
we we we want your game but you know you
want to keep your game but we we just
want the expertise PlayStation was like
so what the numbers going to look like
what they they overvalued themselves for
sure for sure they literally overvalued
themselves to PlayStation and guess what
I don't the reason I don't blame
PlayStation as much as PE other people
now they have no listen PlayStation no
listen King PlayStation has cability in
this just for the simple fact that they
didn't look deep in those numbers and
say how are you going to achieve this
45% you they lie about their own numbers
so how they go look at somebody else's
but King to for's point this was this
came up remember when the documents and
the trial came up I'm about to get loose
when Microsoft evaluated all these
company and we saw bu list they said
that burn rate was too high and there
was concern that they are if they are
really making the money that they say
they make they got the the retention at
the time but life I mean around that
time they were concerned about that that
was one of the reasons why
Microsoft I'mma get a hold of this dude
we got over a th people we got 300 or
something I'm listen I'm not going to go
ballistic I'll let ad go before me if
y'all don't get those likes up I need
600 likes I feel that I need 600 likes I
defin I definitely hear want to hear
what king gota say because I know he
gonna have some good points too but if
you go back to you know 2013 2014 think
about it they needed $500 million from
Activision just to get this game out the
door yes it wasn't their money they use
activid money I Love How She
Move I like listen they always tell you
they always tell you someone else's
money before you use your own and she
she she did that she did that and she
did that but thing is the thing is they
rolled off of the success that the game
had all the way through forsaken off the
dime of what what Activision did for
them by helping them get that game out
the door that was some of the best times
of Destiny consistently because the they
had ancillary Studios help get contentar
Vis that vicarius and High Moon Studios
you know vicarius built Forsaken and
theery for them which is one of the best
um you know Season EV they ever had God
here so think about that when you think
about that in general what Happ we all
celebrated when they went you know
independent we was like yeah go
independent we believe in you we trust
you and it was a slow start people gave
them a little bit of flux for some of
the stuff of the content leaks and stuff
but in general we was like okay we're
willing to wait we're willing to wait
and they just keep making promises and
what really threw me off is when they
sent this whole path forward message and
it read like the same message every time
budgie does something stupid it read
like those same messages that hmark card
that to
myself I'm thinking of and I got to be
100% transparent on this let's go I said
this when redf for Xbox when redf fall
went to the dump everybody was like yo
Starfield got to be a 10 out of 10 right
Starfield gotta be this it's got to be
that and you hear people complaining
about how Starfield didn't live up to
the expectations even if you felt like
Starfield was a good game you know
critically people feel like he didn't
live up to expect
because there was so much pressure on
that game to perform because of what
Xbox and just the state of what the
games where they releasing up into that
point what do you think is gonna happen
with final shape what do you think is
gonna happen with um final shape now
they out here promising the Sun and the
Moon to people they out here telling us
oh your game this game is we want to
make this game the best game we ever
made the you know witch Queen and and
King the standard that's what we want to
overcome we want better than that and
I'm like how are you going to do that in
four
months how are you GNA do that internal
internal you you just let go some of the
people that have the the the um the ear
of the
community yeah but they had the money of
the
community they say that stuff's already
done but you know I'm thinking like four
months ain't enough time for you to make
the grand changes that you think you
need to make in this game and there's
just a lot of other things on top of
that with Bungie being stretched Way Too
Thin Mak you know they're making
Marathon they're working on their
gunball game on Destiny's they're doing
stuff for PlayStation on the back end
every Studio what I told
y'all that's what I said Forte their
messaging literally doesn't make any
sense it never did make sense 100 I need
a hundred more let's go and it never did
make sense and I'm gonna let somebody
else cuz I'm about to get aned up about
it but you can interrupt what knocking
they knocking on the slop syn door they
like and
and and I think the worst thing about
all this the worst thing about all this
is we haven't even gotten to the fact
that they just let a hundred people go
of their yeah
talking G yeah we just talked about the
game now you got people out here
wondering if you even got people's best
interest at heart oh they damn sure
don't
so at that point the human element means
more than anything else because guess
what you just let go the whole Community
side of it that communicated with the
community and the sad part Forte is a
lot of the people that were let go were
the reports came out they were pleading
with leadership make the changes that
the community wants to we could turn
this game around if you don't shut up
you got to go you out here that's that's
hitting my bottom line
well let's get K yeah let's get K he
paay shent so K think I know where you
go King don't got 600 likes okay King is
about to do something else listen guys
I'mma tell y'all something right now cuz
I've been calling this for a second
I'mma let I'mma let Cog set it up yeah
but I need at least come on give me at
least to 555 come on man hit the like
sell yourself we need six we need that
600 we need that 600 it's a th000 y
y'all in here 1100 of y'all excuse me
you know what I'm saying so yeah let's
please be respectful it's great
discussion some jokes fun on Su Sol Got
Hand solo we got Forte cut class see we
we we we are in our own version of the
Multiverse right now you you got a you
got a a timeline where King just just be
regular king that's the one without 600
likes and then the 600 likes King just
Wilds out yeah oh hey y'all want the
wild out line
CU yo yo the Xbox let's show these dudes
how strong we are we about to get these
guys come on let's get 600 let's this is
equivalent to the to the chat holding
their hands in the air and giving King
that spirit ball like me the energy to
get these guys and and I got something
special at the end of the show for you
man let's go y'all go stick around and
I'm going to give you that 600 oh y they
don't play The King Advance the line
y'all definitely Advance the line that's
what I'm talking about
go it's Sony fault it's Sony why is it
son fault all right now check this out
right all right now now here goes the
whole thing Microsoft they went to
Microsoft first they was like hey boo
boo what's going ony what you doing and
she was like well you know I want this
this that and the third Phil was like
nah n your numbers don't even dictate
that cuz we look at real numbers we have
real dudes that check the analytics and
stuff over there we know how you was
from the last time we cooking the books
they don't first of all Sony Cooks the
books and they don't know how to look at
books Lord but we ain't gonna get to
that yet let's finish with what Phil did
cuz Phil they give the real numbers
y'all already know how many uh million
Xboxes out there they got 25 million all
right y'all like numbers here's for you
numbers dude so Phil was like all right
so what you bringing to the T what you
talk about what's up with this mattera
what's up with this Marathon I heard you
doing doing a lot of stuff over there
what's up with Destiny they put the
numbers on the table they was like
oh now we did have y'all in Game Pass so
this is the numbers we had oh yeah but
because we came off the most successful
yeah yeah but these are the numbers that
you was doing we like was in that game
pass we know what you really do boo all
right so but how much you looking for
well I'm looking for uh 3 point 3o what
3 point what oh well
billion he said boo boo boo boo go ahead
now go ahead now go ahead cuz you
bugging you bugging you know you don't
yeah you know in a couple of months you
GNA spend that money you gonna be right
back outside looking for
somebody spend it outside her bees yeah
yeah she works Gucci bag she she a spin
Thrift she a spin Thrift she outside
getting stuff she don't need buy two
pair everything always for no reason
only got two feet she buy two buy four
pair of shoes don't make no sense son
you only got two feet But Here Comes Jim
now ABK is up Jim gotta make a move I
got I gotta make a move I gotta make a
move I gotta make a move I gotta make
move Bungie saw him desperate on the
corner was like hey he was like yo you
did make Halo you did make Halo so
Bungie come with the fake numbers they
don't know how to look at numbers over
at
Sony so he was like how much you want
for that how much you want for that and
she was like well I take 3.7
billion The Voice like that why she got
that voice I take I take I'll take that
3.7 billion why you making like he's a
sucker like he's a her he hey he sound
like that that that Martin girl
yeah you know what I
did Jim was like all right all right I
do that I do that he said you take
payments though oh so so he a had a
buddy all the way up front he have it
all up front cuz you know feeling them
they come with their cash up front so
she was like I don't normally be doing
it a lot of
time okay okay because I I I normally do
with you know everything I get
everything so so two Des this is
something I do every day oh my God Jim
was like all I'll do the Billy but I got
some kids in the house I need you to
check out what they
doing is that PlayStation Studios his
kids I don't be watching kids like that
though I gotta be for the streets though
I would I really like Microsoft tool so
they they say son's on a lay away
payment so wait wait so they laid away a
open relationship is what so so so what
they did was he cuz he had F his F
wasn't right his F wasn't right so
that's why it was a go so he got destiny
over there they was like so all right so
here's the first payment it's like all
that look clean that look clean H
clean so so yo
um we got a retainership so you got to
keep the team um what's the
stipulations said no no no we give you
the money you distribute it how you
going to distribute it oh you gonna keep
that for me that's
Balenciaga so wait wait she she got B
take care the staff like yo she's like
she upep her own house she said yo y'all
just don't let them know that we going
to keep all right
everybody the deal is going to go
through we GNA keep everybody this is
not going to affect
anything cut them off as soon as we get
the chance and do it on the last day
where they can't have no insurance so
they I don't be paying an extra and who
getting the most shares oh I don't like
him anyway
not Michael salvator so wait a second
what happened to that AI y'all was
working with that AI stuff right do that
make music yeah yeah yeah let me hear
what they do they
contract they got the Tupac AI all right
all right all right let him go let him
go let him go oh let's get all those
shares back cuz we need more we need
more Gucci stuff we need more Gucci
stuff all right all right so cool so
right now what we doing what we doing
all right so um we got more staff we got
more staff we could let
go are they int to anything are they
intrical to anything that we doing no we
got AI to do that okay all right let
them go how are we gonna do it just cut
off their key card they won't and then
tell them and then and then and then and
then tell them don't tell
nobody they can't tell nobody and they
can't talk to their friends to exchange
numbers and stuff like that no collusion
no
collusion that part go down that part
we don't want to rise up so we're going
to lock them out one by one we going to
call we just going to call the managers
here and then let the managers know who
we let go but also don't let Tim in the
building because Tim like to
fight what Tim like to fight so all the
dudes that are you know the Rowdy people
they made sure that they key cards
didn't work so they couldn't get to the
other side they could oh if I can get to
the other
side so it's is Sony's fault though cuz
if they' have paid all the money none of
this happen but oh my God we heard that
Bungie mismanages money from what I've
seen right now they don't care about the
employees they mismanage money and if
you had funds that was set aside for
people that were supposed to be there
and they only went along with this this
Deale because of the premise was they
was going to be retained everything was
going to be looked after this is the
worst practices ever but this goes to a
bigger hole the bigger hole is
Sony the bigger hole is they have cus
cing uh uh cost cutting across the
boards that is true they have been
cutting things
forever y'all haven't been seeing it
I've been saying for a long time they've
been prettying their self up for
acquisition and dudes is like no they're
not Sony's running strong the numbers is
great the numbers of Destiny was great
we find out the truth the the numbers in
your PlayStation is great we finding out
the
truth every day we are finding out more
and more now when the light is on and I
told y'all the light is on now this abkd
uh puts the light on more severely than
ever right and we have people that are
vocal more than ever I seen people and
and don't get this Twisted I'm not
making fun of anybody losing their
job not at all because this is this is
more systemic of the problem that is
going on the ABK deal was largely
important of of for unions and M
Micosoft getting unions in this industry
had a union been in place a union would
been able to fight Sony tooth and nail
and Bungie tooth and nail to retain
their their shares I'm more pissed off
about their shares people lose their
jobs every day but if shares that you've
earned or shares that you have gained
through your hard work in these
companies is being removed from you to
go over there in a evil way so that it
falls back to the parent company and
they retain that money that was air
marked for you that is a problem and
unions save you so Microsoft is bringing
unions and this is why the opposition
was so hard this is the reason why
people were going at it so hard and you
ignorant Pony dudes sorry I don't like
using that word y'all wasn't fighting
for the unions you was too busy worrying
about Call of Duty going over here and
and and focusing on that you're not
focusing on the people that are being
harmed a lot of people are being laid
off all across the boards right and I
want y'all to go and look yeah you say
oh Microsoft laid off 10,000 people look
at how many of those 10,000 people still
had their health insurance and their
stuff going forward look at that of
those 10,000 people how many people
still had opportunities to move into
different layers and go into different
things over here we're hearing people
vocally go on social media saying I got
locked out and I don't understand what's
going to happen next that is true I
don't know I wasn't able to to exchange
a number with a colleague that set
across from me how are you ushered out
of the building like that what type of
Heartless manner is going on so this is
the environments that they're working in
over there do you think that's a good
environment now get to the fact that you
have final shape in these other games
and um not matter Marathon
final shavee gets pushed and I'm pretty
sure that I pre-ordered it I don't know
s can tell me um I think I did when it
when I saw it because I got hyped up
just like the rest of you guys and um
marathon is coming out they can't work
on their titles because they're
overseeing too much stuff I told you she
she will be overwork underpaid and under
staffed right so you don't have a staff
big enough and the reason why I'm saying
these things is because like Sol said
epic has one of the most profitable
games in in the world M and they can't
make as much as they output these
servers take money to run these games
and stuff take it takes a ton of money
they have a mobile game that they're
able to monetize there Destiny is not on
mobile so they have a cut off right
there they need to access that Sony and
highsight pay too much and they're
getting too little in return this is the
reason why I said Bungie won't be there
Bungie will get away somebody put and
said you gonna like this PO question
right somebody put and said they can't
leave because Sony owns them no it's not
true Bo ni read the contract yeah we had
hog talk about that they have one of the
most favorable acquisition contracts
he's ever seen they they there can be a
break there she
Bamboozled the hell out of gym and when
everybody got a chance to see this stuff
now why you think Jim is gone Jim has
made a lot of bad moves but Bungie's
ability to finesse the industry finesse
the fan base finesse the workers and
finesse anybody that she has ever come
in contact with is legendary y'all are
witnessing the Great finessa H well said
I a got too much to add with that um
look y'all know my history with this
game y'all know how much um this game
means to me obviously ion L's podcast
was founded because of this game this is
the game that brought me and adct
together um a faithful bet just try it
one time play you know play a game with
me and next thing you know we playing
that thing every night rating was our
highlight that's what we did and we
built a big community and I obviously I
have another podcast that most of you
guys know about which is called the last
word my brother ebontis and now taiy
Travis definely means a lot to me you
know and um again is it perfect no you
know we we s we all saw what the game
could be but it's the ultimate game to
play with friends and yes the shooting
to me still feels you know Second To
None you know the sky boxes to me are
still beautiful um the sound is just
world class and that is one thing I will
fight anyone in the street for is I
always feel it's a crime they don't get
nominated every year for sound but I
think what it is they're counting it as
Destiny 2 as the release they don't
count expansions and stuff like that I
let I let the the voting panel slide but
um no look you know the Michael saltor
thing definitely hit me hard I'm a
person as y'all know health is wealth
I'm in the gym video game music
motivates me Destiny's music is some of
the most iconic music period and then we
even talk about before that with the
Halo days you can say what you want
about you know Halo but Halo's music
that's 50% of why you enjoy in my
opinion like that that is so when you we
heard the Gregorian chance at the start
of a title screen purchasing a console
we knew Bungie this is different this is
a whole another level so you've got that
and um you know to me it's just
disgusting the way this thing played out
you know the disrespect like King was
talking about in reference to you know
veteran employees you let go of the com
team that's crazy the team that
communicates that listen to us all the
time the way it was handled with Senior
Management didn't even know there was
going to be layoffs nor their own
teammates who was going to be laid off
the the manner the cold calculated
manner you know look we understand Sony
is cut costing across the border with
their um their Studios but this is
definitely a bungee decision on as to
who and like s said you know you're
going to look at this is just it comes
down to money if some has too many zeros
next next to their name the sad part is
the Legacy didn't matter the Legacy the
the the the work that was put in the
Blood Sweat and Tears you were just a
number and and and just for the simple
fact that if you got through the month
you know you going to get that insurance
or whatever the vested is it it's just
it's really terrible then to addict's
point you know they came and and Forte
they came out with that statement um the
path forward first of all there was no
weekly bung which we knew was strange so
we know internally they like it's like
your business is out in the street for
the first time on a management level
that's the difference here you know and
and there was always sympathy okay they
left Microsoft maybe the treatment
wasn't there they left Activision I
remember the Bold statements by Luke
Smith where activ say hey we're not
satisfied with what forsaken did we
expected higher Luke Smith comes out and
says we're satisfied it was a rallying
cry when they went independent right but
as the layers come on
it's like the Scooby-Doo cartoon it's
like you know I would have got away with
it if it wasn't for these kids you take
the mask off it's bunie it's bunie like
it it's literally that and that's the
sad part it's all and the thing that
breaks my heart with this is literally
the people who were fighting for the
community and saying all the things that
we were saying that needs to be fixed
that needs to be address if you want
retention because one thing you know
what never got Nerf King eververse ever
never got nerfed that store with the
Emoji like they started this game has
the most egregious levels of
monetization i' multiple mon you're not
free to play cuz you loaded up you can't
really do anything you got expansions
you got battle pass if I want to buy a
shade oh no you got to buy it with these
three things that come with it then I
try to get Maddy plays into the game
he's like I just want to start at the
beginning and play it through you can't
do that because they put red War
campaign in the destiny content can't
play this story from front to back and
as addict said what really is egregious
this is when you knew there's a problem
financially when old expansions
forsaken Shadow keep still full price
still so if a new guy it has some of the
worst on boarding for a new player ever
you literally somebody has a video I
forgot this guy oh my God he he is one
of the funniest new content creators the
brother is hilarious he he has a skit
like all right guys I see Destiny I'm
going to get in with it all right so
what I got to get and the guy goes
through like seven things and then the
price end up being like
$300 you know what I'm saying so it's
just like bro it's just like it when to
me when you are hellbent on not
listening or changing that what does
that tell you to me oh that's that you
live in Check to Check energy that's
that you need that it's it's you're
living above your circumstan right and
you're over and and to s's point maybe
the business of Destiny right is just
not maing and they're overshooting and
then now we find out okay they needed
this Sony money to survive and this is
one thing I will push back on my brother
Travis cuz he was just like he was upset
at the time when Sony acquired them he's
like they should have stayed independent
I'm like bro there's a reason why these
Michael Tren Jacks ain't going away
there's a reason why they need the money
now you do this and you you over pro
project almost 50% more than what you
got mhm bro that is wild right so now
everything comes out the business is on
the street and now everything is on the
final shape and to addict's point is
pressure on Marathon right look I'm not
going to sugarcoat it you know I've been
in this thing I've been through all the
destiny Killers everybody in my timeline
the only thing that's going to kill this
game is them and right now this is
probably the bleakest I've seen it I I I
have to admit I I don't know if they
surviv this I'll be brutally honest and
you know who knows what the future holds
I'm pulling for the people who are still
there I'm sad for everyone who lost
their job but um this is bad and the
only thing I hope and this is this if
anyone is listening cuz I know I have a
lot of contacts at Bungie I know a lot
of you listen one thing I say is that
the thing that's sad is the the people
who were making the wrong decisions were
not let go in any capacity so they kept
the right people right we gonna get into
that statement right listen listen
collusion Pary still there right a and
my thing is if this isn't a wakeup call
for you to actually listen to your
development team and what the community
is saying I don't know what to tell you
so me where I'm at with it if this is
the final s song I have to write this
thing I've been in this thing for 10 I
need to final shap you in your final sh
I'm in the final I have to see the story
out bro I have to see the story I'm not
gonna I'm not going to let me finish I
I'll give it to you I'll give it to you
after I finish I've been playing this
game for damn near 10 years I it's like
the the best example I could give you
for take is I know where you're going
is like game Game of Thrones remember
how everybody say yo they rushing Game
of Thrones bro what the hell this thing
was this is how it feels to me I need to
see what happens with the night King I
need to see what happens with the Dr as
as as terrible as it may sound at least
you knew about that before it happened
at least at the end of the day though if
if if if we stay through to the end and
they still drop the ball I'm out stay
through the end I I just need to see how
the Final Act can I've been here this
long I want to see the Final Act you
know I'm not going to not watch the
final season of Game of Thrones because
I heard something you know what I'm
saying that's just where I'm at now
listen I'm not judging you or anyone
that says bro I'm done cuz they burnt
the trust they broke every relationship
I get that they they they their business
is so out on the street they look so
crazy that's why the hope to be is like
yo you got to listen now if you don't
listen what you going to do you know
what I'm saying or you going to separate
from Sony so look I'll let you go for T
cuz I know where you're going to go I
just want to give my position that was
it and let me go real quick oh yeah
please I'm sorry well at the end of the
day this Bungie and Sony thing it's like
you know this pivot from from games of
service we're gonna talk about that here
in a su uh in in in a minute it's just
like I've been on this I'm done with
Bungie thing for a while I got tired of
you know even with trying to get the
girl playing and it's just a nightmare
even besides that you know just talking
about got tired of them selling me old
content
you know there was a famous thing where
it's like what gun are they going to
sell us from Destiny 1 in this new
expansion and try to wrap it up what
what and and what's funny is like now
we're gonna bring back old rids but
we're gonna take away old stuff and give
you old stuff in return and it's like
okay you know we we got rid of Titan we
gonna bring that back we're gonna
redecorate it bring it back this might
as well be a Halloween event
so the mood's gone don't worry we're
going to bring back that back to you in
another expansion you you going to pay
twice for that
content it's just like and I got tired
of everything is always in that reverse
there's no way of getting it it's just
there it's it's lbo thing that you have
to access by going to and you know
what's funny is at least they made
certain things back but you still had to
pay it's okay so you want the $60 to buy
the game you want the 50 50 50 50 50
5050 for the
expansions if you want to look even
remotely presentable we want the 10 the
15 the 20 the 30 the 40 the 50 you like
the drip cost bro you could even buy to
level up the battle it's crazy and then
they're like okay I used to think that
Desy had an okay monetization route
because of bright dust but guess what
Sony guess Sony guess guess what did
was like we're going the faucet used to
be good you can get bright dust from
multiple scenarios multiple areas you
can get a a decent amount of bright dust
so like we're gonna we're gonna tighten
that you know now now you only get
bright dust for certain things in the
game and it's just like I said it just I
got I got TI adct want his break dust I
got tired of every time I felt like they
were in a the correct path okay you keep
this up that okay now we got the trust
back from the destiny Community let's
pivot again good point and that to me it
reflects what's going on because it's
like good good cycle bad cycle and to me
it's the in if I had to guess upper
management and the need for the
monetization model is superseding what
is good for the health of the game and
sometimes it's okay to take a break but
they want to keep you in there every day
and then over monetize you and for the
first time they like s said they have
broken one of the TR the trust of one of
the most loyal communities I've ever
seen and I don't know if you come back
from that I gotta be honest as a person
who's always say yo that's gonna be
there don't care what you say I gota
look at it like you might not get out of
this one in the final
shap final I want to kick you off the
show right now you
really time me and Co went back and
forth on this because I was like in my
personal opinion I don't see a destiny
after final shake and one of the
first you said you said that I got to
give you that I was looking at like how
are you gonna give dedicated servers to
a new game but not say but don't worry
we bringing them to Destiny because to
me that shows where your heart is that
shows where the future of you think your
company is is the stuff you're giving
all the nice stuff to when you're
pulling you're pulling everyone off of
your pvping right and you're putting
them on another game to me that's where
you're showing where you want those PVP
players to play when you pull when you
lay off the the person responsible for a
lot of the music and Destiny which which
Co said should have been in Game of the
Year uh in terms of like soundra every
year should have been there at the
VGA I see that as we don't need him for
Destiny anymore facts we going Outsource
they literally Outsource into the
cheapest stuff as well yo
I I think those three
episodes depending on how Marathon does
if Marathon comes out well they booed
Marathon son ain't no they said raise
your hand nobody they like nah that
ain't it son if Marathon comes out and
it's not successful I think that th
those three episodes after final shape
that's they'll be like okay someone grab
that grab everyone and back in everyone
to the destiny building now but to my I
personally feel like Bungie as a whole
cannot maintain two games as a service I
just don't think it's possible I can't
even maintain one right now I think if
if marathon is mad
successful Destiny's done they're they
they they AKA they will put that they
will put that sucker they will put that
suck on auto drive to give you the bare
minimum maximum
put me over there right now and and
that's just my and like after those
three seasons they'll start winding more
and more down they'll give you more
we're we're going to be in the OverWatch
territory in a couple years where it's
like man remember that good old days we
you going you gonna hear this a lot we
didn't know we was playing in the good
days because now and that's a be thought
but who she gonna be with who she going
to be with that's that's the whole thing
like who who she who she going to shack
up with we going to talk about the bungy
dogs like we a talking about let's
transition this I'm sorry please I'm
almost done it's like you know it is
what it is you know I think that their
future is Marathon I don't think
marathon's going to be what they think
it's going to be uh you know I think
Bungie and you know we're going into the
games of the service thing now so we'll
go ahead and go to that it's like I hope
they do you know I hope final shape is
the best it could be CU to me unless
they do something crazy final shape is
where I'm off the bus yeah that's the
It's the final it's the last final me
I'm already off the bus now yeah but
final shape I I'mma see it through you
know I'm with Cog I don't care what you
guys say you know they were roasting me
in the Attic show you can roast away I
don't care because I've come too far not
to see this out yeah I just want to see
the end end end of a story that invested
Dam near 10 years old it's calling death
in your
wallet I'm not shake
down yo he said the final shake that
wow the people in the chat the people in
the chat that are telling me addict the
right thing to do is Boycott you are
100% wrong I'm the outliner in this you
know youo this is one of those things
where I said it's not our fault it's the
developers fault the publish fault cuz
they got us by the balls man they got
the ball they got you got you Forte is
out we lost Forte man lost me they lost
me long
timeo yo what's up what's
up what's up I know damn well ke's
playing this when it comes out yo listen
King did you play lifefall Yo Yo okay
yeah yeah listen listen did you play Yo
I play all of them um Sovereign knows I
think I already purchased final Shake
might got that whole thing yeah I got
the I got the whole package no I'm not
listen hey hey s did you say he's
refunding that have you had that call
yet I had it I had it forever they not
giving me that money back son it's past
30 days you can refund Stu he has he hit
you up like yo no I'm not I'm not doing
that because you know listen listen
listen I'mma keep it a buck I laugh at
Cog saying I got to see this through
yeah of course I got to finish the fight
I'm feel I
feel I'm doing it too adct I'm a
[Laughter]
fraud that was perfect
time yo yo chat what part of me being a
fraud don't you understand Chad someone
needs to clip that
the ad the ad I roast Sony every day but
I got a PlayStation 5 and I got more
PlayStation stuff than all them dudes
and I play like you guys don't fall for
the hype I'm a gamer bro and with this
controversy you going to see my face all
all for go we got to combine the top
real quick before you go Forte members I
need some fraud alerts in that chat
fraud alerts in the chat in the chat in
the it's in the chat the the man came
full
circle listen Forte come on we gotta go
I gotta get this combined this to the he
ain't lying he ain't lying it's like
right now emotions are running High EXA
care we care about this game one trailer
and as much as I sit here like listen I
didn't buy final shape yet I I just I I
was key word yes I didn't buy I didn't
buy right now my heart is telling me I
don't need to buy this DLC cuz you it
ain't out yet exactly bu hasn't dropped
that Fire trailer yet that's gonna make
say ah wow this amazing Cade come back
the number one hun this is the thing I I
put in I had a I had a I had a bid for
10 years that's right you got locked up
we we got locked up together for 10 we
10 down in
this I got out on good behavior at n and
a half
now I'm now depending on how the next
six months go months go I'm sitting
there like okay she gon get her life
together I am not gonna lie I am more
picking up the DLC than not picking up
the DLC let's go for but but I did tell
myself and and Taz and Luca and
everybody can contest to it right the
final shape was it for me
yes is it for everybody sh here's the
thing Forte what's the final ship ships
we can all we can all we can all get off
the train
together not we admit this lastly can we
admit this though let's go let's go just
like Phil Spencer said back in said a
couple years ago he said the worst
generation to lose was in 2013 which was
last generation because everybody built
their digital libraries is it easy to
say that this was the worst Year yes to
have their well wor outing when it comes
to absolutely all of these other games
are pulling people away and the entrance
of your game drops to the floor because
I could go play something else I've
always had all these games to play but I
just never played them because I love
Destiny so much but now that once you
got out of it and took the roll tinted
glasses off you're like yo there's a lot
of stuff there's a lot of look how many
games I'm finishing when I don't play
thiso is so they they such a fraud yo
and I'm going to sit here and I'm going
to tell y damn the day okay so when
final shade come out and they going to
do whatever they going to do and
whatever numers ah H when they hit you
with Destiny M three
oh with graphics with new graphics
graphics with new graphics and the
graphics is
crazy you know what you on to something
cuz I'm right back on the train exactly
here's the thing but I got it but they
claim there's no 3 they they yeah yeah
they they claim a lot of things like
they claim they was keeping all they
soldiers when they got the money they
they claim a lot of things things happen
in these streets son like they they they
came they claim they was good when they
got to Activision they claim they was
good when they got to Sony true they
claim a lot of things we got to move we
got to move but to K and to anybody
again it's it's a personal decision if
you're out you're out I respect we back
yeah but do not attack anyone who says
they're out and do not attack except for
King except for
King I'm out and then I'm in again I'm
alive I do want to combine this all all
we already kind of talked about
PlayStation
games k do you want your Cann thing
because we kind of talked about
PlayStation games and service or you
still want to oh no I need to talk about
um I need to talk about that I just just
I just need one rant because I know y do
y saw that Sony pivot y'all know what it
is so can can n affiliate uh it's not
even Ro reuter's song it's it's reuter r
e u
t I've never heard so what is this s's
he's new K news affiliate look look at
the start of this titles off they say
that PlayStation will change one of its
decisions in the controvers
deflation that is the name of the title
they say that PlayStation change one of
its most controversial decisions for
this plan who is day and what is this
plan but we going we got you know what's
funny the the the the amount of news
King tries to bring to K Anda news K
news he'll he'll be posting articles in
the chat that's like two years old I'm
wondering how were you even able to get
to this site because if you put in if
you if you write reuter yeah it's just
gonna give you Reuters R you I are
you got you got to the site clean right
good all right all right check check the
paragraph is like Roto
rer caned affiliate man sources assure
that recent layoffs and the crisis what
this oh my God English what PlayStation
is going through is due above all to
attempt to bet on games as service fans
of the brand believe that it is a
mistake according to a report with no
sourcing sod is aware of the discontent
of players and the developers regarding
this game model for this reason it is
said the company will change focus and
that he who is he and he already has an
alternative plan um PlayStation will
rely more on third parties and bet Less
on games as a
server off the sorcy various reset error
users discuss and criticize the approach
of PlayStation yes and Sony in the Gaze
of the server everyone was struck by the
statements as of a user known as head on
the Block stated head on the
Block stated that several studios are
working on production of this type and
some of them were forced to stay to St
do so the most interesting thing is now
Sony will change his strategy and allow
third parties to work with the franchise
in a more open way he stated I guess
head of the block um that Sega and band
Namo are supposedly working with
PlayStation IP so head of the block
states that this adjustment will take
time to materialize yeah this is
definitely written by
AI this is for the streets this prob
this is worse what was that dude that
had the es RAM for the Xbox One what was
that this is that type of energy oh but
anyway yeah so there's a possibility
that PlayStation will change its focus
to uh from all single player titles and
third parties games as a service so uh
King this is your dude site affiliate
this is clearly what you wanted to talk
about today yo uh uh the pivot all right
so you guys wanted them y' don't like
game of services right y it's not
working y' ain't get not one of those
games out yet but y'all don't like it
y'all don't like how it smell Sony ain't
moving how they supposed to move all
like this I need them to go back to what
they've been
doing all right so they they going to
Pivot they going they g go back so
they're going to take all the five years
of what they was doing and they going
throw that in the garbage and it going
to take 5 to 10 more years again to get
you out a single play experience y'all
brought this change I I appreciate y'all
standing 10 toes down y'all didn't want
no game of services even though none
came
out and and they and
them they ain't G to do it no more so
y'all win today y'all win it's no
PlayStation 6 because of
y'all oh so because they they won't play
ACC to head of the block y'all don't
even want them to try y don't want them
to head of the block
said y'all don't like these type of
games over there so s said you know what
budhist man let's get this stuff
out and no game Ser for y'all Y y'all
got get the single player stuff but
that's coming in 10
years and it'll be over for y'all then
oh yall going to get that DLC for God of
War watch that trailer the DLC is coming
but they going to charge $70 and call it
a full
game
somebody somebody said head of the block
AKA King David so say shut
up B mother said this reads like great
fan fiction someone said it's a AI
article y they Wilding so um yeah
uh we can move on
we I got to get my esteemed guest um
what do your thought do you think
they're pivoting away from um you know
games is service now or do you think
things are still in place and you're not
listening to head of the block ah no man
head of the block clearly has his head
off
straight I'm definitely
listening news
okay I
mean their sources are uh are top
tier we work hard in the Fieldy move man
you ain't doing it right yeah
but but but no I I do think they're
actually going to be moving a little bit
away from that I don't think you're
going to see like the 10 to 12 that they
were talking about whatsoever at all I
think you might see like half of that
which is still a lot right but I but I
think they still need to evolve into it
somehow some way because they're very
behind yeah the reason that you could
see Microsoft moving the way that they
are with any type of live Services
because they they've been known as a
multiplayer console for their entire
existence right that's where you go to
play with your friends that's where the
communities are that's how you talk to
people I mean my wife I didn't even have
to tell her how to use a community tab
in there she went in there she playing
with all sorts of different type of
people from Halo all over the world
which is what's up I love that because I
ain't trying to play Halo all the dang
time but um but uh but but yeah the the
way that Microsoft kind of has it taken
care of is you know that they're kind of
good to go um as for Nintendo Nintendo
kind of always does their own thing
looking at Sony they're known especially
for their single player game yeah but
what's those numbers been looking like
not so
high when you look at what they've been
making a ton of their money on it's like
microtransactions and stuff like that
from third party games such as Call of
Duty so they want to keep that money in
House of course I feel like I'm saying
obvious things but at the same time it's
just like man what are y'all gonna
do for this live service what are you
guys gonna do gas wise because it's just
like I'm not really feeling or I'm not
sure how many people would really feel
like a
horizon I and the thing is is they like
to dip back in even Jim himself himself
said we want to really focus on the
first party games that we've been
releasing as of lately right and you can
kind of see that within their VR it it
looks like they're going to be possibly
having a God of War DLC which we thought
that this game was supposed to be the
DLC right but they said we got the DLC
on top of the DLC to give it I'm hoping
that Spider-Man comes out with the DLC
at oh that's coming you know that but
dlc's I mean that that's a lot of
ongoing you know money being spent
compared to just like letting the game
kind of chill putting the stuff out
there and just letting the community
continue to buy and buy and buy out of
that store and I just don't know how
they're going to make that work
cohesively I mean e even with the last
of us I was thinking about the last of
us and I've had somebody ask me hey man
if the Last of Us factions came out
would you play it and I'm just like well
I'm I'm sitting here trying to imagine
what something like that would look like
and I'm just thinking well is this going
to be like something like a fortnite or
something where like the walls kind of
come in closer like a war zone or
something I mean how are how the heck
are they gonna make that loopable for a
long to multiplayer right especially
since they built the game around
characters that you have feelings for
you're going to give me a bunch of just
random looking people around the town
and tell me to have some sort of of
affinity with that game and then I also
think it's only going to be hot really
around when the TV shows come out and
then that game's going to drop like a
sack of rocks sack of rocks maybe that's
what I think they should pull it back a
little bit but I I I I do think they
should Advance forward and not just hold
on to Bungie when it comes to is this
the right way to do this is a they
clearly don't know the right way for
themselves D oh damn they clearly don't
know the right way for themselves so
it's just like at some point you just
kind of got to trust in yourself do what
you think is right put something out
there and see if it hits fair this whole
10 to 12 thing that's telling me that
you literally are just grabbing mud and
flinging it at the wall yeah no real
something can stick yeah all they need
is hasht just one hash just two for them
but I know adct said he's not really in
care about this topic so it just comes
down to it's like look they're clearly
pivoting like there's no ifans buts
about it they're clearly pivoting they
they've laid off people that worked at
these Studios they put Last of Us
factions on Ice they got they like
defunded that entire Studio that was
making another one like they I mean you
just seeing layoffs and budie by itself
because that's probably the the most key
component to their games as a service is
someone to supervise the games of
service and they they getting rid of
people over there too so it's just like
I person
they but they kept the right
people I personally feel like and I know
I might get some flat for saying this I
think you're going to hear a lot of
comparisons between Jim Ryan and Don
matrick I I I think he has royally
screwed up their brand I think he did it
better
though I think see microsof was still
able to survive I don't think these
dudes get out of this
Quagmire I I personally feel like he put
them back a whole generation thanks
they're still going to sell well because
they still have that brand recognition
but you're going to slowly start to see
you know it's one of the reasons we
don't see no games from them like Sony
has in the past has had no issue and
it's worked out well for them showing
games years and years in advance why
ain't they doing it here because most of
these games either at the beginning of
development or they're have't even
started development yep it's just like
telematic the proof is in the pudding if
you don't feel like eating it that's on
you that ain't on me that's right he
don't like that pudding yeah I don't man
yeah but at the same time it feels like
they've I feel like the magnifying glass
is just getting
stronger as the as the uh you know as
time progresses As Time unfolds and
everything like that and you see they
third eyes waking up
son I'm just saying you've seen
Microsoft kind of do this and like grab
activis and pull them over here and it's
just
like it seems like Phil Spencer pantsed
Jim Ryan right then and there and said
oh so you was leaning on third party a
little too much and I take that far away
from you can't lean on this Sony does
have quality Studios and it's going to
help them pivot more because they they
do have especially people like him saw
me delivering uh like an absurd amount
of cont uh uh uh content like very very
fast but that's not going to carry a
whole generation I mean think about
what's going on the we've had naughty
dog really ain't delivered nothing since
the PS4 we we huh I said talk about that
yeah I mean where where's ghost of
shishima we should be definitely in
conversations with the second one no
announcements it's on
ice and it's just like I'm kind of C
curious if the Legends which would
turned out to be a good games of service
mode was because of Jim Ryan too maybe
you know he's like you we want you to do
some type of thing and I think he's seen
success in certain areas and he's like
okay now now we're going to Triple down
we're not doubling down we're tripling
down and it's just like look like
clearly you see what's going on I I
don't think that I don't think like
Sony's a Brand's going anywhere unlike
King I still think there's going to be
be a
ps6 you only you only say that because
you want to feel safe me I'm out there I
don't care y ain't getting no
PlayStation 6 you ain't getting it it's
done people are convinced that you know
we're going to see Wolverine next year
for some reason and it's just like okay
like and what's funny is like what what
else could come out Naughty Dog most
likely they're were in some form of
development hell so I don't think
they're radio for game Ben Studios
already said they they're wild out like
it's so but Ben Studios is a backup
Squad
now they playing the D-League pause the
problem is is some reason they listen to
Jim Ryan and maybe it was more than
maybe it was more variables ofan no I'm
talking about the Sony like Sony Sony oh
oh they they stopped listening to him
they cut off his ke oh yeah they they
they they cut him out and it's just like
you know it's like I said like when you
look down it and you look at the
semantics and you look at just the
numbers in general everyone wants
fortnite money but most people if anyone
has fortnite products and and you know
games as a service works but it cost a
lot of resources a lot of Manpower and I
honestly truly thought Jim Ryan he could
go in there half ass and able to produce
all of these games as a service and you
seen it with stuff like uh all stars
because I'm pretty sure that was uh you
know one of the initial things that they
were going into this with because that
was like a form of a game as a service
yeah destruction I love that game yeah
you you you've seen it with a variety of
these games and then not to mention we
saw all the rumors like Jim Ryan he
didn't ask these companies and they
agreed he he made them go this direction
he bought all of these Studios because
he said he wanted to help with games as
the service but he still made the other
people that didn't want to do it do it
that's the reason there's so many that's
the reason Connie got fired and half her
Studio walked out with her because it's
you know what's
funny they're switching what Microsoft
used to do Microsoft used to to to to
reach their hands in and say you making
this and now it it looks like having a
ball over here I know he weezing he
having a
be you good no I'm having a great time
had to keep going yeah I just think it
it's one of those things that I just
don't understand you know I don't think
no one's screaming that this is the end
of Sony I do
think you told me a lot of bad things if
you would have told me that to to invest
in a company with all those bad things
that you just said I won't but I love
the way you cooking and and then and
then when you look at it from like the
future standpoint what what do we really
have to look forward to over there right
now we got Final Fantasy 7 rebirth which
is going to be an amazing game
that's it rise r r r Stellar blade but
I'm talking about like from the like
games coming to their the same thing
like if it's not any place else except
PC if you play on PC then best stuff
coming to Xbox it's a wi to change bro
that's fine but it didn't come in Xbox
day one I just think in March from their
standpoint and I and part of me thinks
that Jim Ryan was scared of the
expansion that Microsoft was doing
and you know Microsoft
has all the games of the service that
Sony dreams of having sea of Thieves wow
at this point uh fallout 76 Elder
Scrolls Online uh Minecraft let's go
they they have games that literally Jim
Ryan would commit murder for murder you
say that's crazy you say that adct
because the thing about the thing about
murdering Jim Ryan is done is the
studios he left behind the thing the
thing I want to get out real quick the
thing I want to get out real quick is
that um Jim Ryan really seemed to siphon
the creativity away but adct is sitting
here saying that he die to have this
stuff like it it just kind of counters a
little bit to me
because a lot of CEOs and stuff like
that that we believe to be money making
tend to kill off a lot lot of creativity
to get the back I I think this is one of
those things it's like the dude at the
end of the day he wasn't a game he he he
might analyze the the gaming industry
but he don't actually sit and play these
games like that you know that's one of
the difference between
Phil and Jim was Phil was like yo that
ain't gonna work because I've played
these game and I've seen the evolution
I've se you say he don't hold the
controller upside down or
run hold upside down okay I'm done cuz I
feel like I'm just encouraging King
clearly he's going to keep on the pom
poms with you um that's my guy it's my
guy your thoughts quickly um as far as
the um PlayStation do you think they're
going to Pivot or or not you think
they're going to stay the course games
and service I mean put an exclamation on
this uh we'll see where where they go if
they if they roll back some of that hard
pivot and it's just going to be you know
a couple of games or whatever um from
these new Studios that they have or are
they still going to keep that push and
trying to make you know service games
within their core franchises we'll see
we'll see what they decide to Pivot to
but at the end of the day I think the
big problem is that the entire gaming
industry convinced itself that in order
to stay relevant in the future this was
the way right it's convinced himself
that the only way to stop overspending
and making you know $250 million AAA
games is to go the service route not to
stop spending that much money no God
forbid no the the idea is okay we'll
pivot to this because there's been
success in this space and it it just
feels like there's been so many pivots
and there's been so many failures and
nobody's looking at this and saying hey
for us to attain that level of success
in this space we need to invest this
much time this much money this many
resources it's that Pie in the Sky thing
solve they don't see the failures they
just see the one success see exactly
that was the Google stadia oh we could
make games we we have an internal Studio
it lasted a year and they were out gone
they sold off the studios that they
bought around longer than a trillion
dollar company in the gaming industry
that's crazy it it is it is ridiculous
to me that they still continue to feel
that this pivot to games as this hard
pivot where these games have to be all
about that and we're looking to make the
next fortnite it is a stupid Endeavor it
is a Fool's errand go in make some of
these games make smaller games smaller
budgets see if the game play scks the
the community will tell you if it is fun
and something they keep want they want
to keep playing and then allow yourself
and at the same time look at remedy look
what they're doing with $70 million
budgets they figured it out somehow they
figured it out I love that you don't
work at the head of Sony thank you no
because it is it is you look at that
it's like why can't we make a game that
is 10 to 15 hours why does God of War
Ragnarok need to be a 35h hour Odyssey
why did Last of two get they don't get
reoccurring money solv on these single
player games but it it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter cuz you still what does
it matter if it's if it's 15 hours or 35
hours right it doesn't matter because
once you're done with it you're done
with it I love they want you to be done
with it after 30 hours I played I played
it once I played it once and I'm done
with it until three comes out that I'll
probably replay two that's the only time
I'm G to replay that game and yeah so
what is the need to have me engage for
35 40 hours engage me for 15 that
Revenue love it yeah no but the revenue
be the same charge me $70 for it I don't
care TR the reoccurring after the you
know I'll let you finish I'll let you
but reoccurring on a single player game
the reoccurring part is when you you
release it on PC right that's the type
of stuff so to me it you making a longer
game a game that has this crazy bugged
out budget doesn't change the realities
of single player games in this space it
doesn't so they tried to they tried to
Pivot to instead of figuring out the
problem that was in front of them they
projected someplace else and be like nah
this will fix it and we can keep doing
making the same mistakes in this space
that we've always made
so it's it just doesn't make any sense
to me look at what remedy's doing figure
out how to make high quality AAA games
for less money and less time and you can
still dip your toe into this and it and
and if you get lucky and you make a a
game that people love and is making
money hand over fist be happy with that
add to that and don't try to go beyond
your means don't try to rise above your
station it's always you're always trying
to live up to something literally epic
turned its entire business around and
said fortnite is our business they from
M they went from making other games to
fortnite and unreal that is it it was
that much of a moneymaking No Sol no I
understand but so is Sony is Sony going
to Pivot completely to one oneu I feel
you on the on the aggressive yeah so
this is the thing but there so many
people that are much smarter than me
looked at these scenarios and said
obviously they not and it's like how do
you look at that and be like yeah we
could do the exact same thing no you
can't unless you're willing to spend
billions of dollars on on a yearly basis
to ensure that this community is kept
satiated with with with with content
that is good right and and and
refreshing like it just it's a very
difficult thing to do it was always
going to be a very difficult thing to do
like it's like it's like they looked at
mobile and they saw how much money you
could make with mobile with a small
product that C they didn't cost a lot to
make and then they projected that
outwards into AAA gaming into a game and
and and the the it's not the same like
I'm not going to sit here and say that
that development into Candy Crush is
minimal but when you look at that
product I don't even know how much they
you know how often they add new levels
to it or whatever the case may right so
it's crazy but you I can guarantee you
that it doesn't cost as much to work on
that game as on a Destiny and Destiny
doesn't make a quarter of money not even
even remotely close to what candy crust
makes on a yearly basis so it's like
they looked at it and they it's like
they glanced it over they glanced it
over and didn't read the fine
print it's like they looked at it and
they were like yeah you know oh but
maybe you want to read the fine print
nah we're good we we understand it y I
love that y'all make my point for me the
point that I was making before did laugh
that I love real quick real quick real
quick everyone in the chat everyone in
the chat go over here and like this
Twitter post oh you messy I know what
you're doing you mess anyway yeah this
is the fraud stuff when uh they were
talking about if you go by [__] we got
to get those likes up
man I got to see what the hell he did
you got your B I was going to yeah I'm
done man I just I don't I again I hope
they I hope they they stop and think for
a moment and like okay hey let's figure
this out in a smart way and stop trying
to go beyond their means and stop trying
to rise above this station do what you
do well and then dip your toe and other
things to make more money I get it but
stop stop with this overreaching like
doesn't make any sense to me think it's
the first time you like disagree
strongly on this I mean I get what
you're saying I get what you're saying I
think I I agree with you on the pivot
may have been too aggressive right and
in in that you know you going to make 10
live service games bro we going to make
10 we going you know what I mean and and
where I completely agree with addict is
like especially when the talent that you
have is not known for that like the the
talent that you have is the the hashtag
just one cinematic AAA narrative heavy
Focus high graphic fideli but the thing
is s them games is wild expensive to
make and I think what king is saying is
true to it like Jim is looking at that
like look you know I mean h said it like
when you look at for it's not even NPD
no more is Sak whatever it's called that
right and the top 10 games played on
Playstation right the majority is third
party right multiplayer or these other
third party G it's not necessarily not
saying that the the bangers don't do
well when they come out but they don't
sustain for the life of the platform and
I think Sony's looking at that and I
think I got to be honest I think look
them talking to Bungie was probably done
talking for all some time but I am the
firm belief that that was accelerated
the minute they found out about ABK
because now that puts the fear of God of
you in a revenue Source they're
negotiating that price but then when
that ABK deal happened now just give
them what they want right you know what
I'm saying at the end of the day it's
like that Revenue that you were sitting
back you didn't have a long-term Vision
let's just be honest not even long in
defense of Sony there's no way in hell
anybody thought Microsoft could acquire
activis let's just be honest if you
would have told us that for outside of
Sol who predicted it you know saying you
know if you would have told us that that
that was available to be acquired
and that Call of Duty would be the home
of Microsoft so to speak and be able to
be put in that service that had to throw
off their whole course of action now you
really got a PIV so now you going to
sign that deal with Shen as quickly as
possible you know what I'm saying you
going to try to because you have to
secure a future now and something that
you really don't do now I agree that
pivoting all your resources in that way
might have been the dip this is where
I'm with you the dipping of the toe is
probably the Cor correct approach which
is okay maybe one or two two to three
but to say 10 and throw it up against
the wall and here's the thing they're
they're a they're a publish they're a
base that is known for a high bar high
quality right well-renowned right that
doesn't sit well when factions doesn't
internally review well right they can't
afford based on their output or what
they they can't afford a 70 Metacritic
80 Metacritic they they have that St so
when you throw against the wall with
live service you're not going to hit it
out the park every single time I am
sorry there is a very complicated area
as Bungie would tell you one of the more
successful longlasting ones right and
they didn't get there overnight go ahead
ham you want to jump in real quick yeah
no no I just wanted to say like I feel
like the way they need to go about it
needs to be similar like like like if
they want to take advantage like a
fortnite did remember fortnite wasn't
that game correct before it was a
building
game like like look up the definition of
fortnite that's what that game was yeah
it was completely PVE like base defense
Defender yeah exactly so then when
you when when you have a game I feel
like if they're trying to take advantage
of something like what fortnite did they
need to have like a main game and have
like that as a side game let the side
game get popular stop trying to just
make all the everybody look at this live
service game good luck with that yeah I
mean I I I I thought that it would be
more like what is it firewalk or I
forgot which one it is that has all
those dedicated like X bunge Halo like
really dedicated PVP lineage um
developers I I always I always butcher
them brother yeah it's one of them it's
either walk or Sprite I always butcher
which one is which but one of them
really has you know PVP sensibilities I
thought okay they'll do that factions
would be an Anon or something and not go
to every single studio and say you got
to make one
that I think is full hearted like I I
think now you developers are passionate
about what they want to do when you
start trying to Pivot them to something
that that's not their wheelhouse that's
not going to B well I the last thing
I'll say to the question is that I don't
know if they going if they pivot in like
everyone's saying look you spent 3.6
billion to do this this was Jim's
marching orders out of the
door I don't see how you spent all this
money and now you may pull back from 10
to the seven to six I don't know I mean
I would be surprised if the pivot is
what people think I have not seen
conclusive evidence that they are truly
pivoting away from it in the extent that
people may think I think they're still
going to go that because at the end of
the day these $70 games these single
player experiences cost money and
they're looking at retention they're
looking at engagement they don't have no
microtransactions and they're looking at
these other games and they want a piece
of that pie they it's to the point now
let's be real they're drawing blood out
of a stone by remixing the single player
games they have so many times we're
getting Last of Us two remake remake
we're getting Horizon again remake that
just shows me you're still trying to
draw blood from trying to get as much as
you can he wants these things to when
when Jim Ryan says I want these things
to be bigger that means you're not
satisfied with what you have you're not
your single player Banger that is
critically acclaimed you're not
satisfied I got to give King one of the
greatest jokes that he ever did but it
had the most truth is when he literally
had every PlayStation 4 exclusive in his
hand and he's like Co Banger Spider-Man
God of War Banger horiz go to Shima
Banger he said they don't value this
they value this and the other hand was
Call of Duty that's the money maker
that's why they fought so hard tooth and
nail to block the deal they thought they
had a shot at it who knows what Jim
Ryan's fate was as a result of not
getting that deal blocked but that's
neither here nor there the point of the
point of the matter is they valued that
money and they didn't value the
exclusive the way the Fanboys and the
way Twitter will tell you that's not
what they value so to me whereas
Microsoft doesn't have the critical ACC
claim that they have I bet so will look
at the revenue that Microsoft is have
with that Minecraft that allows them to
facilitate the stuff that they want to
do that the hell blades and all stuff
Gamers got to realize the games that
they care about is really cult classic
Niche stuff to Executives it doesn't
bring the money that they thinking that
it does and the reality is the
Minecrafts the fortnites all agent all
these other little games that we as
Gamers roll out eyes we don't care about
it that's what's sustaining the stuff
that we actually want and that's I don't
think that they're going to Pivot the
way as hard I think they they're in it
because if they don't they they don't
evolve they have to be able to change
some otherwise to me their Market is not
sustainable the $70 game paying all that
money and you have no stickiness long
term with it that to me yeah that's not
sustainable the these G Sean Lon said it
it's not gonna you cannot they show Sean
the door though right and that's why I
think Jim was too hard he just may have
been paused too hard with the p but
that's where I'm at Jim is hard on his
stuff for I'm I'm be I'm gonna be honest
too I think as Gamers we convince
ourselves of this scenario where oh if
they you know if they hit with one or
two of these live service games that's
going to allow them to make you know the
teams to make other games it's like you
said Co they don't care yeah so it's
it's us convincing ourselves that the
the money that comes in from these live
service games will be used to fund more
creativity in the single player I don't
even know that's was I was told buy
another yacht what I was told that money
for the same game what I was told is the
single they're gonna retain people sorry
sorry what I was told is the single
player route works and they make buo of
money but in a corporate world it's it's
not what they want going forward they've
been shown another path right they've
been shown the path of the subscription
service they've been shown the path of
the game that the ever the ever living
game that that continues and continues
they've shown that path the problem is
that they all looked at it and started
salivating and nobody thought about what
the work that it takes to maintain that
absolutely brother you know what's funny
the only problem of Sony really getting
into that Mark and I know King's
probably going to laugh at this is they
don't got the bank account to buy the
ones that are actually mad mad
successful and with them to King's Point
the risk they take the misses could you
with them like you can't miss you you
don't have that Microsoft War chest to
to be able to just you know what I mean
like the can't miss part about it is the
saddest part about it because if you
think about these conversations we
having yo they the industry has killed
regular multiplayer facts regular
multipler is not worth it to anybody to
do it you're right wh which
theoretically factions part one was it
was a BL shout out to my man BG he used
to go so hard for it it's it's the
standard multiplayer but in this day and
age people want that cons consistent
engagement to pull you back but anyway
we've been going along with this um
let's get the super chats let's move on
okay we got all let's start with a nice
Super Chat here Halo Reach
around5 Super
Chat addict your body is Uncharted let's
get drunk man and get Naughty Dog
y yo PS still waiting for the
coordinates so I can give you the hammer
of dawn until until
dawn yo hey man this man wrote a a high
cool he did write a high cool man wrote
a
that I I can give you guys King's
coordinates you keep trying to pass
people obviously they don't want me as
bad as they want you sharing is car kid
no they know that you like the door open
PA that man want the coordinates to the
crib
wow drop that
hammer included all the names of his
favorite franchises in there too there
you go that's for you adct that's Halo
reach around
special gaming night with we we boy lock
member for 22 mons Lord bronze Sony is
turning into Sega Destiny 2 over
Warframe Marathon uh greater than matter
is a game nobody wanted no Sony what
happened to the 3.6 billion you gave to
Bunch KS K I got my
heav K
Shen yeah Shen
then we have good Rich games $5
super the game industry is unstable half
the studios I worked at like
PlayStation oh no no no we have a we
have a Dev here half the studios I
worked at are out of business all have
had layoffs this is why the average game
career is four to five years that's
crazy it's not even not even burnout you
know it's not even crunch burnout and
all that stuff it's just a lack of
stability yeah and the sad part is this
is one of the highest best gate years in
gaming revenues up all out and then we
have the most layoffs and this is why
people unions are coming I feel yeah
this is this is why people are scared to
jump in the industry for I hope so I
really I hope so said you did what we
needed see you yeah they not even
retained facts yes that's that's crazy
that's nuts we have Corey Tidwell $5
Super Chat King it's Sony's fault for
having them waste time policing Naughty
Dog they should have been focused on
life for yes my God
yes yes I ain't going to even lie to you
guys man that that King sayama a fraud
that's about to be one of these buttons
over here still cooking off of this you
are messy
bro Jes you better stop you better stop
before I have these dudes go back and
get that clip with you laying on your
stomach with door Oh I thought you going
to say the shirt off the shirt off is
out there in the streets n no that's his
business that's that's his only that's
that's fine because you going to post a
picture of me I'mma have you saying I'm
a fraud in your voice
it's no problem your nipples out is
fun Halo reach
around it's a family show not on this
show not this not that's the serious
money coming this way I don't see a
Super Chat that that quantifies that
don't care I don't care I don't I do not
care about the Super Chat bz nipples no
y that's a different tier yeah that's
his that's his only tear that over
there ad is a fool Miguel Ivars or evars
with the five yearo Super Chat smoking
mirrors people asking why didn't
leadership bite the bullet instead of
the employees as Jim Ryan goes Mia come
on now I mean the
leadership according to it like some
leadership did didn't get bonuses but
they did take reductions in salary yeah
they got
favors they get bonuses but they got
favors though yeah yeah Nintendo
Nintendo went hard did it remember oh no
yeah the bers are like n I'm cutting my
salary no what they did they cut their
salary they did a whole lot of stuff to
retain and they knew that the the
failure of the Wii U was on them 100%
100% then we have sin vetta Nintendo
like doing massive layoffs like that all
the time because we don't really know
Nintendo num it really be it really be
feel like Nintendo has a bad chord
they're like well that's on us we'll do
better next to and nine times out of 10
you won't know anyway you would never
know bro they they have a complete Black
Box around their security system you
won't know anything they could have laid
off everybody it could just be my model
right there right now running everything
on AI and you will never
know all right then we have uh send
Vendetta $10 Super Chat I used to love
playing Destiny put 1,200 hours into the
first game and put just about a 100
maybe me a thousand um hours into
Destiny 2
once Bungie introduced light as a micro
currency I fell off quickly and
permanently yeah yeah burnt the bridges
those are Wonder look at the how many
how many currencies how many
currencies too much stuen the amount of
currencies that's it's not good and we
have Alvin $5 Super Chat Lorraine drew
the on cover and salvatory did the OST
for myth oh my god wow they pre they
predated Halo probably in line for crazy
shares that's why they sent no
millionaires oh they they would have got
them shares them OG's oh yeah there was
a reason why some people would Target it
that sucks it's it's crazy that they
weren't there wasn't language protecting
them it kind of felt like it was done
deliberately make no mistake make no
mistake probably a good a good portion
of the people that got laid off again if
it was for higher salaries many of these
people are probably millionaires right
oh facts facts facts that's a good point
and and if I could corporate C no finish
corporate C no but but again they
probably M so it's not like they you
know they they're starving for the next
meal but the idea of the lack of respect
for that level of dedication to to that
to to to that one development studio is
crazy I mean the
same still rid of you for no like for no
reason really y disrespectful I will say
this is the I hate being corporate car
on this but this is the mindset is that
in their mind I'm going to just point
them out cuz this is my guy this is no
disrespect microsof aor you had a man
like you have sky on those guys but
they'll look at that salary and like you
said future millionaires they've been in
it you know how long they've they've
acquired that that um increases and
they're like they if we get rid of him
then we can save 10 to 15 more you know
what I mean that would equate that so
it's literally numbers y'all you know
what I'm saying and I'm not justifying
it no Legend should be treated that way
I'm just telling you what they're
thinking like we targeting these people
and we can get three to four people to
do more work for that same or we can get
AI work or or Outsource right that the
rise of the AI is going to kill a lot of
jobs right yeah and the outsources like
you said coas they don't have to pay any
sort of benefits Y no benefits and oh we
did mention um 343 um heard you may have
some positions that you may you know
some formal proes hey that might be
interested yeah and not to mention like
we just got through and you know there's
still a little bit of it going on with
like the the writer strike I think we're
on the verge of like an like a gaming
industry strike like it's possible
there's not too much more of these
massive layoffs especially from like
look bunie I still don't agree with them
laying off people but there is
absolutely zero reason for fortnite's
publisher to lay off anyone they're the
most profitable company in the world
right now when it comes to gaming and
it's just like you got they got so much
money that people just want a piece of
it this what they said though they said
what Happ whated happening was that they
started spending more than they were
making matter doesn't matter how much
you bring it in good point if you're
spending more than you're making good
point you're always going to readjust to
get fully into the black right good
point and that's yeah that's why I tell
Gamers don't get caught up with oh how
much revenue somebody said they make
look at how many consoles they s profit
is look at the profit is what you look
at don't someone is yelling from the
roof this is the revenue you don't know
what the expense the costs are y'all
listening to him are y'all listening
y'all sold how many but why is Microsoft
right next to you stupid
people cuz re revenue revenue is that is
that nice round number and profit is the
number that's left after you pay
everybody let me let me let me put it in
real terms there's gross and there's
net that gross is looking nice it's
gross because when you look at your net
after everything like oh oh I feel sick
to my stomach messy time messy it's
gross that y'all think that them
inflated numbers did anything messy see
you later app use my point use my point
to flip his agenda
continue we have Cory Tidwell $5 super
CH shaking my head bungee fired Michael
salvator to replace him with AI
generated Froot Loop samples
yo sound like elevator music damn they
got Tupac and tekashi messy messy then
we got Cory tow again5 Super Chat Forte
is at a day party laying on his stomach
on a beach towel cut him some
slack why you got to be on his stomach
though what's up with you guys in
stomach with just the beach to
wild that is that is a far cry from a
slop syn I would
say continue then we have Joe Dunmore $5
Super Chat Bungie still in love with
Microsoft only got with Sony for the
money and the open relationship are you
implying that may not be their final
destination it ain't got final
shape she she slided the fil DM so I'm
just joking you know what she want she
want to be wife back over with her love
she was just using him for the money
she's like Phil you know I was just
using him
for I was gonna get right
back he was paying the stuff you I want
to hang out with me was pay me no
attention Phil yo that hood rap Buie
voice is
[Laughter]
wild my baby daddy that's my baby daddy
my baby daddy song please please not
that song Moving
On Cory T well5 Super Chat son's a
billion dollar Company Living paycheck
the paycheck spending all the money on
third party side chicks and the main
chick too good for Cheesecake
Factory yo that's they pulled up to the
Cheesecake Factory with punching I ain't
going there what's wrong with you Jim
take me fil take me to Mr child I got
the child oh stop him y'all he going
keep going you taking me to cheese I
don't eat cheesecake J why she got to be
on high like that the door Jim got out
to walk around and lock the daughter now
you don't Jim now you don't this is the
Cheesecake Factory I want to got him Mr
child you know it's funny King always be
the one that's like man this is long
yeah cuz you oh he cooking he got he
getting all his he been waiting all week
for this yeah today you going get this
work I want 12200
likes 5:00 and we done two we did two
topics topic there was two there was two
bomb topics though but these these last
two topics we're going to fly through
yeah let's go we said that before we
said that before we that we have we had
Robert Kell $2 super laughing at
petition for King to talking Valley Girl
Bo they like bie hood rap boys they like
bie Hood right they what it off then we
got the lz22 $10 Super Chat I love
Destiny it was an outlet for me during
tough times my opinion Destiny has been
behind the eight ball since Joseph ston
left in 2013 when leadership forced the
reboot of the original story say behind
the eight ball since before they
launched no facts the story was like R
con it was so crazy it was it sorry
please no no no 100% it was I remember
if there's anything I remember about
Destiny 1 is that it was uh a shell of
what it was supposed to be at lunch Andy
to you started to see the corrections of
what was supposed to be in there they
was adding stuff it would it was a
survival this game even exists I have to
say that like it was such a patchwork
getting out the door yeah uh DC walks $5
Super Chat Bungie needed this wake up
call you can't leave Destiny the way it
is you're only Money Maker while trying
to work on another game that's what ad
is say what's what's funny is they
initially built a game with the
community yeah it's like oh you you take
resources away from your money maker for
the hope of there something that I might
not hit yeah it's and then the brain
drain at at Sony potentially then we
have mdy $10 Super Chat Bungie wonders
why revenue is down but they charge $15
for Ratchet and Clank emo right back
right one quarter of the price of an
expansion Sony didn't realize the real
final shape is a downwards bar graft at
a Bun's
financials oh my God messy then we have
Alvin with the $2 Super Chat
no matter what happens to Bungie warlock
for Life woo going down with the ship
music's playing all that final season
the game with WR then we have Angry
hippie $5 chat I feel you gotta see it I
got see it bro angry hippie $5 Super
Chat the Lords are Marty sitting in the
DeLorean on a set of train tracks
praying to God to hit 88 M hour trying
to go in that time
machine then we got Gerald Mack hold on
a second R back a little bit damn okay
Gerald Mac member for 36 months Lord
silver this this message goes out to all
the PlayStation fan if you kill Call of
Duty you kill PlayStation thank you
carry the hell on yeah that Call of Duty
talking be
funny we got visual walk through five
pound Super Chat The Last of Us F
factions would work as a division toight
game have PVE in the open world and have
PVP in the zones where if you die you
lose all of your items interesting if
they would put any PVE portion in it at
all being a separate
interesting then we have one pint Johnny
member for two months that boy at the
ball that boy at the ball that's all it
takes fight that's all he need I think I
think bungo that flashbacks that they
said they were going to support a PVP at
a PVE game
again much love Brothers thank you one
pint Johnny appreciate
you then we got Gamers play HUD xzero
member for 35 months Lord bronze good
afternoon Lord Xbox has finally found
the tune that they're marching to Sony
becomes has become ton deaf and are
trying to twostep to regga at24 is Xbox
wow then let's put the crest in the chat
for newest member uh Lord gold KJ Wars
885 shout out to you put some Crest in
the chat the crest in the chat put the
crest in the chat welcome your brother
then we got Cory Tidwell $2 Super Chat
y'all got Saucy Santana in the chat for
W Coco coko didn't like what went down
she text me and she was like I need to
come on the show too you know so all
right Coco everybody seen you all right
okay you done all right let's go Mama
shout out to COC Chanel
Johnson see look all right that's enough
that's enough my I like that she got a
full name like
that cooko chel Johnson y'all yeah
that's Bella R was Johnson too I respect
that we got the Liz 225 Super Chat
exactly they're Latino yeah they're
Spanish
Spanish Latina that's exactly $5 Super
Chat add it glad I could assist the show
today uh and clip that moment even
though I haven't played Destiny lately I
pre-ordered final shape hash I'm a
fraud frud that's it a sound bite of
King saying I'm a fraud would have been
perfect
there no it won't stop
it okay we have Lord roughness
Super Chat I think King is spot on when
he says no ps6 Sony are so in trouble
Jim was telling us and now Xbox has even
more games of the service games
literally printing money yo Scott said
Coco's face it I thought we was going to
miss the
[Laughter]
child yo I heard that in my head when he
wrote
that that's funny
stupid have Metroid for 25 months Lord
silver Destiny the final shape map is
you standing in a corner so how much uh
twoyear Subs sub of great content thank
you gentlemen Metroid Prime 4 yes Metro
Prime abute launch game for the new
Switch yes yes predicting it now I think
Metro Prime 4 is a pyramid scheme at
this point
yo there we have Lord roughness once
again five power Super Chat Spider-Man 2
was like a Cod weekend event those those
one and done games Sony have aren't
paying the bills this is why they have
to Pivot it was it was definitely
shorter than most of their
games you talking about the call uh Cod
no Spider-Man Spiderman no you didn't do
all the stuff that you supposed to
do like I can't sit there and rock with
you with that when you just didn't go
collect all the stuff you just mad
because I'm making a bite of you saying
I'm a Frog I I don't I don't care about
that why you you think I care about that
everybody know I'm a fraud anyway
like you you like you think you got like
this exposable moment that's like that's
like me coming out saying I'm black like
they know that
already oh my God this ain't nothing D
like you know even the dudes that don't
like me be like he's a fraud you know
too so what the hell and there there
there's King's Twitter in the chat Oh my
he y'all can go at me all you want they
the dudes is going to go they going to
be like we already know this y y'all
should hit add up with we know this give
us stuff we don't know since said King
is
black yo they messy continue got maningo
MC
thi5 Super Chat so Jim ain't taking
ain't taking Lance to Chows Lance got to
SLE for Cheesecake Factory Jim I said
Nance Phil well heard
Lance pretty good it is I hated the fact
that they was roasting us when we was in
Seattle remember when we go to Seattle
we was inside the Cheesecake Factory
they like yeah y'all at the Cheesecake
fact I'm like yo first of all with your
McDonald Happy Meal first of all don't
be coming at me all right this place is
actually dope and maybe my standards is
just low but maybe you trying to live
above your means and go to Mr
CHS we went to a nice we went had
Seafood that was delicious oh that spot
that we went with Jas
man I ain't
pay we had to go out of town for the
good food N N I got a blank Cog on that
that Jason place man we going to keep
that a buck we Ain
R it was delicious to me
but was it delicious why was it
delicious tell him why I should have got
the pork chop I should have
got ad ate all my rice bro all my fried
rice it was food that they
eat I I'm not going to lie I was a very
salty jealous individual when I saw that
pork chop that s God I'm looking at my
like God damn I don't even eat that y
just uncultured no no it's the fact
uncultured I don't eat that crap like
everything had pork in it what type of
restaurant is this that you going to get
pork flavored water
like on Hood
king so I'm Hood cuz I don't want por
you just don't want to try a new thing
no man who the hell want pork flavored
butter like everything got pork in it
like this is absolutely disgusting next
time we go to
IHOP but you see see he's trying to he's
trying to he's trying to fix it because
all right so this joint was one of those
traditional dumplin Asian places not
saying that is not dope the menu is at a
point it didn't have the food that I
would have eat exactly everything in the
menu had pork now for individual that
like pork is heaven it's not a por
listen doesn't have a full restrictions
like cog c can eat steak Cog can eat
pork C can eat chicken full restriction
I feel you that Paul I'll give you that
I don't eat meat so I'm not eating that
pork I'm not eating that chicken you
want that beef pause
n like sound like you against beef he
was trying to stop the beef in his
mou he don't like beef in his mouth
that's what it is he don't like the way
that
feel yo let's get out of this
yeah I've been waiting to use myemoji
I've been
waiting I've been sitting on that I know
I know ham is like this is what I was
waiting to get on the show
for yeah yeah Ham's here to give to give
King some
po we got see you know what ham ham I I
was your friend I was the only all that
you had here you going sit here you
going to say I wanted the
P it's in his name he giving you all the
ham hey he got ham oh oh it's a beefy
situation we got F and we got
ham yeah that's
hiso I would like I would like to thank
y'all for showing out High Lord podcast
um I want y'all to have a great time go
where yall going to go but the show is
over
somebody said you going to get that pork
slider man por pork
bun all right yo all right let's go
let's go let's go let's go let's get out
of here next next Bliss
Blom it's hitting the
streets finish these damn
Super
Street King
pork I we got the
meats I mean co co look at this our chat
I put something in the chat reent next
time we got we got JD gamer $10 Super
Chat the bottom line is that Microsoft
will soon own more IPS that were
classically associated with PlayStation
than what Sony owned Cod crash Spyro and
T Persona and T Persona God forgive them
if they get Final Fantasy 2 PlayStation
is down bad thank you always objective
JD game
apprciate did well $5 Super Chat final
shape is the perfect name it's like CG's
final shape up when he knew his hairline
was gone wow yo why you doing me like
bro I still got it
though what happened yeah get him get
him get him oh Dam bro what what
happened man we was
cool trying to say I'm Stephen A Smith
out
here
damn then we got JD gamer oh shout out
who is that block that man who is that
that was Cory Cory Cory tiw that was
foul n Cory you want something Cory you
want something [__] that man restrict
his rights seiz him him keep working
Cory keep
working give that man a be exactly seize
that man out here slandering
me and we got JD gamer put the CR chat
for JD gamer gifting five IOP membership
shout out to you and then uh let's put
the crest in the chat for me oh no
actually no not a new member member for
three months Lord bronze Mr Shadow shout
out to Mr Shadow appreciate you then we
got Mandingo MC thickens yet again $2
Super Chat wait who's going to make King
Phi all the
[Laughter]
meats then we got Halo reach around once
again2 Super Chat adct Got Me Harder
Than The Lion King on
SNES sh shout out to Halo Reach man at
least my purse to be thrown out money s
your person come in there at the one
super CH out my my dude's all on this
yeah he he he stay on hard stay on
hard y off the wheel what's going on you
know this was a pause cast the way this
is
going
went he said that he was as hard as the
L so he stay all hard we got to keep
going we got to get to the Super Chat
yeah yeah yeah Cory tripping astop par
King remember for six months Lord BR
Lord beefy Lord pepperoni Lord juicy and
Lord of walking to a bar Lord only fans
walking to a bar they all have to order
the same drink or no more Xbox what
drink do y'all pick whoa we should ask
juice for that um I I I would say the
LeBron the Leblon Leon never had it
though yeah but uh adct will defer us
when it come to drinks yeah drink like
that cuz he don't drink at all so it'll
be the because the leelon is not harsh
on your throat and I say adct you know
have the you know the problem with his
throat PA so
um this is the wrong time to bring that
up this is
the nor yeah he has has a bad gag reflex
that reflex is flexing that reflex is
flexing have some throat issues and some
meat issues there
we are so left today it's all it's all
of us fault yes this is what this is
what we get for being an inclusive and
accept podc we need we need to start
censoring people again that's what we
need to do all this First Amendment
right stuff in
here yo we lost we lost 100 people we
lost 100 people off of off of that 100
people got turned off they like oh they
bugged out yeah yeah we was at 11 and
yeah we went down at n yeah we lost 100
people from from adct saying that they
was like oh no no no he's being
disrespectful yeah they we we lost we
lost the group today you not you're not
talking about me having a throat issue I
was just bringing it up the fact that
the drinks though yo listen y'all stick
around don't leave like those 100 people
that got turned off don't leave cuz we
got something special at the end of the
show yeah so I guess we're going with
the blon
right so a Leblon it's not actually
called Leon no we're being hit we're
being hit with u it was a it was a
YouTube ad roll that's what was oh okay
okay so they didn't really leave us is
that you was yeah yeah they was
monetizing okay okay so the drink is
called a capar
capar capar no no no no no no don't
don't say that again add yeah don't say
that
word o you flipped it you fli it
something else realize coped what you
said
n let's not repeat that let's move on
yeah
next that was wow then we
got then we got Cory T $2 Super Chat
hold the
hairline wow wow wow listen man I
Advanced my joint don't even try
that there we got spart 6612 Super Chat
Leong from the Philippines Leong Yum Yum
Yum Leong Leong there we got JD gab 43
bus L bronze question for the panel what
classic IP that Microsoft now owns will
Microsoft bring back to the Triple A
Space sound like Starcraft based on the
B I don't know yeah star sounds like
Starcraft right in some way shape or
form um yeah I would I would love to see
tenu come back yes yes yes they got you
know they got Arcane there Arcane make a
for like a third person action game
stealth yeah I would love to see that
back to the 360 PS 3 days and pull out
Deadpool TR that's a good one yes
time all right then we got country big
94 to Super Chat loving all this meat on
a Sunday night
pause off the top rope with that one huh
country big all right let's see what you
do then we got Nintendo tacu $2 super CH
everybody's getting it on this now
what's not harsh on your throat
King
yeah King tell us tell
us you don't what he turned his camera
off he want to answer
that moving on D trying to help you out
there Lord Metroid $2 Super Chat so
addict the king have swallowing
problem oh oh man wow said y'all was
comparing notes no I have swallowing
problems King has meat problems oh his
his pills his pills for my problems
that can be fixed shout out to Blue for
the new sponsorship the new sponsorship
but you're mad at it you got a problem
we got to get with Cameron new sponsored
by
horsepower continue tell him ad it don't
go down easy oh man wow got leave me
alone man don't come for me unless I for
you boy crazy crazy and we are caught up
finally let's go Bliss con s you want to
talk about anything you saw I like are
you want me to set it up or for you I
mean Bliss con uh yeah so I
mean what did they talk about Diablo 4
yeah I can do it real
quick so yeah Bliss conon happened like
last week um and they you know obviously
the first time it's under the Microsoft
umbrella right so maybe there was some
expectations about what what could be
said or what not but again we already
know that a lot of the conversations is
about what the impact of this uh Union
is going to be is going to really happen
next year so uh first thing is that they
named the Diablo 4's first expansion it
will be called The Vessel of
hatred and I think that is that is a
that is a that's a Diablo name that's
for sure the vessel of hatred um they're
gonna have a neverbe seen class which is
interesting it's fun new classes to
Diablo is always because it always
throws everything off right so it's
going to be fun to see what that is and
and then they announced the next three
expansions for World of Warcraft they uh
they now have this new story beat called
the world the world Soul Saga that's
going to be uh that that basically a
story that's going to take up these
three expansions so we're looking at
probably easily the next five years of
wow that they that they talked about uh
speaking of games that still keep on
have had their ups and downs but just
keep on ticking there's wow um and
there's also you know the speculation
about it may be coming to a console at
some time so again which King has for
another another great thing that they've
done is that they separated core wow
from uh Whatchamacallit from Wow classic
right they allow allow people going back
to want to play the original wild heart
was before all the changes um so now
they added cataclysm I believe to that
um which is something that in the
original wild changed everything right
adding it yeah that was dope but it was
a big change so for lot of people wanted
to play the old school and have
cataclysm come in and not make those
changes they're kind of doing that for
you now as well so it's cool that
they're running those two in parallel um
and then we have a new character for
OverWatch 2 malga which is The Game's uh
the first Samoan hero looking very um
what is that movie with the rock as the
you're welcome it's an animated movie
what's it
called um Moana Moana yeah very looking
like the rocket Moana um um let's see
what else we have Hearthstone
expansions um what else Diablo's getting
a tabletop RPG and then Phil comes out
and he says hey what's up I'm here
what's going on y'all introduced by Mike
bar old the old G exactly the exactly
the old gang is all in tow and basically
Phil came out to say hey we're going to
do everything we can to empower them to
empower blizzard to make the type of
games that they want to make so that's
cool because again like like Cog said
that that creates a scenario where it's
possible for games like Starcraft and
and Warcraft proper to come back who
knows man even a scenario where maybe a
Starcraft ghost comes out of the comes
out of the cemetery like so it's very
cool and it's what we what we talked
about right what we hope is that that
that part of this Union is that it
allows some of these old franchises to
come back in some way shape or form so
that was cool to see it's cool to see
you know that you know Microsoft in tow
with them um nothing here that was
really exciting to me again I wouldn't
again I I don't expect any sort of big
world changing things yet to be
announced um but yeah but yeah wow was
still kicking and the fact that a long
time ago I used to be I used to say like
yo wow should they should give wow a
makeover right wow should be they should
make it super pretty and whatever and
make it more modern I kind of disagree
with that now I'm like you know what
keep it where it is everybody can join
in if they want it's not the prettiest
game in the world but it's it's clean
and it runs on everything um and that's
what they want to not you know keep
making money without having to invest
Oodles of it as well even though
obviously it's a lot of money to make
these expansions but it seems like they
see the benefit to doing that so it's
it's cool to see that W is still kicking
how many years later King like is it
more than more than a decade this is
it's crazy yeah so so that's it that's
it what did you guys think of it yeah
let's get uh ham Lord ham solo did you
get a chance to watch blon or catch any
the news man I tell you Mike uh Mikey
bar on stage was fighting for his life
keep tears from rolling down man that
that man for real um he he was about to
cry up there on stage um but shout out
to him he was very proud yes he was very
proud of him and his team and the folks
that came out to check out um BlizzCon I
believe he was saying that that was his
first actual BlizzCon at live and uh
same Bill Spencer as well Bill Spencer
said that was his first one that he's
ever been at as well funny huh yeah
pretty wild um but watching and seeing
what Phil Spencer was saying it was
pretty dope
because he said after Mike said it that
they're
doubling not really doubling down but
they're really getting after uh what
they believe is good good for them yes
what they want to build they're actually
able to go after it now in comparison to
I'm guessing before where they were kind
of more tightly funded they're actually
going to be able to have the funding to
produce more out of these games and
actually spread them out because that
one big point that they made that
they've been making for the last few
years is we want you guys to be able to
play our games anywhere however you want
to and whatnot so in my opinion I hear
that and I think okay wow on console is
that what you're telling me right now
are you telling me that we're going to
be seeing Starcraft coming back sooner
than we think Kingman sent me some
article right now that makes it
seem those those discussions may be
happening you know already U shout out
to an official affiliate C that is we
would have moved up now we we have a lot
of people in the field um we doing don't
we don't sit there and disparage against
people's credentials games radar.com
whom I've heard of whom I've heard of
could uh could water Warcraft finally
come to consoles the MMO's executive
producer says we talk about it all the
time it says it's well positioned to
finally bring the MMO to console so yeah
can then news with this uh this is one
day ago it's it's it's timely it's not
two years ago it's a reputable sight
hasn't been translated from another long
dead language yeah Reddit guy and them
said yes looks officient man looks
officient continue h I'm sorry no no no
no you're good um absolutely but yeah I
I'm just excited to see what they have
here um in in the next few years to come
um I was I kind of went into the event a
little over overzealous thinking that
you know here we might hear something
right now might maybe they're not
porting exactly you know the stuff that
we've been seeing but maybe they might
give us something new that didn't
exactly happen
but which it is what it is but it's just
really nice to see that this merger was
like authentic in the sense of happy
proud have a
direction I didn't see Bungie have a
have a press conference and come out
here and say man we're so proud of what
Sony did for us and we actually have our
uh our road map you
know somewhere where you can see and
verify what we're actually trying to
work that's is the difference when you
pay in cash and you pay on debit I mean
on credit there's a difference bro it's
a difference install installments
installments hit different man do your
homework on installments hitting
different man always
David always got to be a shot my my
final thing I was just getting ready to
say is it it was just cool to see that
what they wrote on you know social media
and Twitter and stuff like that
translated to me seeing him on stage
yeah and the way he felt I was like yo
they were for real when they said they
were happy yeah yeah absolutely well
said Lord addict uh how are you feeling
about this blizzard BlizzCon anything
catch your eye I think they
will definitely be a asset to Xbox I I
actually think they would be more of an
accet asset than like Bethesda because I
feel like they have some really solid
IPS now as far as like which one's going
to deliver more it's just a tossup I
think you know wow the only game I can
really compare like to uh to wow is like
Elder Scrolls for uh from Bethesda it's
just you know blizzard got like icon def
mining games like Hearthstone wow
OverWatch like it's like usually when
one of their big games comes out Diablo
like they got they got you you could run
the whole the whole console off one of
these games yeah games uh so you know I
think they're going to really use those
to their advantage you know I'm kind of
curious if you know what if they make
something new that's going to be
exclusive I would say it would be
because you know they had the opport
Unity PlayStation had the opportunity to
make sure that it happened but you know
they didn't sign that first deal and
they signed the one for Just Call of
Duty so to me it's just like why if if
you didn't have
intentions to make exclusives you would
have just let them sign the same dud
that was gonna sign the first time so
it's just like it seemed like Microsoft
was able to you know get away with Just
Call of Duty and I I feel like you know
PlayStation's going to regret that in
the future because you know I think it's
going to be one of those things where
it's like you know Diablo 4 that's on
Playstation but where's Diablo 5 five
six years down the road where's this new
IP that they're supposedly making you
know if they make a a Starcraft where's
that going probably PC first or maybe
Xbox and PC at the same time like you
know people people console sells after
while comes out the console that will be
something to look at add instead of
people trying to build all these crazy
PCS
yeah during the trial remember with um
judge Corley Indiana Jones yeah she she
said what what I said she's like well
why is why is you guys worried about
Call of Duty won't you know Sony be okay
with that and then she was aluda like
Diablo and all the other blizzard
franchise she doesn't see any problem if
there was to be if Microsoft decided to
be exclusive because she was trying to
understand the Sony argument why can't
you just she is like why do we need to
save Kong like I don't know Kong is a
monster Kong is a king right he been
fighting why do we need to keep inter
all right that's your funniest one I a
go for when you do the same coog I can't
stop my laugh that joint is H cuz I
remember the movie he was laid
out on the boat he like they pulled him
up for the oh Goda took him deep under
the water Godzilla was drowning I think
I think you're gonna eventually see you
know people talk about Starfield it's
like these aren't the games that's going
to annoy and piss people off it's going
to be Elder Scroll 6 Diablo
5 uh you know the next you know star
Starcraft is a huge
franchise and if that's coming to
consoles but not one console you know
it's especially Elder SC six people
thought Starfield was annoying facts
wait till Elder Scroll 6 comes out
Starfield did all that that was a new IP
this is an established Legend I like
yeah people gonna see and imagine if you
know blizzard being free because you
know it's kind of ironic that they're
not seeing them anymore as Activision
Blizzard King B they seeing them as
blizzard Activision and King because
they were one company but now the whole
company's with Xbox so I can see that
company being split up into its three
counterparts and you know blizzard being
able to run on its own and I have a
whole lot of people to uh answer to and
you know especially giving creative
freedom to these uh Studios I I I think
they're going to do some good things I
do you know I don't really care to for
too much of their products besides like
OverWatch and you know that's up and
down for me but I I feel like blizzard
is going to be a huge tool that that
Xbox uses to compete no doubt no doubt
King thoughts on blizz con oh my my my
my thing is Mikey bar this is your first
one right you've been there for a while
but Phil was like everybody need to show
up
this is my first your first two let's
go uh I I put on your best uh you know
BlizzCon clo let's go I think this is
the first BlizzCon since the pandemic
started though and I don't think there
was one last year n no but but the this
just jokes though but um the best part
about this is the road map looking
forward as you know ham was saying and
the fact of the matter is now that
Microsoft owns the situation Financial
backing is cool
um these developers that get a chance to
start expressing themselves with these
games we can finally see weld of
Warcraft on Console wow that be huge L
uh because you know there's no reason
for it not to be there you know you have
the resources now to uh get an
exploratory team into getting the
control schemes down pack and getting
that stuff over there and even if the
control scheme is you bring out a mouse
and keyboard uh type of peripheral for
your Xbox that is dedicated to to that
game to get all out of that game that is
quite possible for you to do so you know
um it opens up a larger demographic and
it Al also opens up uh a bigger more
robust uh catalog because those people
that play Age of Empires if it's not you
know crafted to a controller and you can
get some hybrid of a controller SL
keboard something made up for these PC
titles that needs that extra input think
about what I'm saying to you guys you
can Corner the market on Console gaming
and on on for the PC games that don't
hit that target audience or is
restrictive when it comes to controls
and you can broaden the Bas you you made
a intuitive controller for the handy
capable people you can make an intuitive
controller for the PC merger that you
have done now because remember blizzard
is really PC Centric yeah so what you
want to do is you want to show that
you're embracing their roots and also
telling the console people we're not
going to leave you behind and you can
merge the Two Worlds with that
controller my concept I want PC when
that happens cut that yeah you know
greeny you know what's up um but the
fact of the matter is these games have a
lineage and it brings that robust
lineage over to Microsoft they have they
they're part of BlizzCon now right so
now these cons that go on in the year is
Microsoft has with this
purchase has goned a group of rabbit fan
based guys when it comes for BlizzCon
then you have the Candy Crush people
then you have uh I saw a war zone app I
see these apps that that people were
sending me that I didn't know that was
associated with Activision Blizzard but
these apps are number one to number 20
in the
world as far as paid Revenue coming back
it ain't really about the Call of Duty
stuff as far as console and PC goes it's
really about the mobile hit and the rein
curring Revenue like Sovereign was
saying that it doesn't take that much to
put into Candy Crush as much as a triaa
game but you're getting triple to
quadruple return on investment over said
quad uh AAA game so it's this level of
passive income that will continue to
roll in that will fund creativity going
forward and I saw the the pride of the
people at BlizzCon and the the thoughts
of the future is bright so I I I was
excited I will probably go to a con one
of those BlizzCon or something now that
I haven't ever been to yeah um I'll jump
in and um yeah look it was something
that was really cool to see you know
them actually like you know ham was
saying like
you know it's one thing to talk about it
and yo we're excited and whatever it's
another thing to have that physical
presence and to be there and obviously
the symbolism of of Phil being there on
stage and saying this is his first one I
got a shout out to the dominant though
did y'all see that jacket that jacket
was hard that jacket was God how would
he put you on notice man the boy had the
black jacket was
tough he looked over at Todd he was like
yo you known for the jack hold on man I
don't know f look like that ABK somebody
hit you the bonus and something went
down cuz your drip was crazy bro I'm
just just put it out ja was Fire pocket
pocket watch pocket I was pocket
watching I even going to hold you I was
definitely I was definitely watching in
the situation but um no look it it was
dope um you know for me obviously the
history between Mike as an Xbox former
you know life so to speak him presenting
Phil saying we used to play games
together that kind of stuff which is
real like Mikey bar is a gamer Phil
Spencer a huge gamer they like this is
for Real there nothing made up about
what they were talking about so you got
that and then later obviously to see Rod
come out so it's like the old gang back
together you know what I'm saying which
is really dope so that that waset boys
no we not doing
that I already been through
that we are not doing everybody we're
going to simultaneously
dancebody everybody back together you
trying to make that's very beta boys
energy
all right so so they did Mano they got
Mano
back very bet boys energy we going to
move on
but it was dope to see and the fact that
like I said um yeah blizzard is
important Point adct made a good point
like this is the PC's Community baby and
and to see them have Xbox branding in
association with that is huge to know
that they are going to be supported to
have that separation from Activision
Blizzard like they're going to get
hopefully the support that they need um
Diablo is what I care about obviously
the expansion what is it um The Vessel
what was it season of The Vessel what
was it called vessel of hatred
continuing the story the L story is fire
that people don't realize it's not just
Mo that story that campaign is dope so
to continue that and anybody that ended
know Maisto in the background as a
silver Ser fan who loves this you know
misto story line I love to hear his
story in games so that's going to be
dope um and then think about this King
most likely next year by that time that
thing should be in game pass by the time
that expansion comes out that is huge
that influx of Diablo Game Pass you know
quote I can't wait till they put all the
Diablo and game oh crazy diabl is going
to be crazy and then obviously the DLCs
on those is crazy crazy insane then
obviously OverWatch got it love new
character was hoping for a little
narrative yeah the new character is dope
yeah little narrative content to see
that you know they're supporting it
looks like the community he's happy I
try again I'm not a PC Gamer you see
they got a dating Sim up in there now
yes I PE that homie with the arrow I
said oh man they going all the way with
it but I wanted to get a feel from the
wild Community shout out to um L py
shout out to um Ty because I wanted to
get an idea of how people were feeling
with the announce so the vibe I get is
that t got Travis place no no no t
r okay top really plays OverWatch so
excuse me but okay py is where I wanted
to get to because obv see streams out
every day like this is what he does so
you go to the hardcore like how we
feeling so his thing was the biggest
thing was the stuff that Phil and Mikey
B was said people feel reinvigorated the
commitment to it and obviously they got
a lot of content the negative he said
was just that they're almost Assassin's
Creed where just so much content it's
like you know Assassin Creed going have
like four or five games coming so that
yeah that that's the only concern cuz
it's like yo you you never could catch
up kind of thing but overall people
people were happy so look it was dope to
see you know blizz con you know out
there in full effect to see a live show
and uh yeah this is a great start man
I'm super excited I think it's going to
be this is one the part of deals that we
don't talk about a lot and I think it
should do well even the PC game pass
part where they getting a lot of think I
think it's blizzard hopefully gets their
luster back yes blizzard was Untouchable
for a long time and then
Activision it just it just destroyed
that kind of so it's good to see that
they're excited about the opportunity to
get back to where they were absolutely
do we want to combine the last topic and
just just it yeah let's go pop through
all right so um this one obviously
Modern Warfare 3 lot out there in these
streets and uh reviews are out there and
just talk about ads and wherever y'all
want to go with this is where y'all want
to go with it so we just got to talk
about it so H like I don't know if you
got a chance to see I see there was a
couple of reviews actually just one
review you know saying that um people
may have had some issue with or you know
about the shortness of the campaign I
believe IGN um had their single player
campaign review again just a single
player they did rate it a four this was
has created uh some controversy online
in reference to the score in comparison
to other games then obviously um we have
the ads thing so looks like as soon as
you boot up your Xbox I wouldn't notice
cuz my Xbox is on instant on or whatever
is so I've never seen one ad for Xbox
but apparently this has been going on
since like Starfield and all the major
releases there has been when you boot up
your Xbox you know the option to to pick
it up or whatever and it caused a little
controversy with the with the community
you know as far as you know is this too
intrusive is this too much where do you
stand on both issues Lord ham
solo oh dang I mean hopefully they don't
have Paramount because whenever anytime
you hit pause on that there's an ad are
you apply ad happen every day B are you
applying
half time you turn on Steam there's an
ad half time you turn on Epic there's an
ad why are we acting like this is new I
mean ads have been in consoles for a hot
minute now and and and and and now this
one shows up and people forgot where the
B button is they just don't know where
it is they just lost they just don't
know where that b button is I think it's
silly and then on top of that we have
this uh four out of 10 rating from IGN
which if you want to give a game a four
out of 10 do whatever you want to do but
my problem is when there's a level of
consistency that's
missing so people are like oh man this
game is too short where have you
been I I don't remember hearing too much
about that with uh Black Ops cold war
that game was like four and a half
hours so I'm just like where where's
there's too many guns what does that
even mean in a gun
game so like I I mean just hearing part
of that review I'm just like H this is
kind of giving me a headache like it
just like like any of these reviews
anymore feels like more more of a
clickbait than actual information to get
me interested or disinterested into a
game okay so that's kind of the way I
looked at that whole thing I think this
game you know
it's it's receiving the Microsoft tax oh
are you ining because they are owned Now
by by a new new new company that that
the level of review would would change
is that's what's going on H what we
doing I'm saying these fools are acting
like they got pepper
sprayed because they can't they they
having a hard time seeing what's been
right in front of them for the
longest
time this game is has been doing the
same type of assets for a minute now
this game's been H like I I just don't
understand where the four really and and
I get it it's only for the campaign part
right and and and that I feel like is
the excuse that they're trying to lean
on the hardest because they know at the
end of the day this game is GNA sell
like crazy it's a play on Nostalgia when
you look at the whole game especially
with the whole multiplayer uh feature
added to it so I'm excited for it there
ain't I'm I'm having a hard time
believing you really somehow rated this
game worse in Quantum error you're gonna
say that's the wor tell the truth shame
the devil
bro you're gonna say that this is the
worst PlayStation game or PlayStation 5
game to come out and then you're GNA say
Call of Duty is somehow worse some Call
of Duty is somehow around the the same
area as a gollem like I'm not buying it
I'm not buying that nonsense that they
spewing do I'm done no hey you you stood
on it you I was I was instigating I just
want to see where you was going to go I
didn't know we up but I'm glad you you
said your peace you know no doubt Lord
addict Call of Duty in the news uh the
review like I said uh I gives it a four
right now and then again just single
player c campaign and then obviously you
know the Xbox Community some are very
upset about the ad being plastered when
you boot up your Xbox your thoughts
please first thing I'll do is I'll talk
about the ad thing uh because I'm about
the more people from my GM probably go
and follow me after this one but um uh
so when it comes to the ad thing it
don't bother me but I understand people
get very
like very jumpy when it comes to stuff
like this because they feel I don't feel
like the as the issue I feel like the
fear can go furthers the issue and as of
now I'd have no issue but if they
started playing trailers that I had to
watch and it's like 30 seconds you could
skip then then I'd be on Twitter with
you guys but I agree Ju Just Just a
posting it' be different if they trying
to show me like a pair of Jordans no
they're trying to show you stuff you buy
in that actual store F uh you know once
again people point it out where was this
energy towards Starfield and Forza be in
there yes same same on no one seem to
have an issue it seemed like this is
more of a it's not the game I want to
play so I'm going to complain and that
that's fine and it's like I said I'm not
going to see here and I'm not going to
say you have no reason to be nervous I'm
just saying as of right now I don't
think we should jump out windows right
all right now this IGN
thing I actually investigated this
pretty hardcore and
um it's bad like you know I'm not gonna
I was going to scream screen share but
I'm not going to do that so you guys can
can follow along MH person who reviewed
is a person named Simon cardi okay all
right so you look at you look at the
hold up you look at the
reviews they reviewed Call of Duty
Modern Warfare 3 single player campaign
review they reviewed Marvel Spider-Man 2
review they reviewed secret Invasion
Episode 3 review
they reviewed uh Horizon forbidden West
Burning Shores review okay people
catching are you okay let's keep going
they reviewed Last of Us season one
final review Last of Us
season episode eight Last of Us episode
seven HBO Last of Us episode 6 so you're
implying that there there is I'm hearing
some na going on in the background
what's going Mountain
review HBO Last of Us episode 5 episode
4 episode three are you implying this
person has an affinity for son many
products then they well they review some
Andrew stuff that's cool God of War
Ragnarok they're the person that
reviewed God of War Ragnarok then more
Andrew thing OverWatch 2 so they did
review OverWatch 2 but the majority of
the stuff this individual is reviewing
is TV shows oh okay so you going that
okay okay my b no it's it's definitely
the they're reviewing every every
PlayStation game essentially just about
okay now they did review Call of Duty
Vanguard campaign they did review that
and I don't remember what they gave it
uh they gave it
a I think it's like a seven so they gave
it a seven that's before it was bought
all right so
now all I'm saying is Loki all the Loki
games they did review a couple games in
2021 this person essentially reviews TV
and PlayStation
games now
let's it gets worse gets worse now maybe
you're thinking maybe this is a a common
practice for IGN maybe all of them
constantly dipping in and out of
multiple genres let's go to Lena Harford
harder I don't know what her name is
whatever this person's name is let's
let's check out theirs they reviewed
City skylines Total War Dune boers Gate
3 voter Gate 3 review in process they
reviewed aliens dark Covenant okay maybe
that's enough for you guys it's one
let's check out Jake Jared green another
reviewer
person ER reviewed hellblade re uh
Hellboy reviewed Assassin's Creed Mirage
wrestle Quest Double Dragon gayen awe
fight forever explain to me King how all
these people have been doing nothing but
reviewing games but the only person that
is reviewing Call of Duty at this time
is only reviewing PlayStation games and
TV shows I guess no one was available no
one's available to review a Call of Duty
game don't they have a person that plays
Call of Duty there that has a of Duty on
theire siid the effect so then I started
you let's let's go to people I know
let's go to people that you know Ryan
mcaffrey he didn't review Starfield a
couple months because I was told he
doesn't review G hey King tell me why he
reviewed Mario uh wonders
H H someone explain that to me different
when you do your homework right he he
reviewed Somerville new uh new Tails
from the Borderland
what it's just like look Ryan McCaffrey
he clearly doesn't review a lot because
he's more of the the management but
clearly if he wants to review a game he
can grab that
uhhuh it says like look you know I got
to be honest with you to be 100 with you
the majority of the uh the industry when
it comes to the media uh they're all
fraudulent to me I don't respect the
majority of them oh you said they did I
I I think they just do it for a job now
obviously that's not the whole that's
not the whole canvas now some of you in
the canvas want to get upset because I I
I labeled all of them go ahead mute me
on Twitter block me on Twitter I don't
care Oh No but all I'm saying is uh
there are people I do respect you do
Travis taiy tell them I respect his his
did he review it no he didn't but that's
not the point I'm talking about the
people I do respect that R stuff I
respect
there are people that review stuff in
this industry huh do you respect
Ryan ah there are people in this
industry that I do respect that I do
feel go into this in a genuine the
reason I don't know about Ry is because
I don't know why he didn't review
starford at this point if he reviewed
Mario that's just until I hear that
picking and
choosing schedule what if he wasn't
available so you mean to tell me he he
could he was available to review Mario
but not the game he has been been
covering for like five years he Brian's
been saying it for the longest time he
doesn't play like he doesn't have the
bandwidth to play games like that Mario
right Mario's not a long game he still
played it that's what reviewing process
is for they do it all the time but it's
not a long game
oh we doing we process like if you go to
Lords gaming.net we do reviews in
process so you know you know the person
that reviewed like the person that
reviewed Starfield is a is a bedda head
right I mean I mean I could pull up his
jacket I looked at it
too we got time today it's just like
look at the end of the day get I I'm not
saying that everyone that works at these
media Outlets are frauds but I one other
thing I will say is they're the first
people that slided my DM say adct you're
being too much on on Twitter you need to
comment down but they come my DM pause
they're the first ones that pop out on
Twitter when nothing with something that
they feel entitled to and they out there
Port begging pretty much why did I get
this code so it's okay you call that
what you call that I never heard
that you port
begging don't be out here Port begging
it's just like look I understand if this
was a small game I'd be like I'd be
right there with you guys i' be like you
know what this is a little interesting
it's a little but tell me how the person
that reviewed Call of Duty Modern
Warfare only reviews god of war and TV
shows oh tell them tell them it just
makes no sense to me it's like no was
avilable set
up yo and you know part people say well
what's your problem with the media the
media don't respect me so I don't
respect them oh oh uh oh because every
time I turn around they saying some
slick [__] and I'm gonna cuss I don't
care they saying some sck stuff about
content creat podcasters and streamers
every time I turn around they got some
slick stuff to say uhhuh so you know
what I'm say how I see it
why is this person reviewing a game when
they only think they reviews TV shows
and in PlayStation exclusive games
including the VR for Horizon because
they trying to save Kong to me they're
trying to save Kong son they're trying
to save Kong someone explain that to me
and then and then I I'll step off my my
DMs are open as long as I as long as I
push the accept button come on through
my dude it's only space and opportunity
but guess what king they have no answers
they don't have a word
yeah y got it out I'm
done looking like Mark Jackson for real
I do anything yet he just passed the
rock like oh it's a your thoughts
uh obviously a very spicy topic of with
call of D Call of Duty score and now
obviously the ads popping up on
Xboxes all of y'all jumping to defend
this game or even talk about this game
that never haven't played this game in
like a decade yeah a bunch of fra and
shut up just shut up I
feel alert the bance of the is here
including in including members of this
podcast all of a sudden
now hold up s i I will take that
feedback but my my predictions wasn't
about the review of the game was about
why that individual is reviewing it
that's that's all I will say this I will
say this
if they put a person on it who play who
plays Call of Duty all the time and it
gives it a super high score the reverse
is the
sameas the same thing it's the same
thing the only thing the only thing I
will say about that four score is this
and this is my personal feeling on
scoring especially with a 10-point
system okay five is average when you're
talking anything below five that means
to me the game doesn't function properly
damn that's my brother right there that
means to
broken get him so far as what I I I I
did not fully sit down and read that
review but everything that I've been
able to to glean from that review and
heard King adct in the chat I'm done
with you King so I I have not heard that
the game is fundamentally broken and
unplayable like Spider-Man
sometimes so this so that's to me the
four I understand Spider-Man was short
it was broken and um but I'm not making
it I'm not forget about Spider-Man I'm
not making about for the thing though is
I don't want to go too much on that
because ACG said the game before that
day one patch run ran and I trust AC but
only ACG get to say that everybody else
can't well I'm only saying ACG say okay
so we gonna exclude ACG we talk about
the rest it's just to me look you know
this this idea it first you know
PlayStation fans who are who all of a
sudden jumping on his bandwagon saying
see what happens when Microsoft takes
over Microsoft had nothing to do with
this game so that's one I I I want to
interrupt you for a second that is so
true because the fair Bo you can't have
it both ways you can't say when when
there's a B I think it was when outter
worlds came on something oh microsof had
nothing to do with that being the eight
and N it's not your game and then when
it's something Bing they they also
didn't quot have nothing to do with it
oh no that's all them this is the
effect Microsoft come
down fraud on that facts that's fraud
and the same way as a fraud when when
the Xbox fans are are jumping to the
defense of this game that they don't
just to clarify real quick nobody Bo up
the only game this individual that has
reviewed Call of Duty has reviewed all
year we're almost at the end of 2023 is
Spider-Man everything else has been
TV so that makes him unqualified for the
four again I listen I to me unqualified
yeah the four field feel egregious and
because it feels egregious simp the game
ain't broken like that like four means
broken game it means bugs and stuff
right you to me the game could be even
comparing it to past Call of Duties you
be like yo this is not as good as this
is not as good as this can you play the
game yeah are there bugs that that crash
the game every five minutes to me that
anything below five that's where that
territory goes that's what I'm with you
s yeah yeah and then to me so you know
what kind of what can be behind that I
have no idea I just think it's called
agenda but everybody seems to have an
agenda around this game the word you're
looking for is a
gender that was good if your memory is
failing you right now I got so now what
I laugh ising King said yo I gotta play
this game because they coming at me I'm
like yo you know you don't want to play
this game but you go to play this game
now so first of all got Xbox so first of
all you ain't going to do that because
last year I said let's get Call of Duty
I sat there and I played I was like yo
let's get to the Y facts and none of us
played it yo I said said yo let's get to
this community
stuff to be fair I told you don't buy me
Call of Duty I'm not playing that's yeah
he he said that he said that but I
didn't so at the end of the day you
ain't GNA come for me like that you
ain't going to do that but I'm I'm going
let you continue to smoke keep smoking
but but this is the thing so now he
can't just smoke he needs to he needs to
go
in the hell with you you ain't going to
do that to
me so anyway and then the thing is he's
got buy this game that is probably bad
right probably not a four out of 10 but
it's probably bad it's not bad though
and I know it's not bad but it's got to
be some realm of bad right these dudes
is
Liars so that that's my my main thing
was the to me and this is maybe a
personal thing maybe other people see it
this way but 10o scale five is average
below that you're talking about broken
nobody said anything about broken they
just said they don't like the direction
the sort of more openness of it um that
it's boring cool that doesn't scream
five to me um for to me so that that's
the only thing other than that you know
rate the game whatever the hell you want
I don't care yeah King yeah your
thoughts on Modern Warfare 3's reviews
and oh adct I mean ad s you need tell me
how you felt about the um ad oh the yeah
that once again people just arguing
about nothing I I too my Xbox is always
on sleep so it just comes right on and I
don't see any of that stuff or whatever
yeah um I believe the B button allows
you to back out of that you believe you
heard yeah I heard I heard that you know
you can back out of that in two seconds
okay then your life continuous as it
those are just those are just people
that's trying to save on uh light yo
people so people really want to try to
act like they were stuck at the screen
they couldn't leave the screen it's like
I said I do get the concern for where
they're taking this but it's just not
there yet like they're acting like it's
a rude popup like they like they show uh
pepperonis or something you know you
know what they're acting like King you
were playing Call of Duty or another
game and like when you went to the
loading screen that popped up it popped
up and was like buy Call of Duty
like and then you saw the headline gross
like yo who wrote this like you you
dudes over there I'mma get at you gonna
get this work it just it goes to show
you that everybody everybody still needs
clicks no matter if you're on if you're
on the biggest website Gaming website on
the planet you still need clicks that's
right put somebody on it that just
reviews movies F ahead anyway you good
you good son yeah I'm good I'm good Lord
King who's been patient your thoughts on
the review of V 13
and right now I feel like Jord you know
when he standing there he put the ball
in his hand yeah put it over your head
the triple threat
move you know what move he about to do
jab step pull back ah ah you about to
get this work you jerks did it again and
I knew you was going to do it we set you
up you fell into the Trap yo adct hit
that trap card cuz they fell into our
trap we knew y was GNA pass it over to
the to the individual that want sit
there and do movies and shows that's
some R&R stuff and then all the stuff
that you like is PlayStation stuff that
you review oh I love how God of War
is Horizon forbid westes this
is I I know you so y'all Think You're
Gonna Save Kong right y y'all thought
this was going to be it and Y was going
to sink it right yeah let's give it a
four but you gave qu era five a broken
crappy mess of a game but it was all
your below PlayStation y like a son
that's a game that we can live
with the campaign is short it is it
they've been telling y'all they slowing
it down on
campaign analytics show that half y'all
don't play the campaign y yall want to
play the multiplayer but y'all don't
want to y'all don't want to do it as a
whole
y' want to do the multiplayer and The
Campaign together because it will raise
the
score you see I know y gender baby
you're cute with
it let's separate them let's separate
them let's get the weakest one and let's
put it over here and isolate it and
let's give it a four because we're GNA
get more clicks and we going to try to
syn this ship and tell people don't buy
it it's a whack it's whack it's
whack your review process is whack your
review process is trash you dudes over
there reviewing you're destroying
yourself you're destroying your
credibility trying to save Kong like y'
dudes right there you already show what
what what alignment you're
with it's going to work till it don't
work no
more and it's not working now that you
got addict doing research on who
reviewed the game and then the internet
Never Lie the internet got you on blast
like all you did was TV show TV show
PlayStation game TV show TV show play
game PlayStation game TV show TV show
movie it's just you know I don't know
how things work over there here I don't
you do yes you do it works on an agenda
I don't no the thing is is like I don't
know how things work when it comes like
assigning you know games and stuff but
like to me it's just like was there no
one available like and explain to me
because to me it's like if you're not
reviewing games a lot like why' they get
Spiderman like they've reviewed one game
besides
Modern Warfare this entire year and it
was Spider-Man so son game that yeah
that's that's insane to me they even
reviewed the VR for Horizon a Sony
game and you know it is what it is but
uh I I I I want to go home so I'm yeah
but see I I let you rock when you was
doing all your banana stuff let me rock
I'm referring I am not adding to you
continue allow me to rock son Rock Away
Rock away all right so you gave it a
four that's not acceptable here all
right uh we already know it is a
blockbuster was the graphics terrible
did it glitch out on you was it
progression problem according to the
review um um it's a pale limitation of
the past made up of underbaked story
moments but ultimately he says yes the
game play is still great and the
graphics and sound design are top tier
but I couldn't help but feel I was
playing a shinier less subtle version of
something I've played too many times
before right right yeah so that that
warrants a four that warrants a four all
right so we already know the credibility
is in the trash we already know that so
we we let's let's let's move past that
let's go over to this egregious popup
that's popping up on people's screen
yeah all you do is trying to save on
your gas and electric bill stop turning
your consoles off oh and real quick King
I I did look it up Dan the dude that
reviewed Starfield the only other game
he played this year uh besides Starfield
was Jedi Survivor it's the only other
game he reviewed besides Starfield Al so
what he was doing for the whole year but
go back go back he's the he's the
reviews editor editor and I feel you on
that so he from he needed Starfield is
isend back if you go back he he he
reviewed a lot of betesda games okay so
he reviewed vampire survivors Mario uh
Destroy All
Humans West review vampire
he reviewed the Mass Effect legendary
edition I mean we back two years and
I've only named like five games yeah but
he's the reviews Ed everybody got to
submit their review to him he ain't
gonna have much bandwidth and time to
make so don't then don't take STAR what
y'all
ridiculous care too much about this only
want bias when it's on your
side when it go way is good listen I
told you I'm a fraud like what part of
that don't you get and you going to sit
here you going to keep saying if it
don't work in my favor I don't like it
yo all right look at look at look at
what Simon cardi also reviewed disco
leum
OverWatch Xbox property
OverWatch it doesn't it wasn't it wasn't
an Xbox property then it doesn't matter
it's Xbox property now OverWatch but
okay so what did he rate it then control
matter of Duty Black Ops Cold War but
what that's back then Cold War back then
so so K according to based on your arent
soon as ABK went down there was the
internal joint like yo you already yo
you already know save Kong by any means
necessary save C like whatever's going
down way too much about you you have the
quote that I tell people is the greatest
quote which is no one's going to tell me
how my food tastes and you worrying
about this dude telling you how
you listen listen I'm not this is a
talking
part it's
it's it's not about telling how a food
tastes it's about saying something don't
smell right no y'all pointing out what
y'all feel is inconsistent f i don't
[__] with the super much I I I giving
you information you do what you will no
no fair see I'm going play I'mma play
the game this week I'mma play the game
this week and I'm G to give a real
concise review like like it got to the
point now why you got to get involved
wait can I can I guarantee something
right now go ahead it won't be a four
for you it won't be a four for we can
pretty much guarantee that yo you know
why it won't be a four for me I don't
give games
fours all right unless it's broken okay
all right and you know that's a
factless we on the same no we on the
same page I think I think we all agree
that again first of all we got to be
real though like s said none of us
played this game so we all frauded none
of us have booted up no shoot the gun
don't know anything about it we're going
off conjecture and what we assume based
on what the reviewer said so if the
revie give you a review this week I I'm
I'm not really going at it from like the
reviewing the game itself I'm going for
can we trust the person reviewing
it like you you look at just just the
fact that they ain't reviewed no games
year they reviewed all only almost
entirely I would say this like Simon I I
don't listen to these shows anymore but
Simon Carter used to be like the host of
of the IGN UK podcast like General like
IGN UK podcast uh so again I don't I
don't know what this guy plate looks
like the thing so this is the thing that
kills me everyone saying these guys are
frauds they do this all the time why are
we right watching their show again why
we keep going back to the seat of the
crown and then get mad we of of of
behavior that you've already predicted
but but there there's a difference
between I'm sorry I'm a very big
standpoint on on pointing out the issues
maybe it doesn't get fixed but not
talking about is definit no no I'm not
saying not talk about I just feel y'all
really they doing they they they more
egregious with it right now like right
now since it since it's been done they
they've been dropping depth charges all
over the place it's just like
like said it's because they have a big
influence yep it's so why don't we make
the people that we care about the big
influence why don't we support the
people that we care about why don't we
go Lord the G got that Dam it why why
are we pumping up the other side let's
go we got a home team home that isn't
doing stuff that's that's making me
scratch my head so let's go to the
people that's doing the stuff that we
the thing is is I can do both I can
throw light on this issue but you don't
like that show you don't like that TV
you don't like that anime you like this
anime over here I want to get you to
this
anime It's the final
episode final sh over there
episode me I think what bothers me that
what what you're saying adct and what
king is definitely directly saying
you're kind of you're talking around a
little bit add King isn't is the fact
that this is this is an Xbox tax
thing it's because it's now under Xbox
and I don't I truly don't know these
people are bombing what are you doing
bro what are you doing I'm saying that
100% it is an Xbox I truly don't things
are being bombed for a quote unquote
Xbox T I'm just saying the Pres like
what's going on and the fact that all
these reviews have been it just makes me
do Point more towards that direction I
don't know if it's really happening but
it's just like the facts behind what's
going doesn't
justify and what I'm trying to say is
if if we agree that media bias exists
and according to y'all everybody over
there is a Playstation of
why we keep going over there and about
this hit my timeline like it hit my
timeline it's not about going to it's
not about going to them not going to
them it's about we we are content
creators and podcasts talking about
issues in the industry and this is the
big is this is the second time this is
brought up this way so that it got to be
talked about it got to be talked about
it got listen F I
guess y' y'all messy y'all messy but I
feel you about y y' clearly care about
this you know what I'm
saying it's not that it's like I trly
don't care in the listic of things I
care from how it looks in the industry
okay it's like I feel like that review
system all the way up to Metacritic
should be took more seriously and I
don't feel like it is Hope serious
because of Y what everyone's doing right
hopefully that sh shine's light that
maybe that they can't do that all I will
say is let's not attack not saying that
y'all all I'm saying for anyone let's
not attack let's not personalize it and
harass that's all listen personalizing
it I'm putting it all on the whole Squad
if if people felt like I If people felt
like I was attacking people Travis and
Rob mcaffry I got love over ATT people
individually listen they know who I love
shout out to Miranda Sanchez I got love
listen sometimes you throw a grenade
sometimes you go
if people felt like I was attacking
people individually that's not that's
not what I'm doing like I even said
educate me I got a Twitter but the
problem is is the questions I'm asking I
don't think they have answers for it
word word yeah I feel listen I feel y
y'all care about this
[__] I me I'll jump in if every got we
done with that I'm with Y listen I'm
with y'all just got to keep it cons just
got to keep it consist no listen I'm
with y'all in my opinion when I see a
four first of I didn't play the game I
don't know what the game's about so I
can't talk about if the game is or the
game ain't I'm just talking about what
the screen we have not played the game I
ain't played the game so I can there's
no fraud alert on me I'm not doing that
but when I I'm with I'm on the lines of
saw when I see a four four and less to
me indicates maybe some technical issue
that prevents it from reaching its
greatness right as opposed to again I'm
looking at again this is how I view five
and six is like okay there may be no
technical issue but you boring I'm when
I read the article it felt like it was
more like hey this is regurgitated it's
more the same the graphics is good it's
short but it's more the same and maybe
you need to take some time off from a
yearly Call of Duty cycle to me the
biggest thing and again I don't know how
y'all feel about it is why was the
review split from the whole package of
the game that's that is consistent they
do do that fair enough fair enough fair
enough in my investigation they do do
that
pH thank you homework thank you for
doing your homework I again you could
tell I haven't played card in years
thank you for corre package and they
split them
individually the whole package score
it's still not out that's out yet
because the multiplayer is not out yet
right so personally going wait the
single player isn't out either right
right no single player's out next year
yeah single players out no no
this for reviewers for reviewers codes
have gone out and for the record we got
to say it here officially thank you to
the Fine friends at Activision they have
sent Lords of gaming.net a Cod Nick is U
reviewing it I kind of spoke to him
trying to get a Vibe and he was like no
it's not as bad as people saying it is
but he got his issues look out to Lords
of gaming.net we got our review Nick
Nick gonna give you the real baby so
that's all I'm saying support the real
if y'all you like what you smelling you
don't like that like them trying to save
Kong we won't save Kong Kong will die fa
enough adct corrected me
I didn't know that they've been doing
this separate for you so thank you for
that so look this is how you feel I'm
more along the lines of y'all Sol in the
S I personally when I see a four I don't
necessarily feel that means it's
technically broken in me and it's really
to an unplayable state so I am how low
four is right but I haven't played it
it's close to three but we haven't
played it you know what I'm saying
you're ridiculous anyway moving on from
the review thing the ads I I gotta come
for I'm with I'm pretty much with all of
y'all go for it Xbox Community we got to
talk yeah man we can't be Doc come to
the front of the that's the homie that's
the homie this ain't personal against no
one personally I just got to talk to
theity tell me you Ain do that L all
love death one of them man to me this
like I seen grown men watching y'all
better stick around y better not leave
there's something special at the end of
the show don't think we wrapping up
right now you're walking out the door I
done seen yall come down from a th000
down to eight some more so yall better
stick around cuz we got something for
show for show boss so like this the way
why they everybody got to come to the
front of the congregation these are the
same people that I seen watching cpan
court cases every day about the ABK
acquisition could tell you about the
verbage how the trial went yo it's going
down son popping bottles with judge
corle yeah we we got that it's going
down then in the club with Lulu Lulu ABK
yeah she's with us hey op you know me so
my whole thing is we cheering all this
stuff we we we we think this is what
needs to happen right then we hear yo
Xbox y'all got to Market more bro yo
Xbox what's going on I don't see no ST I
don't see no ads I don't even know I
ain't even got now now kid smooth you
come to the
front I love you K I'm not gonna say no
names but at the end of the day it's
like
this is what they did the deal for you
literally people are literally crying
that Xbox cannot promote there was a $69
billion investment that they worked hard
to get so my thing is again I wouldn't
know I I don't my join is on instant on
but when I saw shout out to ever s he
had the funniest tweet ever when he put
the joint up and said this what y'all
mad at and press B it's like that's
that's that's literally it and it's my
thing is you can't have it both ways you
like now you see in the globe in Vegas
you seeing Starfield buses everywhere
you see them promoting it's not the
first time they've already done this
like adct said with Forza and the other
first party games so you want that out
this is not for you this is for the new
person who's in the ecosystem that
doesn't know oh this is the new home
Call of Duty you see what I'm saying now
this is where I will be empathetic where
remember real quick please they did they
they they they couldn't Market nothing
for Call of Duty last time yes that's
the thing now you have to let the Casual
know oh you just I was ly surprised they
were able to do it like that yeah that
that shows how aggressive marketing to
me that's aggressive so the the only
thing I will be empathetic to the side
who does not like this is now if you
tell me yo we going to have a YouTube
forced video you got to wait through the
timer of a minute fair enough but the
beautiful thing about you guys
mentioning I will'll give credit is that
we have to give Xbox credit they listen
to feedback the same thing when people
complaining about Xbox go listen the
feedback change when people were
complaining about the um what is it
recently with the employees not losing
the game pass whatever Phil jump on it
is on it all I'm saying is this is part
of the process of promoting from your
investment as long as they don't go past
that I'm with y y y'all spoke up but to
me it's just like bro like we we really
bad about this like like I don't know it
just to me it doesn't make sense I I
look at the bigger picture I look at
next year when Diablo and most likely
Game Pass um Call of Duty will be in
Game Pass you need that new series s
owner to boot a series X and S to boot
it up and say wait a minute oh I ain't
got to pay
$70 I can do this right now that's
what's going to supplement what you what
it is people don't like Call of Duty the
hardcore don't like Call of Duty and
that's why they got a problem they
problem withi they problem the game
during the whole process they don't care
about the game in general yeah that's
all this exact thank you that's why
that's why I get me mad you can't you
can't had have been capping for this
deal going extra hard talking about we
won it in court and then you mad they
marketing the thing you've been fighting
and cheering for like that's crazy to me
that's wild to me so yes it's okay to to
talk about it but it's not that serious
y'all and again they are on notice based
on what you said if hey won't be no it
will be a add a forc lock in thing and
shout out to Mt cuz he do has a funny
thing it's called just the
tip just the tip right there say but
pause that pause on that but I
understand the concern but I don't think
we're we're there yeah it's not it's not
that serious to me so I don't blame
people for voicing their opinion but
let's let's let's break let's calm down
hit the power saving thing on your Xbox
and stop turning it off like a fool yeah
just you can't repeatedly say I'm hungry
and then there's food that drops on the
table and you say uhuh yeah like this is
too much not that I don't eat that not
that why you put the pork there I don't
eat cheesecake like I don't eat that so
don't take me to Cheesecake when I pop
up my TV you got mean ass jump off on
the on the joint on the small TVs when
you all it's crazy I'm rambling let's
get to Super chat's get to my part here
man we went crazy long yeah crazy long
are we though wasn't crazy I mean at
this rate right you're averaging yeah
hold on a second and then while we oh I
gota make sure not even check on I put a
poll in the chat by way make sure you
good brother um I know you got to go
please if I can do your outros cuz we
just going to be reading super chats at
this point I want to hold your hostage
oh no I'm cool I'm just chilling we're
holding your
hostage where where can the five people
find you what you got going on ham solo
what's up bro you can catch me on King's
dinner Tech no I'm
just what is going
on you see ham I I actually love you
smoked H bro we got all the we got all
the beats and the beef oh these
guys no but uh no but you can find me on
my channel I've been uh I I've been out
here doing some work for for for a
little over two years now I remember
hitting up adct and King for the first
time being like yo how do I do this and
they just like do it facts so now I'm
here doing my dang thing but but y'all
can check me out at
tsws gaming on YouTube um I'll put the
yeah let's put this in the CH let's get
know who who this guy
is bro I heard you had Sheamus Blackley
on
like two times why two time oh man two
time champ let's go yeah I had a behind
them six episode where I talked which
I've had everybody here except
s yeah
everybody everybody everybody's trying
to get the elusive
juicy
juicy every Thursday every Thursday I do
a show called behind them six where I
have different people throughout the
world of gaming and I just talk about um
their you know come up in gaming whether
they're in the business or streamers or
literally just Gamers I talk to all
sorts of people like I said I have like
everybody here on the panel except and
I've had Sheamus Blackley Jerry hook
that used to be the designer of uh of
Halo back in the day and stuff like that
so definitely come through check put the
channel in there yes I appreciate that
almost at a thous Subs oh let's get up
to a thousand how much you at right now
where you at we we at
853 oh let's go come on y'all and I've
been trying to hit a thousand before the
end of this year if I could do that that
would be an amazing real come on y'all
we got how much we still got in here we
got about 800 in here if all of y'all
just hit that button and subscribe and
let this brother ex it's free and let
that brother be able to monetize his
channel that' be a blessing man let's
show out for the real come on y'all I
appreci that y'all doubt no doubt
appreciate but it's been an amazing show
I really appreciate you uh inviting me
here and then telling me that com back
you're coming back we gonna give you the
Royal Treatment bro man I'm I'm I'm I'm
stoked um to be up here with you
Brothers you guys seen how much work and
stuff and time I put into he already
gained he a playing we going to get him
then we going to get him there what's up
I appreciate y'all just we appreciate
you just know that I always holler I
always shout out to you guys whenever
people ask me about my history is
specifically King and adct cuz I
literally talked to them folks before I
did one of my first shows that's what's
uh so so shout out to them brothers no
much love bro I love what you doing love
the way you handle the channel it and
also I love like he brings so many
different personalities on you know mean
it's a lot and he he encourages
constructive uh discussion it's not just
about even people with different I know
with different opinions or viewpoints
than him he's had a shout out to the I
had a two hour argument with uh with Jay
du with JD yo I watched that episode I
watched the J du episode so I was like
I'm tuning in for this cuz I know when
both of y' on different view points and
it was one point you was like all right
I got to jump
him I was I was done with the I was done
with I saw the moment you was so done if
you if you continue to play by his game
he will bring you down J will keep going
with the ja very good at biting and just
laughing off and now was good shout out
to job shout out to you again brother go
subscribe to the channel go check him
out we gon do these super chats and then
get up out of here and stick around
stick around we got stick around stick
around I got like 50 Subs that we ain't
playing real is
outside 100 more we at
9 come on we going to keep checking it
bro brother doing the thing let's get
him let's get him to get this bread bro
fact positive in the community too all
right we got Stitch uh remember for 47
months Lord cold okay let's completely
derail this imagine King laying on his
belly while adct feeds him some
bacon also this is the last C ATT for
Sony great show
yo King you got to hit the beat though
I'm not doing nothing to that that's I
ain't doing nothing to that first of all
your little sick mind coming up with
thoughts like
that why you why you don't like it when
it's
you why you don't like it when your door
is open you hold your stomach with your
door open why you don't like it now hey
I important that say was on your belly
get somebody freeding you some fish
sandwiches and you on your belly why we
don't make a shirt and an emoji for that
how about we don't do that you you came
up with your own
drink you want to whole beef and lift
beef up I was going to do something
totally
different that's you that's you I had
nothing to do with that you completely
influenc need 90 more subs for us let's
go let's go oh my God that was
funny continue we will not continue with
that
conversation more subs guys we have
Stitch again with $2 Super Chat PS
addict is calling him a fraud while
feeding him yes he's aling Al all right
let's get off that
timeline we Barton 661 remember three
months the ILP is a podcast
is the podcast is the event you should
subscribe to enjoy the show uh just know
that is one of the best entertaining
shows you can enjoy thank you apprciate
Primo Drake said he gonna buy that
shirt don't worry I got some shirts
coming I'm talking to graphic art you
guys are gonna get
it we have ja 82 $2 Super Chat where
does Battlenet fit in this equation o o
good question we didn't even talk about
that there so many dope yeah so much
stuff that came out of that yeah we need
80 more subs guys yeah that that's
that's a conversation to be had okay
this next one I'm going to purposely
read incorrectly because it's foul oh
wow here we go that's why I don't read I
don't pinea Grandy pinea Grandy $10
Super Chat P oh I know what you're doing
oh okay okay I got it I got it wow wow
wow demographic is changing changing
very much yes yes there we have Raheem
linor $5 Super Chat IG is about as
credible as Freddy Krueger as a babysit
y they wilding out
bro then we have Jack 82 once again $2
Super Chat adct brought out his inner
King David tell him yes ad can get there
as
well there we got s Ming with a 2B Super
Chat addict bruised throat seems to have
healed yo
oh Bru bruise that's that's very
aggressive
wow it is what it
is let's put the crest let's put the
crest in the chat for Lord bronze
Filipino Beast shout out to Filipino
Beast welcome to the round no doubt
blessings brother blessings
blessings there we have JD gamer $5
Super Chat you know what happens when
you try and get your media job to do
what your wallet can't
it doesn't work salty PlayStation fans
out here being
transparent there we have Philip carile
$5 Super Chat addict is WR some game
journals are slick when they review
games Paul I'm coming for
knes
yeah okay then we have nintend onaku $5
Super Chat at least at IGN five is not
average seven is average if you take the
mean of their scores from the last five
5 years four is completely broken which
Cod isn't yeah back to our Point yeah
that's kind of what we agree with then
we have JD gameer $5 Super Chat you
can't save Kong IGN you can't save
Kong that analogy is I can't stop
getting out of that movie out my
head only PlayStation can do that and
they've been caught lacking don't mad
about the Xbox is
competing that's we have JD gamer $5
Super Chat PlayStation laying on on the
ground panting bent over out of breath
can't breathe begging for a hint of
fresh air no games on the horizon where
the games that yeah talk about Wolverine
next
[Laughter]
year then we have Spartan 661 $2 Super
Chat they will fall or fail fall like G4
TV ripx
playay Facts remember that right they
was dope
too said we have
diaku $5 Super Chat Simon sent the
review to Dan and it was a six and Dan
said drop it two point yo yeah y
scenarios yeah I'm out of pocket right
now no we not there we
have damn oh damn there was a lot more C
uh black Ronin 357 yeah remember for 21
months Lord silver I care how major
media puts out info to the masses
there's a bias at IGN and other outlets
against Xbox recently also go king beef
go King
beef that's that's that's that's Cog Cog
king
beef you're both beefy now hey
yo we all float down here then we
have JD gamer $10 Super Chat uh uh play
play Playstation I caught you at the
scene of the crime it being lack of
media Integrity PlayStation fans still
trying to save Kong stop it he can't
breathe under water he needs to stick
with what he's good at
oh my God then we have relis riski riski
a member for four months Lord Brun so
Cog what you're saying is we need a IGN
is biased Lords of gaming art is a bias
Lords of gaming article on the website
investigator adct we need you on the
job I literally spent like an hour and a
half investigating that stuff yo and it
feels like you did and thank you for
your great investigative work he he got
his Allen wake to on
did he went to his mind
Place playing that game yo yo adct
honestly I would tell you don't that
game is
dope he said don't play a great game
no it's scary as hell time then we got
truck Neto $5 Super Chat IGN is
literally using the Starfield the
Starfield six in their uh marketing
campaign it's a commercial this is all
for traffic and I do believe in the in
the Microsoft tax I think they both gave
it seven I think it was I thought it was
seven yeah they were both sevens they
were both sevens uh then we got JD gamer
$5 Super Chat uh what's a king to a god
play PS you can't save King Kong
Godzilla put his foot on his chest is
over you remember that too right let's
start his heart
up this a get your heart
racing we got hary chan member for 28
months Lord gold to be fair other
ratings for mod Warfare 3 are fives I
expected a five out of five for this one
five out of six for this one uh it was
supposed to be a DLC no new CoD game
this year they then expanded it to a
full game IGN final score should be
higher when you talk about it's that's
the thing though subjective things when
you talk about a subjective thing should
be higher again I go back to the whole
argument of it being broken which nobody
seems to be saying it is so that I it
should be higher based on that principle
yeah definitely then we have ch Walker
member for 28 months Lord bronze Sav is
an ILP exclusive and not a
multiplay that was good that was good
that I mean yes as many people as as I
owe interviews
too and many others solo many others
yeah get in line bro yeah many people
want that JD gave her $10 super CH I'm
dead you got to stop saying it like that
people
Happ time
sorry I'm hungry I'm losing
it this is why my family does not listen
to the
show JD gamer $10 Super Chat insert Meme
here what happens when you have a fight
in water 70% of the earth and you can't
breathe under the water you get Kong and
everybody knows what happened to Kong PS
fans you can't save
Kong got to stop with that that is
hilarious started a movement another
one oh no a second that we got $2 super
chat with Su
don't said what he was on it Fu up on
that pork too [__] up on me fck up don't
fck up on me you can buck up on all the
pork you want my guy
then we have Bel remember for 25 months
bronze fellas keep doing what y'all
think love that you guys are part of my
Sunday salute to the best gaming show
the
community subcribe let's get the
subscribes up too now yeah let's go
let's get it up higher por then we got
Spartan 661 $5 chat I'm laughing at the
media bias we we enjoy the games but
that uh games that they don't
acknowledge we The Gamers have more fun
with all the games that are available
than them this is true it's something it
does true it does sometimes feel like
some of them are just not having fun and
it's like dude reviewing games man like
well if you watching your icon die you
ain't having fun
either those overwork though it's a lot
of lot of yeah yeah
yeah they watching a lot of movies oh my
Lord we got Stitch work it only worked
on one game this
year sorry King let's switch the bacon
for a salad I forgot you don't like
meaty stuff but don't worry full grown
zucchinis will be
added he let you go yeah go make it
making sure you get your veggies make
sure you get
that is right I see where y'all at with
it but yall like all the meat so God
bless he said the eggplant is right my
God yo ham I really liked you before you
showed up
here that's they going take care of you
you know you better stop before I take
them subscribers
back immediately effective
immediately
seiz seiz
him seiz th
subscribers that's it we are finally
caught up wow what episode all right oh
I think we got a poll and every about it
uh with the recent layoffs don't worry
we got something for yall and we got
stick around yes the re and future of
Destiny 2 in question what do you think
is the best course of action for the
studio to turn things around the choices
are a upper management must listen to
Dev teams and focus on the quality of
Destiny and Marathon content Choice B
scale back on Sony games as a service
and help focus on its own Survival C
separate from play station entirely C
this marriage isn't working out for both
parties or D I don't care the real
Destiny killer was Bungie all along
shout out to those in chat it was going
up late today shout out to H Solo in the
building you know what I'm saying won't
be his first time and um yeah we had a
good show y'all and again please support
Lord gaming.net there's a lot of good
content we got going please stick around
for after the show and tomorrow on the
Lords gaming.net uh Twitter account at
Lords gaming net U we got some
announcements to make there so come
check us out come support and real quick
we about to send you to a uh to a video
that uh you know King made he's very
passionate about it go there and check
it out man go there and check it out
king he got his own YouTube channel now
go over there it's called x uh Xbox
Frontline we about to send you over
there right now new ghost face wait
hold up oh
D yeah you want get it CH yeah no I got
it Joe Repco AKA flame super oh you
thought you free no one is free that's
oh they got the egg they got the the egg
plans for you in the in the zuc got no
EG shout out to shout out to I am game
master AKA Karen raisin potato
salad we got his his thing's going he's
got two minutes like we got to go we got
to go okay we out we out so Shout see
you peace
[Music]
peace
w